So, da bin ich. Moin.
Einer ist schon da. Wobei, laut
Viewer-Anzeige sind sogar schon
22 Leute da.
Äh, ich hab die...
Ah, ich seh, ich hab die Kategorie
noch gar nicht richtig eingestellt.
42 Monate, alter. Krasser Shit.
Danke schön für den Sub. Hier ist Extremely
Pogu.
Und gleichzeitig...
Easy as fuck.
Ich muss noch die Kategorie
umstellen. Seh ich grad. Ich bin doch in Just Chatting.
Nein. Michael, 50 Billionen
auch Subscribed. Dankeschön. 35 Monate.
21 Monate Streak. Geht aber hier
richtig zur Sache.
Hyper Subscriber.
Weil du's bist.
Warte mal. Wo hab ich's eigentlich?
Ich benutze das. Ich benutze...
Nee, Moment. Ich benutze das zu selten.
Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein.
Falsch, falsch.
Hyper Subscriber.
Äh, Moment.
Half-Life 1.
Kann man die Kategorie
umstellen.
So.
Excellent, excellent.
Ja.
Habt ihr gesehen? Ich hab grad ein Video hochgeladen.
Nur für den Fall...
YouTube. Nur für den Fall, der Fall, dass
irgendjemand nicht gesehen hat.
Ja, kann ja auch sein, dass euch das Thema nicht interessiert.
Das ist ja in Ordnung. Aber...
Vielleicht wisst ihr's auch gar nicht.
Ja. Hab ich. Vor...
Viertelstunde oder so. Guck hier.
YouTube.
Äh, hallo?
What the fuck?
Max...
Äh, ja, äh, genau.
Wenn man seinen eigenen Channel nicht richtig schreiben kann.
Ja, tatsächlich. Ich hab ein Video hochgeladen mal wieder.
Seit, glaub, vor 25 Tagen oder so.
War das letzte Video.
Schreiben die Leute, denn ich hab die Comments
jetzt schon ein paar Minuten nicht gelesen.
Ich würde nie mehr
als vier Tage in einer Woche arbeiten.
Fünf Tage in der Woche bieten mir zu, ich auch nicht.
Ja, seh ich genauso.
Ja. Ist das übrigens...
Ich hab eine...
Ja, gut. Da kann man nix machen.
Ähm, eine Sache ist, dass...
Eine Sache ist mir aufgefallen.
Muss ich euch jetzt grad nochmal zeigen, was hier jemand vorgerechnet hat.
Und zwar, guckt mal.
Meint ihr das stimmt?
Das müssen wir mal ausrechnen. Und zwar, er hat hier geschrieben...
Äh, bla bla bla bla
ausrechnen. Bla bla bla bla.
Hier, genau. Er hat gesagt, eine fünf Tage
Woche bedeutet in Deutschland ungefähr
ungefähr ein Verhältnis von 60%
Arbeitstage
versus 40% freie Tage.
Und eine vier Tage
Woche bedeutet in Deutschland ungefähr ein Verhältnis von
45 Arbeitstage.
Also 45% Arbeitstage
zu 55% freie Tage.
Und das heißt, durch den einen Tag bekommt
man quasi mehr freie Tage als
Arbeitstage. Also das Verhältnis hin.
War mir überhaupt nicht klar.
Man müsste das echt mal ausrechnen.
Ich bin ja so auf
den ersten...
Weißte nicht. Ich komm mir erstmal komisch vor.
Aber kann durchaus sein.
Also das fand ich tatsächlich ganz interessant.
Da hätte ich gar nicht dran gedacht, dass das so sein könnte.
Arbeitet ihr auch wirklich...
in der Summe
weniger?
Oder arbeitet ihr quasi 10 Stunden am Tag
und dafür nur 4 Tage?
Oder keine Ahnung.
Oder 9,5 oder so.
Weil ganz ehrlich, gerade auf dem Bau kann ich mir das auch
sehr schwierig vorstellen.
Also, wie will man das machen?
10 Stunden am Tag?
Ja, weiß nicht.
Also ganz ehrlich, die Diskussion
gibt es ja überall aktuell.
Letztens hat sogar unser
Arbeitsminister irgendwas zugesagt.
So 4-Tage-Woche, super Idee.
Die diskutieren alle aber
glaube ich zum größten Teil über die
4-Tage-Arbeitswoche mit
kompletter, also mit gleichbleibender
Arbeitszeit.
Und ob das so geil
ist, weiß ich nicht.
Wenn ich mir vorstelle, ich möchte
10 Tage am Tag da arbeiten.
Das wäre für mich nix.
Mit Urlaubstagen, ja klar mit Urlaubstagen.
Mit Urlaubstagen und Feiertagen.
Das ist schon klar.
Doch, man darf mehr als 8 Stunden arbeiten
im Durchschnitt.
Ich glaube, du darfst nicht mehr als
10 Stunden arbeiten.
Und du musst
11 Stunden zwischen Arbeitsende
und Arbeitsbeginn haben.
Ich glaube, das sind die einzigen Vorschriften, die es da gibt.
Ja genau, so habe ich
das auch im Kopf.
Du darfst nicht länger als 10 Stunden am Tag arbeiten
und du musst zwischen Arbeitsende und Arbeitsbeginn
11 Stunden einmal am Stück
quasi, nennen wir es mal
Pause haben.
Gut, es ist ja gut, dass wir
in Deutschland so Regelungen haben.
Ja gut, das kommt noch dazu.
Wie gesagt, ich hatte mir im Kopf, dass du
an manchen Tagen nicht länger, also dass du
insgesamt nicht länger als 10 Stunden arbeiten darfst,
sonst gibt es irgendwie Probleme.
Danke für den Sub, gar nicht gesehen.
Aber ansonsten ist ja gut, dass wir in Deutschland so
Regelungen haben.
Wir arbeiten schon genug.
Ne, mein
Fall wäre das tatsächlich auch.
Juki, danke für den Sub.
Mein Fall wäre es tatsächlich auch nicht.
Ich wüsste gar nicht, also ich kann mich schon nicht
8 Stunden richtig konzentrieren.
Weißt du gar nicht, wie ich das mit 10 Stunden machen sollte.
Also ich denke tatsächlich, dass die Zukunft
und das wird, ich meine an den Diskussionen
sieht man es doch schon, das wird die nächsten
Jahre über immer weiter zunehmen, dass
immer mehr Leute
4 Tage Woche arbeiten
und was, also den Eindruck, den
ich habe, ich kann es euch nicht bestätigen, weil ich
gehöre zwar nicht direkt zu der Generation dabei,
aber ich habe den Eindruck, dass die Generation
jetzt quasi
nach mir, wenn
ich sogar 2 nach mir, also die, die jetzt quasi
anfangen zu arbeiten und gerade
angefangen haben zu arbeiten,
also ich sage mal so bei den
jungen Leuten, sagen wir mal so 20, 20
um 20 Jahre rum,
ich glaube, die haben gar keinen Bock
mehr, 5 Tage
die Woche, 8 Stunden am Tag
durchgängig zu arbeiten. Ich glaube, die setzen ihre
Prioritäten noch anders als
meine Generation und nochmal ganz
anders als die Generation davor, weil
ganz im Ernst, bei der Generation vor mir,
also
so quasi meine Eltern
im Endeffekt,
da war es ja eigentlich fast normal,
dass dein Lebensinhalt
war, arbeiten gehen und
krass Karriere machen, zumindest bei vielen Männern
war das der Fall, für die war quasi
Karriere machen so das geilste, was man im Leben erreichen kann
und
insgesamt, weiß ich
nicht, also ich glaube,
ich bilde mir zumindest ein, dass das die Generation
heute, die jetzt quasi anfängt zu arbeiten,
auch die, die jetzt schon angefangen hat,
zu arbeiten, teilweise auch inklusive
meiner Generation schon,
bei meiner hat sich so ein bisschen angefangen, das zu wandeln,
manche sind so richtig,
du merkst es extrem, also
ich glaube, meine Generation ist
ziemlich zweigespalten, generell,
also nicht so sehr, nicht nur was
die Einstellung angeht zu
man lebt nur um arbeiten zu gehen, sondern
generell, es gibt Leute,
was ist denn meine Generation,
ich weiß gar nicht, wie man das nennt,
Ypsilon, oder so,
warum,
was auch immer,
nicht wirklich die Boomer-Generation,
aber das, wo man immer Boomer zu sagt,
also quasi, ich würde mal sagen, so Leute
zwischen jetzt 35 und
45, irgendwie so, ja,
und, wie gesagt, ich bin jetzt auch
38, 38 gerade,
und werde dieses Jahr 39,
man merkt, bei
meiner Generation ganz extrem, es gibt Leute,
die sind Ultra-Boomer,
die sind quasi wie,
komplett schon wie die Generation davor,
und es gibt Leute,
die sind irgendwie, gefühlt noch gar
nicht so alt,
so, und ich glaube, das liegt
an einem ganz
einschneidenden,
äh, wie soll man sagen, an einer ganz
einschneidenden Weggabelung,
die die in ihrem Leben getroffen haben, nämlich,
die Leute,
also, ich kann das nur von meiner Erfahrung
berichten, ja, die Leute, die mit
Technik, Internet, Computer und sowas
was am Hut haben, die sind
eigentlich nicht wirklich richtig
Boomer geworden, obwohl sie schon 38, 39,
40 sind, die Leute, die
damals gesagt haben, ah, geh mir
weg mit dem Technik-Scheiß,
das sind heute die boomerigsten
Boomer ever, die, die beim Stammtisch
sitzen und irgendwie über die Welt
philosophieren, wie geil sie Bescheid
wissen und keiner das macht,
was sie sagen,
also, das ist zumindest mein
persönlicher Eindruck, ja,
ich weiß nicht, ob das wirklich
stimmt, aber es gab halt gerade,
weil, bei meiner Generation war es
halt nun mal so, so im Alter von
so
10, 11, 12,
13, 14, 15, je nachdem,
wie alt die Leute damals
gewesen sind, als es dann langsam
salonfähig wurde, Computer
daheim zu haben, Internetanschluss daheim
zu haben und das ist immer weiter, da gibt's Leute, die sind halt
auf diesen Technik-Trend aufgesprungen und
das hat die irgendwie auch ein bisschen jung gehalten,
vor allem hat sie es so mit dem,
hat man so ein bisschen so
weiterhin Kontakt auch
so im Internet, dass man so mitbekommt,
so der Zeitgeist
der jüngeren Generation und sowas
und die, die das nicht mitbekommen haben,
die kaufen sich morgens immer noch
die Bild am Kiosk und
meckern, meckern den ganzen Tag
rum, also
du hast Leute mit
39, also 38, 39 heute,
die sind so krass Boomer,
so ungefähr wie mein Opa und du hast
welche,
ja, die sind halt wahrscheinlich eher so ein bisschen wie ich
und ich, ich, ich führe das darauf,
ich schreibe zurück, ob die damals mit Technik
aufgewachsen sind und sich dafür interessiert haben
oder nicht, alle, die gesagt haben,
Computer und Technik und Internet und so
ein neumodiger Scheiß und so, das braucht man nicht,
die sind heute alles mega
boomerische Boomer und die anderen, die sind noch
halbwegs gut dabei,
denn ja gut, Haus, Haus kaufen ist
ist auch echt in Deutschland voll
für den Arsch, also ich hab's gesehen,
ich hab's ja, ich hab's ja
im Video heute gesagt, ich hab's ja bei einem meiner ehemaligen
Ex-Kollegen mitgekriegt, der ist
ein bisschen jünger, ich glaub, der war,
als ich da weg bin, ich glaub, der war irgendwie 29, 28, 29,
ungefähr 10, 5 bis,
ja, sagen wir mal 10 Jahre jünger,
ähm,
Frau, Kind und die haben sich jetzt ein Haus
gekauft und die haben die Planung gehabt,
ja, ich sag mal, sagen wir mal, der war um die 30,
sagen wir mal so ungefähr, der hat geplant,
der, die haben sich ein Haus gekauft
und die haben geplant, für 30 Jahre
das abzubezahlen, alter, ich weiß
nicht mal, was in 5 Jahren ist,
geschweige denn, was machen die denn,
gut, vielleicht mach ich mir auch viel zu viele Gedanken
um sowas, deswegen hab ich auch keine Kinder,
heirate nicht und kauf keine Häuser und sowas,
kann ja auch sein, dass ich da einfach zu viel Bedenken
habe, aber, ähm,
ich, ich, ich seh's einfach
nicht so, weil, wie gesagt,
ich weiß schon nicht, was in 5 Jahren ist,
und, und was in
30 Jahren ist, schon mal gar nicht,
ich kann abgekratzt sein bis dahin,
ähm, man hat
keinen Bock mehr aufeinander, lässt sich scheiden
und sonst wie, was machst du damit, ich, ich
würd im Leben keinen Kredit aufnehmen für 30
Jahre Laufzeit, alter, das ist jetzt,
also ich nehm prinzipiell keine Kredite auf,
aber für 30 Jahre Laufzeit schon mal gar nicht,
du hast 40 Jahre Arbeitskunde nicht
mehr im Handy, ja, genau das mein ich,
ja, ja, korrekt, die Leute,
die dann auch sagen so nach, oh, Smartphone
so ein Kack, so, das, äh, das ist
mir nix und Social Media ist ganz böse
und, gibt's ja Leute,
die sind tatsächlich so der Meinung, weil,
so, also, muss man wirklich sagen,
Social Media, ne,
ist für'n
Arsch, also, wie die Leute
da miteinander umgehen, beziehungsweise,
wie manche
Leute da, da so
in die, wie soll man das nennen, so, so, so
in die Falle tappen, so nach dem Motto, dass sie sich
permanent mit irgendwelchen Influencer-Leuten
vergleichen müssen und, äh,
es gibt ja, es gibt sogar mittlerweile Krankheitsbezeichnungen
dafür, dass wenn die Leute
auf ihre, auf ihren Follower-Account auf Twitter
oder auf YouTube oder TikTok oder so
gucken und der Follower, der Follower-Account
ist gedroppt oder irgendwie der
Like-Account ist gedroppt, dann sind, dann geht's denen
schlecht so den Tag über, bis dann wieder irgendwie
nix, da gibt's ja tatsächlich mittlerweile schon
Krankheitsbezeichnungen für, also, das ist, das ist ziemlich
für'n Arsch, das heißt allerdings nicht,
dass es nicht auch eine sinnvolle
Seite haben kann, ja, das ganze
Rumgeflame auf Twitter und
das dumme Geschwätze,
das ist, das ist dämlich, aber
es hat ja durchaus auch seinen Sinn, ich mein,
grade bei Twitter ist der Vorteil offensichtlich, ich glaub,
du kriegst nirgendswo so schnell mit,
wenn irgendwie was passiert,
event-, auch nur aus dem
Gebieten, was dich, was dich
persönlich betrifft oder was dich persönlich
interessiert, wie auf Twitter, das ist
unglaublicher Vorteil, früher musstest
du, musstest du warten, bis man irgendeine
Nachrichtenseite darüber geschrieben hat oder sowas.
Ja, das ist halt ein bisschen, ein bisschen
für'n Arsch, dass es in Deutschland nicht so gut geht
mit den Häusern, ich mein,
ich hab mal, ich hab mal vor einer Weile
ein Video geguckt, wie gesagt, was so
Finanzberatungsanlage-Zeug geht, bin ich jetzt nicht
so der Pro, aber die haben gesagt,
dass es sich in den meisten Ländern lohnt,
ein Haus zu bauen,
weil die Leute dann quasi
mehr oder weniger das, was sie so
sonst für die Miete bezahlen würden, quasi
benutzen können, um ihren Kredit abzubezahlen
und wenn sie das dann abbezahlen
haben, gehört's ihnen halt, also im Prinzip
eigentlich nur von Vorteil, so
und das wäre wohl in nahezu jedem Land so,
nur in Deutschland wird sich's nicht lohnen, oder in
Deutschland ist eines der wenigen Länder, wo sich das nicht lohnt,
auf diese Art und Weise ein Haus zu bauen.
Ich kann es weder bestätigen
noch, keine Ahnung, entstetigen,
weil ich von so Finanzanlage-
Sachen wenig Ahnung hab, und
gut, ich mein, ich hab das Problem auch nicht, wir haben
das Haus vom Opa, aber
klang schon logisch,
ja, ja gut, ohne
Geld geht's halt nicht, ne, das ist halt
so ist es halt.
Ohne Kohle klappt das nicht.
Ich mein,
ich hab's insofern ganz gut,
ich hab
keine Kinder, oder irgendwie sonst wie was, wo ich
großartige finanzielle Verpflichtungen hätte,
und ich geb halt eigentlich auch einfach
kein Geld aus.
Ich geb halt, guck mal Leute,
für was geb ich Geld aus? Ich geb für alle
Jahre mal Geld, bisschen für den Rechner aus,
okay, letztes Jahr tatsächlich, ich hab mir
seit 20 Jahren oder so mal wieder ein Auto gekauft,
oder seit 15 Jahren, oder irgendwie so,
ist auf jeden Fall schon lange her,
hier ein Auto gekauft, also,
insofern, ich geb ja
eigentlich auch noch kaum Geld aus, aber ich mein, ich muss ja
auch nicht, ich muss ja auch keine Familie versorgen,
Kinder versorgen, oder sonst was, wo man halt die Geld,
ja gut, Stonks hab ich tatsächlich,
ich müsste grad mal gucken, wie meine Stonks laufen,
ach, wahrscheinlich jetzt hat's nicht
plus minus nicht so viel getan,
Stonks hab ich tatsächlich, ja gut, irgendwo muss ich ja
mit der Kohle hin,
aber ETF Stonks, nix
sonderlich risikoreiches, falls jemand
fragt, ja Leute,
so, wir spielen heute Half-Life weiter,
Stonks
gingen gestern richtig ab,
lass mal kurz gucken,
ne, es hat sich quasi im Lauf des Jahres
nicht allzu viel getan mit Stonks,
na, immerhin, immerhin, es ist,
wobei,
hä, was ist das für ne Kackseite, man,
die Stonks,
Stonks gingen tatsächlich recht gut rauf,
Big Stonks,
muss ich,
ich muss mal nachher in die App gucken,
Stonks ist das Beste,
Stonks,
Aktien,
ich guck mal kurz ins Handy,
warte mal, ich muss mal kurz Scalable aufmachen,
meine Stonks angucken,
äh,
hm,
ah, ne, es hat sich wieder ausgelockt,
die App sackt auch richtig,
alter, ah, ne,
ich hab mein Passwort gespeichert,
okay, nice,
oh, oh, die Stonks gingen ja mal richtig,
alter,
hä,
diesen Monat plus 1113 Euro,
Big Stonks,
Quickmuffs,
und
Amazon,
Amazon ging diesen Monat einfach mal
20%,
nice,
Pogostonks,
schon 2FA Login
Scalable aktiviert, ja,
gibt's noch nicht so lang,
nice, ja, Chat,
gut, dass ihr Bescheid gesagt habt,
jetzt weiß ich, dass ich
plus 4,45%
in diesem Monat gemacht habe,
meinen Stonks, aber nachdem ich ja meine
Stonks nicht verkaufe, äh,
hab ich die im Endeffekt ja nicht wirklich,
also, wenn das jetzt wieder runter geht, ist halt wieder weg,
und, aber wir hoffen natürlich
drauf, dass das nur, nur noch rauf geht,
bis ich dann irgendwann
mal mir ausbezahlen lasse,
Big Stonks,
wieder plus minus 0,
nee, es ist mehr als 0, äh, ich kann
mal gucken, äh,
nee, es ist, nee, nee, nee, es ist,
äh, wo steht's denn, plus ein
Jahr, plus eins,
also,
also ich hab's für das, für das Jahr,
im Jahr ist es auch plus
100, 1136,
today, Moment, Moment,
allein heute sind die Stonks um
477 Euro, also was ging,
was war denn,
was war, hab ich irgendwas
verpasst, warum sind die Stonks so krass
abgegangen,
wie sieht man bei Scalable den Gewinn in Prozent,
äh, du kannst einstellen,
wie so direkt auf der Startseite siehst du das,
das steht direkt auf der Startseite,
da steht Portfolio,
oh, und dann kannst du
auswählen,
äh, das Jahr,
seit dem Kauf, seit
gestern, seit Woche, das ist direkt auf der
Startseite ist das, ganz gut.
Tatsächlich, reich werden muss man nicht,
wichtig ist, dass man genug Geld hat,
dass man das machen kann, worauf man Bock hat,
dass man das natürlich nicht so
zu 100% alles immer
äh, ausleben kann,
was man sich
zu 100% was man sich wünscht, ja,
das ist das eine, aber,
also, ich find's halt ein Unding,
dass es Leute gibt, die 40 Stunden die Woche
schaffen müssen und am Ende des Monats
plus minus null auf dem Konto sind,
und
die quasi arbeiten gehen und nichts
was sie quasi so
erfüllt und wo sie Bock drauf
haben und was sie sich wünschen,
je machen können davon, das ist halt richtig
von Arsch, das find ich kacke, dass es da
zunehmend Leute gibt, ich hab letztens
erst wieder so ein Diagramm gesehen,
ich glaub beim Spiegel oder so,
mit, ähm,
oh, wie ist das, es gibt ja so
Geschichten mit Durchschnittsgehalt, ne, irgendwie
Mediangehalt, Durchschnittsgehalt,
und bereinigt,
ganz komisch, ich krieg's aus dem
Kopf nicht zusammen, wie der Campbell heißt,
zumindest ist es,
also man ist quasi
reich, in Anführungsstrichen,
bei viel weniger als man eigentlich denkt,
also wenn man mal reich
so definiert, so dass man quasi zu den
zu den 10% der Leute
gehört, die mehr
verdienen als der Rest, das ist viel
weniger als man denkt, das war mir
im Vorfeld auch so nicht bewusst.
AI-Hype bei
Big Tech und Einigungen ist, aha,
siehste mal,
ich hoffe die einigen sich weiter, dass die
Stonks raufgehen.
So, Leute, wir spielen noch in Half-Life
weiter, übrigens, wisst ihr was ich gerne
nach Half-Life 4 im Stream nochmal durchspielen würde?
Beziehungsweise, ich hab's ja noch gar nicht
durchgespielt, falls jemand, falls
jemand mein Video heut gesehen hat,
ähm, und das Game
noch nicht kennt, das, es
gibt tatsächlich mal ein gutes
Warhammer-Game. Ich weiß,
ich weiß eh nicht, was Wizards of the Coast
macht, oder nee, nee, nee, nicht Wizards of the Coast,
ähm, von wem
ist Warhammer?
Game Workshop, oder?
Games Workshop.
Ey, jetzt hab ich mich grad vertan.
Ähm,
jetzt hab ich mich vertan.
Mich wundert's eh, dass
es so wenig gescheite Warhammer-Games
gibt. So, und wer so auf so bisschen
Retro-Shooter-Sachen steht, oder wie das
auch neuerdings liebevoll so genannt wird,
Boomer-Shooter, was ich ja persönlich
eine ganz nice Bezeichnung finde, weil
es trifft sich einfach, ja. Ich bin
genau in dem Alter, mir gefallen so Games,
das Game dauert nicht lang.
Das würd ich auch gern on-Stream
nochmal spielen, weil es macht mega Bock, das
Kampfsystem. Es hat ein paar Probleme,
Treffer-Feedback ist nicht so geil,
aber ich find
die Optik, ich find die Optik nice,
grade halt, wenn man eben so aus der Zeit kommt von
ja, von Quake und Half-Life
und so, dann mag man solche, solche Retro-Optik.
Und das Gameplay macht Bock.
Das würd ich im,
das würd ich gern im Stream auch nochmal schnell durchflitzen.
Dauert wahrscheinlich drei Stunden oder so,
dass man durch, geht relativ, geht relativ zackig,
wenn man die Level kennt.
Ja. Doch.
Ja.
Irgendwas hab ich auch letztens gehört.
Was ich,
was ich lustig fand.
Also, erste Mal
muss ich sagen, ich fand die Witcher
Serie schon nicht sonderlich geil.
Also,
das, man konnte sich's durchaus
geben, aber
es ist so, die hohe
Kunst war das nicht. So.
Also, es war vor allem
sehr unlogisch an vielen Stellen.
Nun gut, was ich da aber
halt witzig fand, dass, also, eines der besten Sachen
für mich in der Witcher Serie war
tatsächlich der Hauptdarsteller.
Ich find, der hat das wirklich gut gemacht. Ich hab ursprünglich,
als ich den, den ersten,
diesen ersten Mini-Teaser
damals gesehen hab,
hab ich gedacht, der passt doch überhaupt nicht
als Geralt, aber ich muss sagen, das war eines der besten
Sachen an der ganzen Serie.
Und, naja, im Endeffekt
hat sich's nicht so, also,
ist die Serie nicht so gut eingeschlagen,
wie man sich das vorgestellt hat, beziehungsweise auch
so von Kritiken her und auch von Fans her
kam das jetzt nicht allzu gut an. Zumindest nach der dritten
Staffel ist er jetzt ja ausgestiegen
oder wurde gekickt oder was auch immer.
Und wisst ihr, worauf ich raus will? Wisst ihr, was ich
witzig fand?
Es haben sich Leute bei ihm
beschwert
während des Drehs, dass er so
stinkige Fürze lassen würde, würde
immer am Set.
Hab ich mir gedacht, okay, es mag ja
sein, es mag ja sein,
dass ihr Probleme hattet, dass
euer Hauptdarsteller euch zufurzt, aber ich
mein, ernsthaft, ist das irgendwas,
was man in einem öffentlichen Interview erzählen
muss? Kann man
nicht einfach mal die Fresse halten, Alter?
Ich mein, muss man
das seriously in einem Interview
sagen? Man hatte Probleme
mit dem Hauptdarsteller, weil er immer so stinkig
gefurzt hat?
Ich mein, der Typ ist eh...
Ich mein, überleg mal,
wo findest du das in
der Kombination, ja?
So den übertriebenen
Bodybuilder-Sigma-Chat-Typ,
der dann auch noch Ahnung
vom Source-Material hat
und nicht nur Ahnung,
der sich dafür auch noch interessiert
und Lore-Ahnung hat und
alles mögliche. Das ist doch eine Kombination,
die gibt's eigentlich gar nicht
normalerweise.
Also, wenn der ein bisschen was zu sagen hat bei der Warhammer-Serie,
könnte ich mir durchaus vorstellen, dass das was taugen.
Na gut, in der ersten Staffel
hat er ja quasi nur mürrisch geguckt
und irgendwie 5000 Mal Fuck gesagt.
Hast du schon mal was mit Blazer gemacht?
Gemacht ist zu viel
des Guten.
Also, wir haben
tatsächlich mal vor 4
Jahren und vor 2 Jahren
und sowas, ein bisschen was
mit Blazer gebastelt.
Ich muss aber sagen, mir hat das nicht gefallen
und mich überzeugt auch
Blazer an sich nicht sonderlich.
Keine Ahnung, was da gelaufen ist. Ich fand
bloß die Story mit dem, dass er angeblich gefurzt hat
am Set lustig.
So.
Dann gucken wir uns mal Half-Life an.
Zweite Hälfte.
HTTPS-Quickstart.
Ne, nicht HTTPS-Quickstart.
Aber die Musik
aus Moin Fips.
Also, wir sind
das letzte Mal stehen geblieben.
Weil, ich muss mal kurz hier umstellen.
Und wir müssen mal schnell die Lautstärke testen.
Ob die Lautstärke
passt.
Sagt mir mal, ob das
alles okay so ist.
Müsste, denke ich, eigentlich so
passen, ja. Vielleicht ein bisschen
laut?
Warte mal, lass mich mal kurz was checken.
Volume-Mixer.
Ne, das ist richtig. Das ist genau die richtigen
Sound-Settings vom letzten Mal auch.
Ist eigentlich gut.
Ne, ich glaube,
wenn ich rede dabei, ist es eigentlich ganz passend.
Guck mal, lass mal hier vergleichen.
Warte mal.
Warum ist es immer so schwierig?
Sound-Lautstärke in Windows.
Ja,
wir können, wir können
ein Tick, wir können ein Tick
noch leiser machen. So eins, ein Prozent
oder so. Genau, also wir sind
stehen geblieben. Da wollte ich...
Oh, kann man die Dinger...
Man kann die Dinger platt hauen.
Leute, Fisch-AI.
Oh.
Das war jetzt ziemlich bescheuert. Jetzt bin ich fast abgesoffen.
Also, wir sind an folgender
Stelle stehen geblieben. Vielleicht soll ich nochmal kurz
was zum Mod-Gesang.
Wir spielen nämlich nicht einfach Half-Life 1.
Wir spielen Half-Life 1
M-Mod.
Und zwar Half-Life 1
M-Mod. Ich schalte nochmal kurz um auf
den Desktop.
Half-Life 1 M-Mod.
Zack, gibt es kostenlos bei
Steam. Also, wenn man Bock hat, Half-Life
wieder zu spielen, beziehungsweise wer Half-Life 1
noch nie gespielt hat, dem kann ich
das wärmstens empfehlen, sich das auch gleich
mit M-Mod anzugucken.
Ich meine, das Ding hat nicht umsonst
hier übertrieben
positive
Bewertung.
Und zwar, was haben die
bei M-Mod gemacht?
Mal gucken, ob sie sich...
Die hatten doch selbst eine Liste. Genau. Also, sie haben
das Original-Game genommen und versucht
das quasi so im Sinne des Erfinders
ein bisschen zu erweitern. Also, sprich
man hat neue Waffen, man hat neue
Schussmodi für die Waffen, man hat beispielsweise
auch, ja guck mal,
man hat beispielsweise auch fürs Brecheisen,
das ist jetzt neu, das gab es im Original nicht,
fürs Brecheisen hat man jetzt so einen
Powerschlag, Sekundärmodus
und sogar noch eine dritte Attacke,
dass man das aufladen kann und
damit hauen. Weil normalerweise hat man den
Brecheisen ja immer nur
gemacht.
So, und das hat viele, die Pistole hat einen
Schalldämpfer und sowas in der Richtung. Die haben da relativ viel
geändert. Ja, also
viele Waffen sind jetzt auch Projektile
und nicht mehr normale
Hitscan-Waffen. AI ist besser,
die haben die
Animationen und
vor allem haben sie die Effekte, also
Partikeleffekte, Feuereffekte und sowas,
haben sie ziemlich verbessert. Wohlgemerkt,
das passiert alles immer noch auf
der Half-Life 1, also auf der Gold-Source-Engine.
Das ist jetzt nichts wie Black Mesa.
Black Mesa war ja quasi in
der aktuellen Source-Engine
nachgebaut, das Half-Life 1.
Das ist wirklich Half-Life 1
gemodded und einfach Sachen eingebaut, die es noch
nicht gegeben hat. Es gibt ein bisschen
mehr Content, die Level sind minimal an manchen
Stellen angepasst und
es ist eigentlich, wenn man
also für Leute, die Half-Life schon gespielt haben,
ist es nice, mal wieder zu spielen. Für neue
Leute ist es keine schlechte Idee,
damit jetzt anzufangen, wenn sie mal Half-Life
spielen wollen. Black Mesa oder
M-Mod als firstes Game? Ganz ehrlich, ich würde
sagen M-Mod, weil es
ist das originale Spiel.
Nur ein bisschen verbessert.
Oder ein bisschen modernisiert,
ein bisschen erweitert. Also ich würde auf
jeden Fall, bevor ich Black Mesa spiele,
Half-Life 1 durchspielen und
dann bietet sich M-Mod einfach an, weil es
das Gameplay ein bisschen mehr nach
2023 anfühlen lässt.
Gerade, guck mal, ich meine, Leute, man hat
sogar Beine jetzt. Gordon Freeman
hat Beine. Moment.
Man hat sogar
Beine jetzt. Hatte man im Original nicht.
Sie sieht jetzt zwar nicht sonderlich schick aus, aber man hat
Beine. Und man hat sogar eine
Crouch-Animation.
In den Beinen.
So, ich mach mal die Musik aus.
Legen wir mal los.
Ja.
Poggy Legs. Okay.
Let's go. Also wir sind stehen geblieben.
Ähm.
Okay, okay. Ich versuch das mal zu
erklären. Für alle, die Half-Life noch nicht
gespielt haben. Also die
Half-Life-Story ist ja immer hochgelobt,
aber eigentlich ist die Half-Life-Story äußerst simpel.
Und man muss auch ehrlich sagen, so
aus 2023er
Standards, oder selbst damals,
die reine Story von Half-Life
hat jetzt nicht so
viel Wahnsinnssinn ergeben, weil ich glaube,
es wurde nie erklärt,
also es wird nirgendwo erklärt,
warum Gordon Freeman als MIT
studierter Physik-Doktor
auf einmal so geil ist
mit der MP5 und
als Sniper und sowas. Und warum der
das überhaupt alles überlebt.
Gut, überleben tut das wegen seinem Schutzanzug,
aber naja. Also, die Half-Life-Story
ergibt nicht allzu viel Sinn. Zumindest
Grundstory von Half-Life
ist eigentlich relativ simpel.
Man arbeitet in einer geheimen Forschungsstation.
Es gibt ein Experiment, an dem man beteiligt ist.
Das Experiment geht schief. Deswegen
gibt's jetzt Aliens in der ganz
normalen Welt. Und
damit das Ganze nicht rauskommt, ist dann auch
die Regierung und das Militär da,
um alle zu beseitigen, die es mitbekommen haben,
um das Ganze zu vertuschen. So, das ist die
Half-Life-Story. Fertig.
Das war's im Endeffekt. So, erste Hälfte
vom Game. Was ist denn da oben los?
Ah, das sind Überreste vom Flugzeug.
Erste Hälfte vom Game
versucht man aus der kaputten Forschungsstation
zu entkommen, die bei dem Experiment
kaputt gegangen ist. Und
flüchtet, flüchtet vom Militär.
Wobei flüchtet gut gesagt ist, man bringt einfach
flüchtende Leute um, sowohl Aliens als auch
Militärleute und alles.
Und dann wird man gefangen genommen.
Man wird gefangen genommen und dann wird mit so
einer Schrottpresse reingeworfen.
Und aus der Schrottpresse sind wir das letzte
Mal geflüchtet. Da kommt man
hier aus dem
hier aus dem Rohr kommt man raus, weil man
aus der Schrottpresse rauskommt.
Und man bekommt alle Waffen abgenommen, wenn man
gefangen genommen wird. Das heißt, wir sind jetzt offiziell
quasi so in
der zweiten Hälfte des Games.
Wir haben nichts, wir haben keine Waffen.
Wir haben nur ein Brecheisen und
sonst nix.
Das heißt, wir müssen uns jetzt erstmal Waffen suchen und gucken,
wie das Ganze so weitergeht. Mehr müsst ihr
an der Stelle zu Half-Life nicht wissen.
Wie viel Spielzeit braucht man,
um das durchzuspielen? Also
das Speedrun Weltrekord liegt glaube ich bei
haben wir uns das letzte Mal angeguckt, glaube ich 26 Minuten.
Normal Casual
Playthrough würde ich sagen
brauchst du, also wenn
du es wirklich zum ersten Mal
spielst und Casual würde ich sagen
zehn, acht, neun
zehn Stunden, wenn du dir das auch
alles anguckst drum herum.
Wenn du ein bisschen schneller bist, würde ich sagen so sechs,
sechs Stunden. Und wenn du wirklich
nur durchrennst, ohne Speedrunner
zu sein, dreieinhalb.
So. Ja und in der zweiten Hälfte
muss man sagen, dreht Half-Life tatsächlich
Oh, was ist hier los?
Ah!
Ey, was soll das hier?
Ich muss mal kurz abhauen.
Nein.
Komm her.
Bam! In your face!
Und jetzt das allerwichtigste, neues Feature.
Neues Feature, hier.
Charge Attack
von M-Mod und jetzt
neue Splatter Effekte.
Wie jetzt?
Kann man nicht splattern?
Bam!
Was war Quicksave?
Erstmal
alles zersplattern.
Spielst du eigentlich auch CSGO?
Schon lange, lange hab ich, ich hab lange
kein CSGO mehr gespielt.
War das jetzt?
Ich glaube, ich muss das ablassen,
das Wasser.
Ich glaube, ich hab's kaputt gemacht.
Ja, ich bin ein Kack-Noob.
Oh!
By-Fair-Time.
Und ihr müsst wissen, Gordon Freeman ist
a highly trained professional,
wie man gerade gesehen hat.
Oh, ich bin zu langsam gewesen, Leute.
Alter, kann man
nicht mal im Flug sich...
Ich hab gesehen, hier hinten gibt's übrigens
ein bisschen Energie.
Und Leute, ich hab das Spiel, glaube ich, so oft
durchgespielt, wie kein anderes Game.
Bestimmt 35 Mal oder so.
Aber Half-Life 1 ist bestimmt
schon 5, 6, 7
Jahre her, wo ich das Original zum letzten Mal
durchgespielt hab. Deswegen hab ich richtig Bock,
das jetzt mal wieder mit Mod
durchzuspielen.
So, ich glaube, das fährt jetzt hoch hier.
Ja, Leiterphysik bei Half-Life
ist eh so ein Ding.
Ich muss jetzt warten, bis das hochgefahren ist.
Und jetzt muss man das drehen und schnell
hochklettern.
Besteht noch Hoffnung, dass Teil 3 kommt?
Äh, ehrlich gesagt, nee.
Ich glaube nicht.
Ich mein, Hoffnung, ja.
Hoffnung gibt's da immer irgendwie, aber ich glaube nicht.
Also ich glaube nicht, dass
wirklich nochmal Half-Life 3 rauskommt.
Alex gespielt?
Nee, ich hab kein...
Ist aber jetzt doch ein bisschen laut, oder?
Das dumme ist,
ich kann in OBS die Lautstärke nicht richtig
sehen. Das suckt halt mal massiv.
Ja, ein bisschen leiser müssen wir
glaub ich doch noch machen.
Lasst mal kurz was ausprobieren.
Nee, jetzt zu leise.
Jetzt ist gut.
Jetzt optimal.
Ja, Windows und
Sound-Settings. Mann, das ist echt nicht
normal. 2015
meinten die Leute, es kommt bald... Leute, die...
Die haben schon 2000...
Wann kam Half-Life 2 raus?
Ich glaube 2005 oder so.
Da haben die Leute schon gesagt, ja, ja, Episode...
Oder 2007 haben die Leute gesagt,
ja, ja, Episode 3 und so
kommt ja auch bald und...
Kam ja bis heute nicht.
So, der
Wachmann, der will mir unbedingt seine Pistole geben.
Yep.
Gif.
Wir müssen jetzt warten, bis...
Wir müssen warten, bis
er zersplattert wird.
Wenn er zersplattert wird, kann ich seine Pistole aufheben.
Sehr schön.
Sterben, please.
Oh, oh. Oh, das ist schlecht.
Huh!
Nochmal Glück gehabt. Weil...
Wer die Dinger nicht kennt, ich werd mal zeigen,
was passiert, wenn man da reinläuft.
Dann kriegt man nämlich den Kopf abgebissen.
Und...
Splattert
weg.
Die Viecher halten drei, äh, halten
glaub ich vier Schüsse aus. Ja, und das ist jetzt
auch neu in diesem Mod, Gif.
Ähm, die gibt viele Waffen,
die haben jetzt einen... Also,
Sekundärschussmodus gab's ja in Half-Life 1 auch schon
bei ganz vielen Waffen. Aber die haben jetzt
oftmals noch Attachments und sowas.
Kann man
einen Schalldämpfer draufmachen an die Pistole.
Was es bringt? Ich glaube,
es ist reine Optik. Und die Schüsse sind
leiser. Eins, zwei, drei, vier.
Ich glaube, es ist reine Optik,
es bringt einfach gar nichts.
Außer James-Bonds-Feeling.
Ach ja, und das fand ich auch nice in Half-Life,
dass man diese Kakerlaken weg...
kaputt treten kann.
Wie gesagt, ich hab das Game so ultra oft... so mega oft
durchgespielt, wie ich jünger war. Das ist nicht normal.
Trotzdem, wie gesagt, schon eine
Weile her, dass... Oh, wow!
Schon eine Weile her, dass ich... Eins, zwei,
drei, vier... dass ich zuletzt
gespielt hab.
Bin mir nicht mehr ganz sicher, wo das
jetzt lang geht.
Oh!
Achtung!
Erstmal alles zersplattern.
Die haben auf jeden Fall viel gemacht
beim Mod. Das merke ich hier allein schon
bei den ganzen Gore-Effekten.
Die, ähm...
zersplattern jetzt viel
besser als im Original.
Natürlich
ein äußerst wichtiges Feature, ich weiß.
Eins, zwei, drei,
vier.
Oh, Headcrabs, Headcrabs!
Ey!
Komm mal her!
Oh, habt ihr gesehen,
wie ich die im Flug erwischt hab?
Pog!
Ach ja, und Half-Life erschreckt einen auch mal ganz gerne mit irgendwelchen
Zombie-Viechern,
die um die Ecke
spawnen.
Äh, übrigens, es hat absolut keinen Sinn,
warum ich die zersplatter.
Das ist die zweite Hälfte.
Also, wir sind jetzt in der zweiten Hälfte vom Game.
Ah, hier ist zu.
Hier ist auch zu.
Das pickt jetzt auch
so richtig ab vom Pacing.
Geiler Satz auf Deutsch,
oder? Findet ihr es nicht auch nice,
dass das vom Pacing so ein bisschen abpickt?
Leute, ich bin verwirrt. Wo muss
man nochmal lang? Lass mal kurz.
Ähm, also für das, dass ich schon...
Also, man muss jetzt hier drüber, über diese ganzen,
über diese ganzen Dinger hier. Das, was weiß ich noch hier.
Über die ganzen Stampfer und sonst was.
Am Anfang kommt jetzt hier so ein bisschen
minimales, so wie soll man sagen,
Survival-Kram mit
zu wenig Munition und
Nahkampf bei den Gegnern.
Ich glaube, ich muss wieder zurück zum Start,
oder? Wow, wow, wow, wow.
Ich muss wieder zurück zum Start, wenn ich das richtig
im Kopf habe. Ja.
Genau.
Hier muss ich lang. Nice.
Und jetzt kommt das,
was, glaube ich, niemand in Half-Life 1
wirklich mochte.
Parkour.
Parkour-Einlagen.
Siehste?
Da passieren dann so Sachen wie hier, dass man
in die Suppe fällt.
Macht zum Glück alles nicht sonderlich viel Damage.
Also, es ist sicherlich nicht alles nice
an Half-Life 1. Ich muss sagen,
ähm,
das haben sie in Black Mesa
verbessert, so dass die, dass
die Sprungeinlagen und so nicht mal ganz so nervig
sind, aber nichtsdestotrotz,
ich mochte das
Gesamtpaket von Half-Life, weil
das, das war das erste Game
in, äh,
das war das erste Game, so was ich gespielt
habe, wo ich sagen muss, das hatte halt so eine, also
was Shooter angeht, das hatte so eine
zusammenhängende Welt. Du, du bist
quasi von Anfang bis Ende durchgelaufen,
ohne dass jetzt großartig,
dass es großartig
Level-Grenzen in dem Sinn zu sehen
gab, und
die Welt an sich
ist stimmig, und
die Abwechslung war halt auch nice.
Ja, erst aus der Forschungsstation raus,
dann wird das unterbrochen durch so
mini, mini-Survival-Path, danach
gibt's richtig, richtig krass, ey, und am Ende
kommst du in so eine Alien-Welt, also ist schon,
also Half-Life war nicht umsonst wegweisend.
Übrigens, nur, ich,
ich weiß, dass das hier jetzt einbricht.
Oh, shit, jetzt hab ich's
verkackt, ich lade nochmal schnell durch.
Das so, eigentlich sollte das hier einbrechen.
Macht's nicht, okay.
Eins, zwei, drei, vier.
Warum, warum bricht das nicht ein?
Ich bin mir, ich bin mir eigentlich relativ sicher gewesen,
dass das hier einbricht. Oh, das kommt
jetzt bestimmt noch, oder?
Ne? War das,
war das so eine reine Black Mesa-Geschichte,
dass das einbricht?
Ich, ich, ich hätte wetten können, dass
das auch eingebrochen, weil die haben doch nicht
umsonst hier unten diesen ganzen Kram hingemacht.
Guck mal, die Aliens
sind auch ziemlich pepega.
Oh.
Ach, da kann man unten drunter durch.
Gibt's hier Munition?
Ah, nice!
Okay, dann war das im Original gar nicht so,
dass die, dass die Röhre, äh,
die, die Rohre eingebrochen sind.
Sag mal.
Ich hätte wetten können, die, die Rohre sind eingebrochen,
ja. Oder vielleicht hier?
Vielleicht hier? Moment.
Wenn man, wenn man zu... Alter.
Okay.
Also die Steuerung ist teilweise...
Ich komme hier nicht weiter.
Ich bleibe an der...
Ah, hier ist die Röhre eingebrochen.
Okay. Ich habe schon
pro-proactive-agile mitgedacht,
dass die Röhre da vorne einbricht.
Hast du schon mal die
Half-Life Speedruns gesehen? Ja, habe ich. Wir haben uns
das letzte Mal nach dem Stream, haben wir uns den
aktuellen Weltrekord angeguckt. Extrem
krasser Scheiß, ey.
Also ich bin der Parkour-King,
was Half-Life angeht.
Ja, wir haben uns das letzte Mal angeguckt.
Das ist extrem krass gewesen, ey.
Vor allem, wie precise...
Könnt ihr euch noch an den Speedrun erinnern?
Wo, wo er hier diese Parcours durchgerannt
ist? Jetzt kommt,
glaube ich, das mit den, ähm,
Förderbändern, oder? Kommt das mit den Förderbändern?
Ah, ja, genau.
Oh, erst mal alles, erst mal
alles... Oh, was ist hier los?
Äh, ich bin stuck.
Dead.
Wo ist das Viech?
Gucken, ob irgendwas drin ist.
Munition und
Schild kann man immer gebrauchen.
Guck mal, das war stuck,
die Headcrab.
Ich frage mich, ja, und das habe ich mich schon,
als ich Half-Life 1 gespielt habe,
gefragt.
Ähm,
NarkoTV, danke schön für den Sub,
das habe ich schon bei Half-Life 1 gefragt, ist,
was soll das hier?
Was soll das hier? Oh, geil.
Was soll das hier eigentlich sein?
Also, ich meine,
irgendeine Müllpresse, oder
Müllbeförderungsdingsanlage,
oder was ist das eigentlich?
Ey,
meine Güte.
Ja, schön, dass du deinen Weg
hergefunden hast. Also, keine Ahnung,
was das sein soll.
Eine Müllbeförderungs-, Müllverbrennungs-
Müllpressanlage,
wo aber irgendwie aus irgendwelchen Gründen überall
Körperteile rauskommen? Hä?
Und...
Charge! Bam!
Next! Bam!
Jawoll.
Biogasanlage.
Ich glaube, da haben die da noch nicht dran gedacht.
Ach, jetzt kommt dieser, jetzt kommt dieser Unter-,
jetzt kommt dieser Part, wo man tauchen
muss, und durch diese, an den Walzen
vorbei.
Ey, gehst du weg, Headcrab?
Zum Glück habe ich genug
Schuss.
So eine Art Kläranlage aus Amerika.
Das könnte natürlich sein,
wobei man sich fragt, warum,
warum klären die da Körperteile?
Gut, bei den Amis
weiß man ja nie.
Äh, ging's hier lang?
Glaub-, ich glaube, hier ging's lang.
Gehst du weg?
Oh, hinter mir ist noch eins, shit.
Crowbar-Ninja.
Oh, oh, shit.
Fuck, schon überhaupt kein
Leben mehr, richtig. Jetzt müssen wir aber
aufpassen. Ah, gut.
Huh, Glück gehabt.
Das ist ein halb aufgeladener Automat.
Fuck.
Ja.
Okay, das haben die in dem Mod
geändert. Also, es gab im Original
schon viele Headcrabs, aber nicht
so f- What?
Hat mich bitteschön jetzt
gerade gekillt?
Die Tür? Hat mich die Tür-
Moment, das muss ich nochmal ausprobieren.
Mich hat die Tür gekillt und-
Geil.
Ich glaube, die Tür
ist ein bisschen verbuggt.
Wenn man zu nah an der Tür steht, bringt einen die Tür um.
Okay, wir gehen mal-
Wir gehen mal vorsichtig, vorsichtig.
Moment, wir sind wieder am-
Wait a minute, sind wir wieder
am Anfang?
Okay, dann mussten wir hier auf jeden Fall nicht hin,
weil wir wieder am Anfang sind.
Dann waren wir hier falsch.
Gab's hier hinten noch irgendwas?
Ich glaube,
dann müssen wir weiter tauchen. Ja, ja.
Wir müssen weiter tauchen.
Wo sind wir denn hier?
Okay, hier können wir nicht auftauchen.
Ah, jetzt sind wir durch.
Genau. Oh, Stampf-
Stampfsohr.
Wow, wow, wow, au, au, au.
Ich muss mal kurz
gucken, ich bin mir nicht sicher, wo die Viecher sind.
Alter, hier sitzen ja überall
Headcrabs.
Okay, jetzt müssen wir mal gucken, wie kriegen wir
das gebacken.
Oh Gott, ich sacke ja mal richtig krass, ey.
Okay, wie machen wir das?
Vielleicht soll ich nicht so viel-
Ah, ich weiß, wie wir das machen. Das Viech-
Das zieht mich unter Wasser nicht, oder?
Pepega-Viech.
Detke.
Weiß.
Geklitscht.
Granaten? Gab's hier nicht?
Ah, nice. Minen.
Und der Revolver.
Pogu.
Leute, jemand Bock auf eine runde pixelige Pizza?
Jetzt mal-
Ich mein, man kann wenig erkennen,
weil es ist Pixel.
Aber was würdet ihr sagen, was das ist?
Das sieht tatsächlich bisschen nach Oliven auf der Pizza aus.
Und man kann's nicht-
Oh.
Hat ein bisschen was von Oliven.
So, erst mal die
Dampfer anhalten.
Eins, zwei, drei, vier.
Ach, der-
Hä?
What the fuck?
Okay, wir müssen echt aufpassen. Ganz schön viel Damage.
Hier gehe ich nicht mehr.
Nein, nein, nein. Die Tür benutze ich nicht mehr.
Nach der letzten Tür,
die mich fast gekillt hat.
Oliven, rote Zwiebeln, Basilikum,
Oliven. Ich mag Oliven.
Pizza.
Wir brauchen einen
excellent six head half life
physics knowledge
dude.
Wie komm ich hier oben drauf? Ich brauch irgendeine Kiste,
hä?
Irgendeine Kiste. Wo gibt es eine Kiste?
Leute, wisst ihr, was meine Lieblingspizza ist?
Es kommt jetzt
bisschen random bei den ganzen Innereien,
die wir hier sehen, aber-
Drei, vier-
Wisst ihr, was meine Lieblingspizza ist?
Wahrscheinlich werden die meisten Leute sagen,
Max Monka es.
Wie kann man denn sowas essen?
Aber meine Lieblingspizza sind
Sardellen.
Au.
Rekt.
Kein Ananas.
Nee, Sardellen.
Und Sauce Hollandaise.
Ohne Mist, Sauce Hollandaise Pizza
ist auch mega. Hähnchen.
Und Sauce Hollandaise Pizza.
Das habe ich auch immer gern gegessen, als es
noch bei uns beim Lieferservice gab.
Natürlich wird der Purist jetzt sagen,
das ist aber nix,
was man auf seine Pizza machen sollte.
Da kann ich nur sagen,
man sollte auch das auf die Pizza machen,
was einem schmeckt.
Äh, ich bin mega
pepega.
Nee, das kann überhaupt nicht funktionieren
so. Sekunde, ich bin zu blöd gewesen.
Wartet mal.
So, jetzt.
Alter, ich bin
zu dumm für die Steuerung, Mann.
Okay, nice, geschafft.
Nee, aber Hähnchen-Sauce Hollandaise Pizza
ist extremly
pog.
Ah, jetzt
kommt das mit den Minen.
Moment, Headcrab?
Die muss gebatet werden, die Headcrab.
Headcrab, gebatet.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Das haben die neu gemacht.
Das war, glaube ich, im Original nicht so.
Ich habe keine Munition mehr.
Moment, wollen wir mal gucken.
Kann man hier oben drauf?
Shit.
Okay, ich hoffe...
Oh.
Ja, ja, knapp.
Shit.
Okay, das da hinten
müssen wir irgendwie killen, das Viech.
Ja, down.
Okay.
Wow, wow, wow.
Da hatte ich aber Glück.
MonkaS.
Stampfsohr.
Warum auch immer hier Stampfer sind.
Oh, oh.
Leute, wenn ich das richtig in Erinnerung
habe,
dann konnte man
hier jetzt ein bisschen
klitschen. Und zwar,
ich glaube, man konnte, wenn man es richtig
gemacht hat,
den hier killen
und dann hier durchhoppen.
Nee, aber das geht auch so.
Aber hier kommt man nicht durch.
Moment, ich habe eine Idee.
Achtung, so.
Wenn man die Controls nicht kennt,
ist halt PP gar.
What?
Wie jetzt?
Wollt ihr mich ver...
Game.
Weirdchamp.
Wollt ihr mich veräppeln?
Guckt euch das mal an.
Warum geht das nicht kaputt?
Okay, jetzt ist es kaputt.
Die Effekte
sind auch richtig cool gemacht, im Vergleich
zu den originalen Half-Life 1
Effekten. Und jetzt konnte man hier durchhoppen,
weil das war, glaube ich,
soweit ich weiß, nicht gedacht
vom...
vom Hersteller,
dass man hier durchhoppen kann.
Aber wir machen das jetzt.
Pie-Fat-Time.
Pie-Po-Fat.
Oh, nice!
Okay,
das haben sie cool designt.
Dass man rückwärts läuft von dem Zombie.
Meint ihr, das ist Absicht?
Ich glaube, das ist Absicht.
Dass man rückwärts läuft von dem Zombie
und dann rückwärts in die Shotgun läuft,
das ist bestimmt Absicht.
Wenn es Absicht ist, dann ist es extrem Pie-Fat gemacht.
Weil es geht.
Die Soundeffekte sind beste, ja.
Bin mir nicht ganz sicher,
ob wir nicht einfach hier weiterhoppen sollten.
Das ist...
Leute, das ist nicht der intended way.
Der intended way ist
der hier.
Oh.
Was zum...
Hör mal.
So ganz...
What the hell? Was ist das?
Warum trifft das nicht?
Ich bin genau drauf.
Oh, oh, oh, Mist.
Ich muss noch eine kleine
Extra-Runde machen.
Ich hab ein bisschen wenig Leben.
Wobei, wenn wir das Ding treffen...
Warten mal, wir machen das von hier.
Wir haben doch
irgendwo hier sogar so einen Sniper.
Das ist doch jetzt
in dem Mod neu. Sniper Mode
für den Revolver.
Ja, so ist gut.
Six Head Mode.
So, und hier können wir jetzt die Handgranaten
benutzen.
Oh, oh. Alter.
Achtung, jetzt. Bam.
Voll. Nice.
Jetzt haben wir's
geschafft. Jetzt geht's hier raus.
Ich renne heute wirklich
echt überall rein, wo man nur reinrennen kann.
Krieg ich der... Oh, hier unten
kriegt man Damage. Das ist
Dreckwasser. Hier bekommt man Damage.
Das ist ziemlich
dumm, dass man hier Damage bekommt.
So...
Ey, von...
What the f...
Ey, von was krieg ich Damage?
Man weiß es nicht so genau.
Highly trained professional.
So sieht's aus.
Müllpresse.
Oder...
Irgendjemand hat doch gesagt, es ist
eine Ami-Kläranlage, oder?
Habt ihr eine sinnvolle Erklärung
für eine... für sowas
in einer Kläranlage?
Vielleicht bin ich einfach nur blöd und
jede Kläranlage hat sowas.
Ey...
What the f... Ey!
Wie zum Teufel soll ich das überleben
hier alles?
Kann man da irgendwie... Ah, okay.
Hier kann man so eine Zwischenlandung machen.
Weil ansonsten...
Leute, wir haben ein kleines...
Wir haben ein kleines Problem.
Ich muss hier irgendwie ohne Munition durchkommen.
Haben wir vielleicht hier irgendwo
so ein bisschen Muni?
Ich hab genau einen Schuss noch in der Pistole.
Nice!
Sehr gut!
Läuft, läuft bei uns.
Läuft richtig gut.
Pass mal auf, der Vichy badet.
Ey...
Ja, ich hab ihn an...
Ah, lol.
Bad Crap.
Das dumme ist nur, dass hier keine Munition liegt.
Kann ich das...
Oh, oh, oh shit!
Wir sind dead.
Oder nicht?
Wir sind dead, aber...
Pass mal auf, wir machen jetzt Five Head Time.
Wir laden eine Granate auf, werfen die Granate rein
und gehen wieder runter.
Und bam, jetzt sollte hoffentlich alles tot sein.
Nee, nicht.
Okay.
Alles dead?
So muss das sein.
Wir haben aber selbst...
Okay, wir haben keine Munition, Leute.
Ich bin mir nicht mehr sicher,
wie man das hier macht ohne Munition.
Kann man übers Dach irgendwie?
Normalerweise muss man, glaube ich,
diesen...
Das Ding anballern, da hinten.
Vielleicht kann man es auch irgendwie jumpen.
Weil wir haben ja keine Munition.
Kann man das auch irgendwie jumpen?
Vielleicht kann man das auch irgendwie jumpen.
Weil wir haben ja keine Munition.
Kann man das irgendwie...
Shit.
Moment, Moment, Moment.
In der Situation war ich noch nie.
Okay.
Doch, mein Revolver ist leer.
Ach nee, ist nicht leer.
Ich dachte irgendwie, der ist leer.
Okay, mal kurz leben.
Nice, wieder 30%.
Okay, ein Schuss hätte gereicht.
Ich hätte es mir sparen können,
das rumgestellte.
Aber okay.
Fünf leben noch.
Wir müssen uns jetzt mal ein bisschen
zusammenraffen hier.
Ah, nächstes Kapitel.
Ich bin dumm, wir haben jetzt sogar noch eine Shotgun.
Die habe ich ja ganz vergessen.
Easy, die brauchen wir jetzt auch.
Ich habe, als ich das erste Mal
das Game gespielt habe,
ich habe immer versucht, ob man dieses Ding hier nicht
irgendwie aufbekommt.
Aber nee, man...
Das ist neu.
Ich bin mir relativ sicher,
das ging im Original nicht.
Guck mal, kann der mit dem Fuß schießen?
Der hätte...
Das ist natürlich sinnlose Munitionverschwendung,
das machen wir nicht.
Ich bin mir relativ sicher,
dass das im Original...
Das ging wirklich?
Das ist mir neu.
Man lernt nicht aus.
Nee, im Leben war das doch
im Original nicht so.
War das wirklich so?
Dass das Viech dann herausgekommen ist?
Okay, vielleicht
ist es einfach zu lang her.
Wo ich das Original gespielt habe.
Aber ich bilde mir ein,
man konnte das nicht.
Konnte das nicht killen.
Wir haben kaum noch Leben, Alter.
Highly trained professional ist unterwegs.
Ah, wir kriegen auch die Minen. Sehr schön.
Ich bräuchte mal ein bisschen Schild
und mal ein bisschen Leben.
Moin, was geht?
Sorry, du kannst nix für,
aber ich brauch Munition.
Sehr schön, jetzt erstmal
alle Headcrabs zerstören.
Ja, vielleicht ist es wirklich
zu lang her, dass ich das Original gespielt habe.
Die letzten Male habe ich nur
Black Mesa gespielt. Black Mesa habe ich auch so
durchgespielt insgesamt.
Und vielleicht
bringe ich es einfach durcheinander gerade.
Ist ja mü...
Wow!
Ich muss noch mal laden.
Ich bin dead.
Ich habe zu wenig Leben.
So, wir müssen den Typ jetzt one-shotten,
wenn er um die Ecke kommt.
Oder, wenn wir Glück haben und er ist gespawnt,
können wir ihn wallbangen mit einer Granate.
Predicted.
In welchem Chapter befindet...
Äh, das ist Questionable...
Questionable Ethics heißt das, glaube ich,
das Chapter.
Also, ich krieg die...
Achso, hier, guck mal.
Tatsächlich, guck mal.
Ich weiß sogar aus dem Kopf, wie die Chapter heißen.
Questionable Ethics, ja.
Steht nicht da.
Jawoll, MP5. Easy Win.
Das ist jetzt übrigens auch neu
in dem Mod. Im originalen Half-Life
hat die MP5 ja den normalen...
Also, ich zeig das mal kurz. Du hast den normalen
Feuermodus. Du hast... Ach, ich hab keine Granaten.
Rechtsklick ist ein Granatwerfer.
Und jetzt mit dem Mod kannst du noch
Stealth-Mode, den Stealth-Mode
aktivieren.
Dann hört sich das Gesilenced an.
Meine persönliche Vermutung ist,
ich hab's Damage-technisch nicht ausprobiert,
aber meine Vermutung ist, der Damage
zwischen Silencer und nicht-Silencer
ist exakt das gleiche.
Ex...
Op.
Du, du, du.
Aha.
Jetzt probieren wir mal aus, ob wir
die Typen-Chibaten können.
Seid ihr blind oder was?
Ey, ich bin hier.
Poggers AI.
Ich will euch jetzt...
Geil gemacht, Max.
Sehr schlau. Sehr schlau.
Jetzt aber.
Bam.
Jawoll. Das...
Das ist echt...
Das ist eigentlich das, was ich die ganze Zeit schon machen wollte.
Ich wollte hier reinlocken, die Granate.
So, jetzt haben wir...
Jetzt haben wir nahezu unendlich Muni.
Dadurch, dass Soldaten hier am Start... Oh, shit.
Passt mal auf. Sniper-Mode aktiviert.
Get rekt.
Outmoved.
Outmoved, outgunned, outplayed.
Hier, die Leute.
So, hier kommen wir nicht raus.
Ich glaub, das ist die Lobby, wo wir dann zum Schluss raus müssen.
Hallo, Barney.
Was ist so los hier?
Oh, siehst nicht gut aus, Barney.
Sieht gar nicht gut aus.
Ziemlich fertig aus.
Ich glaube,
übrigens, dass es
von der Half-Life-Lore her so ist,
dass der allererste Wachmann,
den man
im Tunnel sieht, noch
in der Train-Sequenz,
dass das lore-technisch
offiziell Barney sein soll.
Also, den man im Intro sieht.
Alle anderen sehen zwar genauso aus, aber
das ist nicht Barney.
Barney ist nur der erste. Aber gut, Half-Life-Lore,
und Half-Life-Story,
nach all den Jahren, wahrscheinlich
gibt das alles nicht so viel Sinn.
Ach, jetzt gibt's die Viecher.
Wer soll Barney sein? Ja, der Wachmann.
Äh.
Äh. Äh.
Das ist auch im Original nicht so.
Das ist definitiv, Leute,
das ist garantiert im Original nicht so.
Aber tausendprozentig ist das im Original
nicht so. Also, wer mir sagt,
dass das im Original so ist, der hat's im Original
nie gespielt. Oder ihr wollt mich einfach nur ganz
krass chibäden.
Also, falls ihr's grad nicht mitgekriegt habt, das Alien
hat den Knopf gedrückt für den Versuch.
Hier. So wie ich das auch machen kann.
Das, das war im
Original nicht so. Das Viech gab's hier nicht.
Ich glaub, man konnte selbst
im Original hier draufdrücken, konnte so ein paar Viecher
in die Luft sprengen.
Aber so rum war das auf jeden Fall nicht.
Jetzt gibt es gleich die...
Man könnte sagen,
die unbeliebteste Waffe
in ganz Half-Life.
Es gibt so komische
Explodier-
und...
weiß ich so.
Beiß- und Explodier-Aliens.
Die kann man,
guck hier, so funktioniert das.
Die kann man auf die Gegner werfen
und die gehen dann auf die Gegner und machen die Gegner kaputt,
wenn sie nicht rumbacken.
Das Problem ist nur, wenn die Gegner down
sind, und ich zeige euch das mal,
und man geht dahin,
dann gehen sie...
Dann gehen sie auf einen selbst, ja.
Deswegen muss man immer ganz weit
wegstehen, warten bis die
Viecher, bis die Viecher tot sind.
Guck, guck, genau das meine ich.
Und dann explodieren
sie in einer Zeit.
So, wir nehmen mal die Shotgun.
Kann man? Okay, okay.
Passt mal auf. Ich hoffe,
man kann. Komm um die Ecke.
Komm um die Ecke. Komm um die Ecke.
Komm um die Ecke.
Ja, egal.
So geht es auch.
Die Explosionen sehen viel besser aus,
wie noch mit original Half-Life.
Und auch die, auch die Feuereffekte.
Alter, was eine Sauerei.
Wo geht es hier lang?
Ah, da kommen wir
gerade, da kommen wir doch gerade her, oder?
Ja, ja, hier kommen wir her.
Eins, zwei, drei, vier.
So.
Wir snipen jetzt mal welche
mit dem Crossbow.
Bin mal gespannt, haben die?
Ne, es gibt keinen dritten Feuermodus
für den Crossbow.
Ähm, Leute, ist
ist der Pfeil nicht falsch herum
auf dem
Crossbow?
Ach ne, das, okay, doch nicht.
Die Spitze ist vorne, das sollen so eine Art Federn
von dem Pfeil sein.
Achtung, Achtung, Schneiber.
Massive Schneiber.
Nichts da.
Okay.
Stelzmodus.
Ich hör da was laufen.
Ich bin begeistert,
wie gut man einfach die Gegner
hört. Man hat den halt einfach
drei Kilometer schon gehört.
Und das im Jahr 2023.
Also, ich hätte das nicht nach
Call of Duty Vanguard und MW1 nicht für möglich
gehalten, dass man noch 2023
Games spielen kann, die
Fußschritte von Gegnern
ortbar haben.
Wir müssen mal kurz hier durchstelzen.
Die haben mich noch nicht bemerkt.
Ah, komm, ein Treffer
noch, bam.
Die haben mich noch nicht bemerkt, ich will
die snipen.
Oh, noch besser.
Ich will euch snipen. Ihr seid doch hier oben, oder?
Lul.
Was, was, ne Munitionsverschwendung?
Für ne
Headcrab, nen Pfeil.
Kann es sein, dass hier noch gar
keine Soldaten sind, erst wenn man
Ja, ich glaube, man muss
erst die Dinger in die Luft sprengen.
Ja.
Schreck.
Die sterben nicht mehr.
Oh, hab ich die grad wallbanged?
Oder nicht wallbanged,
collateral, collateral damaged?
Okay, Viech, du willst bestimmt hier?
Ey, ich bin hier oben, kommt mal hoch.
Ihr dürft euch gerne gegenseitig killen, hab ich kein Problem
mit.
Aber du willst, du willst hier lang.
Nee, nee, Viech, Viech, du willst hier lang.
Auf jeden Fall, du willst unbedingt hier lang.
Hier, hier lang, komm mal her.
Komm her.
Her, komm.
Mensch.
Okay, das hat keinen Bock.
Das ist gebuggt.
Dead.
Ja, haben wir leider so ne Mine verschenkt.
Wow.
Das ist jetzt Neues, oder?
Dead.
Nice.
Kann man die Dinger wieder einsammeln?
Leider nicht.
Weiß jemand, ob man die Dinger in Plank Mesa einsammeln
konnte wieder?
Die Minen? Bin mir nicht sicher.
Wäre auf jeden Fall
ein sehr sinnvolles Feature.
Ah, noch mehr Minen.
Explosive Kisten.
Beste.
Sie können in ihre eigenen Minen rennen.
Excellent.
Äußerst sinnvoll hier Kisten hinzustellen.
Aber das ist man ja gewohnt.
In Half-Life.
Dass an vielen Stellen einfach random Kisten stehen,
die keinen Sinn machen.
Wow.
Der hat sich nicht headshotten lassen.
Ah, fast.
Ah, jetzt kommt dieses Ding.
Da hab ich mich auch gefragt,
wo ich noch ein bisschen kleiner war und das Game gespielt hab.
Welchen Sinn hat dieser Raum?
Ein Raum mit so einem
rumfahrenden
gefährlichen Ding.
Warum baut man diesen Raum?
Erstmal eine Runde.
Headcrabs entsorgen.
Noch mehr Headcrabs entsorgen.
Und Zombies entsorgen.
Komm her. Bäm.
Und ganz wichtig.
Erstmal
splattern.
Ja in Black Mesa ist es ein
Operationsroboter.
Warum splatterst du nicht?
Aha.
Beste.
Jeder ernsthafte Wissenschaftler
hat so einen Raum um die eigene Schöpfung.
Dafür würde er sogar Sinn machen.
Sex.
Okay, da kommen wir her.
Wow.
Oh shit.
What the hell? Wo kommt denn das Zeug her?
Jetzt bräuchten wir...
Wir bräuchten den Dead Space Flammenwerfer.
What the?
Das sind Mini Headcrabs.
Die sieht man ja überhaupt nicht.
Okay, die kann man aber bestimmt
mit der...
Komm her.
Genau.
Einfach zerquetschen
mit der Brechstange.
Ja, guck mal.
Da sind noch mehr.
Eins, zwei, drei.
Das sind Mini Shelobs.
Guck mal.
Nee, Moment. Shelob war die aus
Herr der Ringe, oder?
Sorry, sorry.
Nee, nee, nee.
Shelob ist die Spinne aus Herr der Ringe.
Wie hieß das Viech? Gonarch.
Gonarch Slayer. Mini Gonarch.
Wir sind ja in Half-Life.
Ja gut.
Kann man sich schon mal vertun.
Hier müssen wir später lang.
Ich lasse die Dinger extra da, damit ich mir das merken kann,
dass wir hier noch nicht gewesen sind.
Wie hieß das Ding in Half-Life?
Die Spinnenviech.
Was dann, was später...
Oh, Sekunde.
Ich werde mal die Viecher
platt machen, weil
ich glaube die Soldaten sind nicht so das Problem gerade.
Hey!
Kannst du mich mal in Ruhe lassen?
Was ist das hier?
Nice Aim.
Vielleicht habe ich Glück und die sind so doof und checken es nicht,
dass ich auf sie schieße gerade.
Es sieht danach aus, als kapieren sie es nicht.
Guck mal.
Die kapieren es nicht.
Pepega Marines.
Jetzt kommt der Kram
mit dem Laser.
Ich erinnere mich.
Wenn man jetzt hier um die Ecke läuft, links rum,
da kommen jetzt die Typen,
die sich selbst mit einer Waffe in die Luft sprengen.
Ja.
Hier, pass auf.
Das ist eines der geilsten Waffen im Game.
Ist auch die beste, um Helis
zu killen und sowas.
Oh, alles dead.
Also ich muss ja sagen,
die KI, also die verbessert wurde.
Vielleicht ist es ja auch
normal, dass wenn man beschossen wird, dass man
stehen bleibt.
Aber ich muss sagen, von der verbesserten KI...
Sag mal.
Die KI ist doch nicht verbessert, Leute.
Hi.
Geiler Dude.
Okay, es kann, Leute, es kann durchaus
sein, dass die KI im Original auch so
Pepega war. Man war damals extrem
beeindruckt. Wisst ihr noch,
falls jemand, falls jemand so
1998 in Trierum dabei war,
wisst ihr noch, von welchem anderen Game man
sowohl grafisch, als auch
KI-technisch damals übelst
beeindruckt gewesen ist?
Neben Half-Life? Kam ungefähr zur gleichen
Zeitraum, Zeitraum, ich glaube
ein Jahr früher.
Hat übrigens keinen Sinn, dass ich das draufkloppe gerade.
System Shock.
Äh...
Nee, nicht wirklich.
Von Unreal.
Also Unreal grafisch, allerdings die KI war
damals auch extrem nice.
Und die haben...
Also Unreal wurde
auch ziemlich für die KI
abgefeiert.
Allerdings war die Half-Life
KI damals noch ein Tick besser.
Man hat es jetzt dazu wirklich erkannt.
Ehrlich gesagt.
Die KI macht auch ziemliche
Aussetzer gerade.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das ein Bug im Mod ist,
oder ob die KI wirklich so blöd gewesen ist
im Original.
Also die Half-Life 2 KI ist auf jeden Fall
oder AI für die
Soldaten ist auf jeden Fall deutlich
cleverer als das hier gerade.
Ähm...
Habe ich jetzt eigentlich alles?
War es das?
Ich glaube, ich habe alles.
Ja.
So, jetzt erstmal ein Loch in die Wand brennen.
Ah, nee.
Moment.
Moment, ich habe was.
Siehste?
Wie gesagt, 35 Mal
gespielt mindestens, aber
das weiß ich natürlich nicht mehr.
Man muss die Kiste hier...
Das war quasi eines
der ersten Physikrätsel, was sie dann
in Half-Life 2 auf die Spitze
getrieben haben.
Kann man das überhaupt
Physikrätsel nennen? Nicht wirklich, oder?
Äh...
So...
Umgebungsrätsel.
Ist ja nicht wirklich ein Physikrätsel.
Ist ja alles gescriptet.
So eine richtig gescheite
Physikengine hat das Game ja nicht.
Ich meine, guckt euch das mal an.
Seht ihr, wie die Kiste rumspackt?
Und wie kacke ich...
Wie ich mich nicht bewegen kann, wenn ich die Kiste schiebe
und sowas.
Also Physikengine hat das Game.
Keine wirklich...
Durchdachte.
Aber ey, das ist jetzt von 1998.
Man kann es ja auch irgendwie übertreiben
mit den Ansprüchen.
Übrigens, System Shock
gab es letztens in Remake.
Habt ihr das gespielt?
Oder hat sich das jemand
schon angeschaut?
Ich habe es mir gekauft
und bin so die ersten paar Räume lang
und ich muss sagen, atmosphärisch ist das extrem nice.
Ich habe nie ausprobiert,
was passiert,
wenn die Wissenschaftler sterben
von diesem Ding.
Okay.
Oder was...
Man kann tatsächlich an der Stelle
Game Over gehen.
Gibt es neuere Unreal Spiele?
Es gibt
Unreal 1, Unreal 2, Unreal Tournament,
Unreal Tournament 2004
und das neue Unreal Tournament
hatten sie ja die Entwicklung eingestellt.
Weil sie jetzt
Fortnite haben.
Und Fortnite einfach viel geiler ist.
Für die, was Money verdienen
angeht, als Unreal
wahrscheinlich je gewesen ist.
Ja, auf. Nee, nee, du waitest nicht
vor deinen Colleagues. Du kommst jetzt mit.
Mitkommen?
Du auch mitkommen.
Hier, auf Leute. Hopp, hopp.
Hopp. Move.
Moved euch.
Ach gut, da kommst halt nur du mit.
Das ist mir auch egal. Hauptsache einer kommt mit.
Einer kommt mit und jetzt müssen wir, wenn ich das richtig
im Kopf habe, wir müssen wieder runter.
Irgendwie.
Wo ging es runter?
Nein.
What the f... Warum ist da gerade
was expl...
Hä?
Hätte ich dem
nachlaufen müssen?
Der ist vorne weg gerannt
und ist gestorben.
So, komm mit.
Ja, komm mit.
Komm mit, komm mit.
Nee, jetzt rennt er nicht vorne weg.
So, weil ich glaube, wir müssen jetzt
in den Gang zurück.
Oh shit, Alter, nee.
Fuck, wo mussten wir...
Nee, hier raus können wir doch jetzt, oder?
Hier. Da.
Mach auf.
Ja. C U.
Ich fass es nicht, Leute.
Ich bin, ich bin geklitscht
in der Tür. Nochmal.
Okay.
Achtung.
Ja, der Mod ist noch nicht so
ganz bugfrei.
Müssen wir mal gucken, hier sind jetzt...
Hier sind jetzt
Sentry Guns draußen.
Doch, hier sind Sentry Guns,
ne?
Kann man hier rüber?
Kann man hier irgendwie...
Guck mal, hier kann man oben langlaufen.
Glaube, irgendwie.
Wir müssen mal kurz die Sentry Gun ausschalten, da oben.
Was?
So.
Alter, der hält aber ganz gut
was aus hier.
Oh, noch ne Sentry Gun. Shit.
Der hat gehe...
Nein, doch nicht der.
Jetzt aber.
Nice. Ähm...
Wie kommt man hier rüber?
Ich hätte jetzt ja mal gesagt... Ups.
Jetzt habe ich rausgetappt.
Ich würde ja sagen, irgendwie hier so.
Aber das scheint ja so nicht zu klappen.
Ne.
Kommt man hier irgendwie rauf? Hier so? Da so?
Irgendwo da?
Weil es ist eindeutig
gedacht, dass man hier irgendwie rauf kommt.
Wenn es nämlich nicht gedacht wäre, dass man hier rauf
kommt, dann würde auf der
Seite kein Revolver liegen.
Kennst du auch zufällig ein paar ältere
Spiele?
Ich bin 1984 geboren, ich kenne jede Menge
ältere Spiele.
Muss man vielleicht hier irgendwie
Anlauf nehmen? Oder hat einer
eine schlaue Idee, wie man hier hoch kommt?
Ne, so nicht.
Ist auch egal. Ich meine, es ist
jetzt nicht so, als bräuchten wir das unbedingt.
Oh.
In your face.
Vielleicht den
Zaun zerstören?
Das sieht nicht so aus, wie ne...
wie was, was man zerstören könnte.
Gravity... Mir bräuchte jetzt die
Gravity Gun.
Bestimmt Bait.
Ja, wahrscheinlich ist es echt Bait.
She Baited.
Die haben glaube ich auch die
Crossbow Ammo ein bisschen
runtergeschraubt. Ich bilde mir ein,
im Original hatte man mehr
Crossbow Ammo.
Achtung, Achtung, jetzt bin ich so langsam.
Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein.
Achtung, ich weiß, dass
sie Gegner sind.
Ja, damit habt ihr nicht gerechnet.
Da hat sich das MIT
Studium richtig gelohnt.
Ich meine, es gab irgendwo einen Tunnel
hinter den Stromkästen. Okay.
Ja, aber jetzt sind wir schon im anderen Level.
Hier wird das nirgendwo mehr sein.
Heli stellt!
Ich bin mir nicht mehr sicher, ob wir den Heli
hier jetzt killen mussten auf der Map.
Oder ob das erst später kommt.
Doch, ich glaube, wir können den Heli hier killen.
Easy.
Alles.
Das ist die geilste Waffe.
Die absolute Lieblingswaffe in Half-Life.
Wie heißt das Ding? Gauss Cannon, oder?
Einfach aufgeladen, alles
in die Luft gesprengt. Easy.
Okay, ja.
Genauso hätte ich das auch gebaut hier.
Äh.
Also, so ganz fehlerfrei
ist der Mod nicht.
Ich glaube nicht, dass die Fische normalerweise
so an der Oberfläche geschwommen sind,
dass man sie killen kann.
Ähm.
Jetzt müssen wir mal hier...
Oh, ich hasse sowas, ey.
Ihr kennt mich, ne?
Ihr wisst, dass ich tiefe, trübe, unbekannte
Gewässer und so halt überhaupt nicht mag.
Also auch real life.
Ich kann halt auch nicht im See richtig
schwimmen gehen, ohne dass ich
ein blödes Gefühl hab.
Okay, wir müssen...
Ja, ist ja gut,
Mann. Okay.
Wir haben zwei Schuss mit dem Bogen,
um das Viech zu killen.
Wo bist du?
Eins?
Komm her.
Zwei?
Wie, das lebt noch?
Shit.
So funktioniert das schon mal nicht.
Okay, wir müssen uns beeilen.
Wir tauchen jetzt einfach durch.
Shit, wir können nicht durchtauchen.
Ah, guck mal, das ist Pepega, das Viech.
Das ist verbuggt, das ist verbuggt.
Keckel.
Sehr schön.
Er sieht etwas geschockt aus.
Kann man das Viech splattern?
Ich glaube, das geht nicht.
Ich glaube, das kann man nicht kaputt.
Es sieht... Ach ja, jetzt...
Jetzt ist auf einmal...
Okay, nice.
So kann man es auch machen.
Wenn man zu blöd ist,
das Game zu spielen, kann man einfach
die Gegner klitschen.
Half life Trauma. Ja, ist echt ein bisschen so.
Ah, ja.
Oh.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Muss nochmal kurz auftauchen.
Gordon,
schwimm mal ein bisschen schneller.
Luft holen.
Ja, ja, gut, gut.
Weiter Luft holen.
Okay, genug Luft geholt.
Andere Seite ist es.
Äh.
Moment, Moment, Moment.
Ich habe etwas vergessen.
Ich weiß nicht, wie das funktioniert.
Habe ich den Motor noch nie angemacht?
Ist es verbuggt?
Fragezeichen.
Oder muss ich noch irgendwie Strom einschalten?
Oder sowas?
Oh, das weiß ich jetzt gar nicht.
Ich meine, ich komme ja nicht mehr raus.
Gab es hier...
Moment, musste ich hier irgendwas noch machen, was ich nicht mehr weiß?
Ähm.
Sicher...
Ich glaube, da kann man nicht durchtauchen, so.
Oder ich bin...
Oder ich bin zu blöd.
Und ich muss es einfach mal probieren, durchzutauchen.
Es kann ja auch sein, dass es einfach nur so aussieht, als kann man nicht durch.
Ich meine, das Game ist 20 Jahre alt.
Äh.
Ne, 25 Jahre alt.
Okay, ich habe nichts gesagt. Easy.
Geht einfach.
Ich hätte echt gedacht, man muss die Dinger einschalten.
Übrigens, guckt mal, wie nice die Beleuchtung von diesem Tor ist.
So richtig...
So richtig passend für unter Wasser.
Dass es unter Wasser genauso aussieht wie über Wasser.
Und gut beleuchtet ist.
Headcrab.
Hier ist bestimmt eine Headcrab drinne.
Wetter mit euch, hier kommt gleich eine Headcrab.
Oder auch nicht.
Muss.
Echt nicht.
Ich hätte gedacht, die wollen uns mit irgendeiner Headcrab schocken.
Ah.
Gute AGP Grafikkarte.
Bleibst du...
Stehen bleiben.
Jetzt kommt das mit den Minen.
Jetzt muss man aufpassen.
Weg.
Musste man hier nochmal einen Heli killen?
Oh ne, please.
Ne nochmal einen Heli.
Ich glaube wir sind richtig.
Hier gab es auch sonst nichts.
Wenn ich das richtig im Kopf habe.
Man konnte hier nur durch.
Ich glaube der Heli ist dann auch wieder...
Oh shit.
Hier waren so Tentakel-Teile.
Da kann ich mich überhaupt nicht mehr dran erinnern.
Leute, hat jemand das Original gespielt?
Tentakel-Dinger.
Ist mir...
Ist mir komplett neu.
Tentakel-Shells.
Ah ja, ja.
Und die Preisfrage ist auch...
Ah ja.
Die Preisfrage ist auch, wo muss ich denn...
Wo muss ich denn eigentlich hin?
Ja, mein Gott.
Heli ist gut.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wo ich hin muss.
Sag mal.
Hier ist doch nichts, oder?
Muss ich den Heli killen?
Okay, Heli ist down.
Okay.
Den Tentakel kann man nicht zerstören.
Die sind unzerstörbar.
Meines Wissens nach.
Sehr schlau, Max.
Ja, da ist er wieder.
Okay.
Vielleicht ist es auch egal.
Und ich kann wieder zurück?
Weil der Heli jetzt weg ist?
Und ich muss gar nicht weiter,
sondern hier?
Ich muss hier weiter, ne?
Ich musste da gar nicht hin.
Das war einfach G-Bait mit dem Tentakel.
Oh, sind ganz schön viele.
Bam!
In your face. Next.
Also...
Gordon Freeman is a highly trained professional.
Aber was sind denn dann die Marines hier?
Muni.
Aha, Mine.
Beste Minen-Posi hier hinten.
Wie kommen wir denn hier vorbei?
So vielleicht.
Ah, yes.
Das ist auch reichlich unsinnig, oder?
Au!
Es lohnt sich ja überhaupt nicht, das Zeug zu killen.
So, was haben wir denn hier gemacht?
Wir haben Storm Train Hatch.
Haben wir.
Plastikkaktus.
1998 Level Design.
Was hier?
Jetzt kommt das mit den Minen, genau.
Minen-Stelz.
Das ging so glaube ich nicht.
Ich glaube das einzige, was er machen konnte ist...
Wir müssen da hinten hin.
Meins.
Ach, hier hätte ich auch lang gekonnt.
Hier ist der Tentakel-Stelz.
Ja meine Güte, im Leben wäre ich nicht drauf gekommen,
dass man hier durchkriechen kann, Mann.
So, jetzt müssen wir an den...
an den Minen vorbei.
Ok, hier war eine.
Ok, wo? Da hinten müssen wir hin.
Da müssen wir hin.
Kommen wir...
Kommen wir vielleicht einfach hier vorbei?
Was? Ok, was?
Wie haben die sich gedacht, dass man hier durchkommt?
Ah, so.
Ok, nice.
Gute Idee.
Einfach Granatwerfer benutzen.
Und alles in Luft sprengen.
Ok, jetzt müssen wir mal ein paar snipen
von hier oben. Nein.
Wissen wir nicht.
Wo sind die...
Wo ist die Sentry-Gun?
Da ist Sentry-Gun down.
Da oben den headshotten wir jetzt.
Das juckt ihn nicht.
Aber ein Double-Headshot juckt ihn.
So, wenn ich das richtig
hin und ab, muss man hier hinten rum.
Au, au, au.
Dead.
Das haben die Mod auch gut gemacht.
Guck mal, die splattern jetzt
anatomisch korrekt.
Und was mir am Original auch gut gefällt
ist, dass es mehr...
Oh shit.
Bisschen...
Oh ne, ich lad nochmal kurz.
Was wir am Original...
Au, wow.
Jetzt kann ich mal den Satz fertig machen.
Was mir am Original auch gut gefällt ist,
dass man ein bisschen mehr Granaten bekommt
im Vergleich
zu Black Mesa. In Black Mesa bekommt man kaum
Granaten für den Granatwerfer.
Da hat man immer 1, 2
ab und zu mal,
aber man hat kaum
kaum mal 8 Stück im Granatwerfer.
So.
Ich glaube,
jetzt haben wir die meisten hier clear.
Was mich übrigens
extrem beeindruckt hat damals
dieses Level. Ihr müsst euch vorstellen,
das ist 1997, der Max spielt sowas
zum ersten Mal, ja. Ups.
Ich hab damals nicht
gecheckt, dass das hier halt Hintergründe
sind. Ich meine, man denkt sich so,
wie kann man das nicht checken? Ist doch
das ein Bild ist.
Ja, nicht für euch, wenn ihr
das mit 13 das erste Mal spielt, das
1997 ist. Und
ich hab dann tatsächlich damals immer rumgeguckt
so mit dem
Fernglas von der...
von dem Bogen so.
Oh, erkennt man hier irgendwas drauf?
Man erkennt
die Ränder von der Sky...
Das ist ja nicht wirklich Skybok.
Man erkennt die Ränder vom Level, wo
die Textur hier so drübergelegt, wo das Bild drübergelegt
wurde. Ich meine, das Wasser
und so nix bewegt sich halt.
Aber trotzdem, ich
fand's damals geil. So, boah, sieht das
toll aus. Außenlevel und hui.
Und ihr
könnt euch vorstellen, ich hab
Half-Life gespielt
vor Unreal. Und
Unreal war damals
absoluter Wahnsinn, was Außenlevel
anging. Aus heutiger Sicht...
Hat jemand von euch mal diese Castle-Demo
von An...
Die Castle-Demo von Unreal geko...
Aua!
Kennt ihr die... Kennt ihr die Unreal Castle
Demo?
Ich... Ich war so
geflasht damals, als
das erste Mal Unreal die Außenlevel gesehen
hab. Und dann... Und dann auch
spiegelnde Oberflächen und sowas gab's in Half-Life nicht.
By the way, der Raketenwerfer
sieht zwar so aus,
als wäre er gut, Helis
kaputt zu machen. Ist er auch.
Aber ganz im Ernst, das Ding hier
viel besser.
Ich bin übrigens gerade am überlegen,
wie hätte man dann eigentlich
korrekterweise den Heli auf dem
Damm killen sollen?
Ich glaube, man weiß zu dem Zeitpunkt
doch gar nicht, dass die Waffe gut gegen Helis ist.
Warum hab ich eigentlich nur 100 FPS?
Wie kann man das
anlocken?
Glaube gar nicht.
Meinst du, man hätte, glaube ich, einfach durchrennen sollen,
gell? Und sich verstecken sollen
vor dem Heli? Ich glaube, storytechnisch
soll es so sein, dass der Heli vom Damm
der gleiche Heli ist, der einen bis hierhin verfolgt.
Ich hab, ich hab
beide Helis gekillt. Ich glaube,
jetzt, ich glaube,
der Story nach war das hier der Heli
vom Anfang. Wir haben halt gerade drei Helis gekillt
schon.
So nach dem Motto, man sollte bis hierhin fliehen
vor dem Heli. Und hier bekommt
man dann quasi die Waffe, um den Heli zu killen.
Ich glaube so.
Ich hab's, ich hab's nicht korrekt
gespielt.
Ja, aber Unreal fand ich damals so geil.
Von den Außenleveln.
Von der Sicht lachst du dich da natürlich kaputt.
Mit so ein paar eckigen Palmen, so als
Bäume und sowas. Aber war schon...
So, hier ist eine Headcrab drinne.
Ich sag's noch und werd
gehittet, ne? Spawnt die
erst, die spawnt erst, wenn man hinguckt.
Hä?
Gaben. Das hat er sich höchst
persönlich ausgedacht bestimmt.
Dass die erst springt,
wenn man reinguckt. Dass man auch schön erschreckt wird.
Ja, das soll so eine Art
Jumpscare sein. Ja, denke ich auch.
Was kommt denn jetzt?
Hm... Ah!
Das mit den Panzern.
Okay, passt natürlich. Game...
Das ist Five Head Game Logik.
Wir haben einen Raketwerfer bekommen.
Und dementsprechend haben wir selbstverständlich
natürlich jetzt erst Panzer, die uns killen wollen.
Warte mal, komm ich hier
nicht her? Nee, oder?
So, jetzt müssen wir mal gucken,
wie wir das überleben. Wir haben nämlich nicht viel...
Shit.
Alter! Okay.
Ja, gegen den Panzer.
Sehr gute...
Sehr gute Idee. Wie machen wir das jetzt?
Hab ich...
Okay, den Panzer kriegen wir kaputt.
Wir wissen ja, dass solche Dinger auch gegen
Panzer funktionieren.
Hoffe ich mal, dass die auch gegen Panzer funktionieren.
Shit, die funktionieren nicht
gegen Panzer. Okay. Okay, okay.
Pass auf, wir müssen jetzt rennen. Wir müssen uns beeilen.
Nee, nee, nee. Das muss
highly trained professional mäßig laufen.
Fuck, so schon mal nicht.
Highly trained professional.
Alter! So.
Highly trained professional style
läuft das jetzt.
Okay.
Highly trained professional, so macht man das.
Fuck!
Okay. Next.
Okay, das war doch
eigentlich schon ganz, ganz nice. Man kann die,
glaube ich, auch umlaufen und auf der anderen Seite
rausgehen. Das wäre, glaube ich, deutlich...
deutlich
schlauer.
Es wäre, glaube ich, deutlich
schlauer, auf der anderen Seite rauszugehen.
Oh, down? Alle down?
Bam?
Panzer dead?
Nee, Panzer nicht dead. Gegner?
Moin, Sven Fox.
Nee, Seven, Seven
Fox.
No, God!
No,
God, please, no! No!
No!
Fuck!
Gegen die Wand geschossen,
beziehungsweise gegen den, was weiß ich,
komisches...
Dach geballert.
Okay, nochmal. Highly trained professional style.
So,
langsam, langsam haben wir es doch.
Okay, ich glaube, der Panzer ist
gleich down. Jawoll, Panzer
kaputt. Alter,
was ein Messacker hier.
Dead kill.
Bin ich sicher, ob es da
noch was gibt? Nee, alles down.
Nice.
So kann man es auch machen. Ich, beim besten
Willen, ich glaube nicht, dass das der intended
way war, den Fight anzugehen.
Aber,
warum nicht?
Hat jemand zufällig das neue Star Wars
gespielt? Äh, nein.
Ich habe nur gehört, dass es technisch
überhaupt nicht richtig ausgereift sein muss,
dass es überhaupt nicht läuft.
Okay, Feuereffekte check.
Also, ich glaube,
das ist was, was der Mod neu gemacht hat.
Ich glaube, im Original, aber so viel
schlechter sah es im Original
auch nicht aus. Ich meine, so viel schlechter, das sieht schon
ziemlich schlecht aus. So.
Da hinten war noch
eine Heal-Station, wirklich?
Eats.
Die hier, ach stimmt, die habe ich ja
nicht, gar nicht.
Jetzt.
Was denkst du über Diablo 4?
Ich habe es mir noch nicht gekauft.
Also,
noch, ah, guck mal da.
Noch denke ich gar nicht so viel drüber.
Aber was ich bis jetzt gelesen habe, ist, dass anscheinend
Blizzard
es seit langer Zeit mal wieder auf die Reihe bekommen
hat, ein halbwegs gescheites Game zu machen.
Hier ist noch ein Panzer.
Au.
Ey.
Dead.
Richtig, richtig low, low, low
IQ
ähm, LLV
Driver.
Aber das hätten wir in Battlefield 3
besser hingekriegt.
Das war definitiv kein highly
trained Professional.
Nice. Geschafft.
Ui. Ui.
Ladezone, jawoll.
Ey, das ist so krass, wie das lädt mit SSD.
Ich habe das gespielt
1998 oder 1997
und die Ladezeiten zwischen den Leveln
waren auch schon schnell, aber das ist halt
einfach Millisekunde
Ladezeit.
Ey.
Wow.
Warum ist das Viech dead, gell?
Ah, jetzt kommen die
Sniper.
Habe ich das, habe ich
das noch richtig? Ich glaube jetzt kommen die Sniper.
Sniper kommen jetzt.
Pass auf, für 60 no scopes.
Ja.
Sniper.
Guck, der wird jetzt geschneipt gleich.
Ne, der wurde schon. Der wurde schon
geschneipt. Sniper.
Auf ja.
Massive Sniper.
Guck mal, da war er schon. Habt ihr ihn gesehen?
Da ist er drin hier.
Der Sniper.
Okay. Ey.
Ich glaube so ging das nicht.
Aber man kann den hier bestimmt
aufladen.
Ey.
Wie hat man die Snipers nochmal gekillt?
Ich glaube man konnte die Sniper nur
mit einer Granate killen.
Oh Gott.
Alter.
Meine Güte. Granatphysics.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher,
ob das geklappt hat.
Nein.
Konnte man die vielleicht gar nicht killen?
Doch.
Dead. Dead.
Ich muss mir mal eine Granate hochfeuern.
Äh.
Jetzt wird es aber hier.
Von da oben.
Jibader. Krasser Sniper.
Das Spiel passt.
Ja, das passt 10 mal in den
GPU-Ramm. Das stimmt schon.
Ich bin mir nicht mehr ganz sicher, wie man...
Oh.
Ach, das war es jetzt.
Oh nein. War es nicht.
Ich glaube man muss einfach warten, bis es aufhört.
Ja, okay.
Musst du mal eine Granate
hinschmeißen?
Ja. Okay.
Da musst du eine Granate hinschmeißen.
Und jetzt kommt das Lagerhaus
mit den vielen Minen drin.
Äh.
Und irgendwo ist ein Eingang.
Da.
Von wo wird hier gesniped?
Moin.
Kannst du mich heal sohren?
Kannst du mich heilen?
Ja.
Jetzt müssen wir vorsichtig sein.
Pass mal auf.
Jetzt müssen wir aufpassen.
Nein, nein, nein. Du bleibst mal schön hier.
Du bleibst hier stehen.
Pass auf.
Hier ist bestimmt eine Headcrab drin irgendwo.
Ja, okay.
So, jetzt müssen wir aufpassen, weil
für alle, die das Game nicht kennen, wenn ich hier sowas in die Luft spreng, dann passiert folgendes.
Das ganze Lagerhaus fliegt in die Luft.
Man ist dead.
So, ich glaube der Intended Way,
das hier zu lösen ist so.
Das darf man nicht.
Ob man?
Ne, oder?
Headcrab sind hier drinnen nicht sinnvoll.
Nicht sinnvoll.
Also, wir haben es ja letztens im Speedrun gesehen.
Man kann ja von hier irgendwie direkt hier reinspringen.
Wenn man irgendwie
lebensmüde ist. Aber das machen wir nicht.
Wir gehen nach außen rum.
Gucken, dass wir nichts in die Luft sprengen.
Ich glaube das hier können wir kaputt machen.
Nix dran.
Ab hier sieht man übrigens, dass wir keinen Bock mehr hatten
die Kisten einzeln zu machen.
Am Anfang haben die sich auch total viel Mühe
gegeben. So jede Kiste hat
Hitpoints bekommen und alles.
Und hier hängt einfach nur noch alles zusammen.
Einmal draufschlagen, alles kaputt.
So.
Wenn ich richtig liege, kann man
den hier einzeln kaputt machen.
Moin Juicy.
So, hier oben drüber kann man nicht.
Man muss jetzt glaube hoch hier.
Hier drunter. Oh, knapp.
Hier drunter durch, da lang.
Die Headcrab schnell killen.
Drüber jumpen.
Das hier hoch.
Oh.
Close.
So, das hier hoch machen. Und jetzt musste man einfach
nur noch.
Oh.
Uh. Ich dachte ich hab's
gebackt. Ich dachte ich hab's
verbackt. Und irgendwie funktioniert jetzt der
Aufzug nicht. So und der hat
angeblich jetzt einen zweiten Feuermodus
in dem Mod. Also man hat ja schon immer diesen
diesen Feuermodus und den
schnellen Feuermodus.
Und
angeblich
gibt es
dachte ich
eigentlich, dass es für den noch
noch einen dritten Feuermodus
gibt. Ah doch, hier. Habt ihr das gesehen?
Äh.
Das war so eine Biene,
die ist da oben dagegen geflogen, weil das hier
das macht nämlich überhaupt
nichts. Das war irgendeine Biene,
die da oben das kaputt gemacht hat.
Wollen wir mal kurz gucken, ob wir ein bisschen
Shields und Sachen hier drinnen finden.
Nice.
Nehmen wir mal das Teil. Das ist aber eigentlich nur gut, wenn man
sonst.
Okay,
das ist definitiv ein neuer Feuermodus.
Den ich nicht so ganz checke,
wenn ich ehrlich bin. Wie soll das
funktionieren?
Ah, so. Okay, das ist ein
Nahkampfmodus.
Der schon ein bisschen suckt.
Aber es
scheint, okay, das ist das.
Das ist ein neuer Feuermodus, der ist aber
nicht sonderlich geil. Guck mal, der killt
noch nicht mal eine Wache mit einem Schuss.
Der Wachmann muss mal kurz dran glauben.
Oh.
Wait a minute. Wenn man direkt
hittet, platzen die
von den Bienen?
Ah.
Okay, das ist gut zu wissen.
Nice. Okay, das ist,
das gab's im Original auch nicht.
Das haben die sich ausgedacht für den
Mod. Coole Sache.
Nice. Ja, komm mit.
Find ich gut. Da ist
ein Sentry Gun drin.
Wie ich einfach die Position noch weiß nach,
nach 20 Jahren.
What?
Okay, was genau hat mich jetzt gerade in die Luft gesprengt?
Ich war einfach zu schnell.
Loading, loading.
So.
Aliens bashen.
Ist doch gar nichts.
Oh doch, jetzt kommt was.
Übertreib halt.
Au.
Okay, jetzt wird's, jetzt wird's close
mit den Lebenspunkten. Ich glaub, das überleb ich nicht.
Okay, wie krieg ich den Tank kaputt?
Wenn ich Glück habe,
wenn ich viel Glück habe.
Dead kill. Nice.
Okay, wir lassen die sich erstmal
hier oben jetzt kloppen miteinander.
So.
Und tschüss, und tschüss, und tschüss.
Wach man, weg da.
Oh, oh, der kriegt auf den Sack.
Ja, dead.
Das lief nicht so gut.
Ich hab echt
ein Problem. Ich hab kein, ich
hab kein Anti-Tank-Ding
mehr. Okay, wir müssen uns beeilen.
Go, go, go, go, go, go, go.
Fuck. Okay. Ich hab ne Idee.
Wir müssen durch.
Wir müssen durch, bevor
das hier alles kaputt geht.
Genau. Nice, nice, nice, nice.
Sehr gut, sehr gut.
Okay, vielleicht, vielleicht.
Warte mal, wenn ich das safe mach.
Vielleicht haben wir Glück.
Jawoll. Ey.
Ich brauch das gegen den Panzer, Mensch.
Hoffe mal, dass das reicht.
Shit.
Okay, wir haben ein Problem.
Wie kriegen, wie kriegen wir den Panzer kaputt?
Vielleicht, okay, vielleicht müssen wir
einfach nur schnell sein.
Wait a minute. Mit der Shotgun hab ich,
na gut, ich will mich jetzt mal
nicht beschweren.
Ich hab gerade den Panzer mit der
Shotgun in die Luft gesprengt.
Geiler Panzer, oder?
Ich, ich,
ich fürchte, das war nicht der intended
way.
Wir haben halt nur noch 13% Leben jetzt, aber gut.
Alter, ich hab noch,
ich hab halt noch
1% Leben. Da oben ist,
da oben ist ein Schneiber.
What the?
Okay, Schneiber, please sterben.
Nice, okay.
Is that dead? Ich hoffe, der ist dead, der Schneiber.
Wobei, das müssen wir jetzt ein bisschen vorsichtiger
angehen. Wir haben nämlich nur 13,
13 Leben. Achtung.
Schneiber, Schneiber-Action.
Dead?
Oh.
Mensch.
Auf, komm um die Ecke.
Kommt her.
Was geht denn da drinnen
gerade ab?
Was geht da oben gerade ab?
Oh shit, wir haben ein Problem.
Oh, close.
So, ich glaube, hier ist jetzt Leben drinnen.
Muni as
fuck ist hier drinnen.
Ich bräuchte
das hier. So, erstmal alles
durchladen.
Weil hier haben wir jetzt quasi unendlich Muni für alles.
Jetzt müssen wir uns erstmal,
müssen wir uns erstmal aufladen.
So, hier, das da. Nachladen.
Bogen nachladen, Dings nachladen.
So. Ich glaube,
mehr gibt's hier nicht.
Ne, das war's.
Aber dafür sind wir gut ausgerüstet.
Achtung.
Bam. War das wirklich
so klein im...
Was ist da, was ist da los?
War das wirklich so klein im Original?
Ich bilde mir auch ein, dass die Waffenkammer
viel größer war. Und ich bilde
mir auch ein, man musste irgendwie...
Ach nee, hier war das. Ah, das haben
die in Black Mesa verbessert.
Ich glaube, in Black Mesa muss man
dann durch die Waffenkammer
und so durch.
Okay, wenn hier ein Sniper noch drin ist,
bin ich gefickt.
Okay, anscheinend kein Sniper.
Kein Sniper mehr.
So, mal schauen, wie wir
die Soldaten da unten kaputt kriegen.
Normalerweise... Ah, da ist er
doch, da ist er doch. Guck mal, da steht doch einer.
Ich find's ja ein bisschen befremdlich,
dass die Headshots
überleben mittlerweile.
Oder war ich einfach nicht
auf dem Kopf drauf? Kann auch sein.
Dead?
Fragezeichen? Alles dead?
Wie?
Wirklich? Mehr gab's da
nicht? Nice.
Nice Jump
Skills, Max.
Gibt es vielleicht hier irgendwie
ein bisschen...
So ein bisschen...
So ein bisschen Leben vielleicht?
Was ist alles?
Ah, yes, nice.
Okay, dann hat's sich sogar gelohnt, hier hinzugehen.
Stellt sich nur die
Frage, wie kommt man hier rauf, so?
Ah, Half-Life-Logik.
So, und das Ganze
please jetzt ohne...
Nice, ohne Damage zu nehmen. Pog.
Was? Die haben kurz FFA
oben gemacht, ja.
Sah so aus. Ich hab nur noch die Überreste aufgeräumt.
Hallo.
Oh oh.
Nope, lasst mich in Ruhe und tschüss.
Ich bin weg.
Viel zu wenig Leben.
Fuck.
Ich hab
zwölf Leben. Wie stellt ihr euch das denn
vor?
Hallo.
Okay, jetzt kann ich das Vie... Viech,
komm mal her. Ich muss dich in die Luft sprengen.
Oh oh. Nein,
ich bin down. Shit. Ich war zu langsam.
Is this dead?
Jawoll.
So, jetzt muss ich...
Tür
Hut machen.
Oh shit, shit, shit, shit, shit. Max, das war blöd.
So, ich hoffe,
dass alles dead ist.
Weil mit zwölf
Leben komme ich hier nicht so weit. Gibt's hier
nicht irgendwo noch was?
Nein.
Oh, zwölf Leben, Mann.
Highly trained professionals.
Shit.
Okay.
Schön sidestepped.
Ja, ja.
Flieg doch mal da ein bisschen weiter rum.
Ich brauch auf jeden Fall Leben. Leben
und Schild. Jawoll. Perfekt.
So nicht.
Ja gut, das ist easy. Die haben mich
jebaited.
Ich muss einfach warten, bis die hier rankommen.
Ja, das ist easy.
Es ist übrigens nicht gedacht.
Fuck, Mann.
Okay, das muss anders gehen.
Shit. Das funktioniert nicht.
Ich hab zu wenig Leben dafür.
Okay, passt mal auf. Trick 17.
Wir schaffen das.
Wir schaffen das. Easy, easy, easy.
Okay, jetzt ran.
Gib ihm.
Ey, was ist das?
Okay, das ist nix. Das funktioniert so nicht.
Das...
Das funktioniert
so nicht.
Wir müssen Munition verschwenden, Leute.
Es geht nicht anders.
Wir müssen Munition verschwenden.
Ich bin Two-Shot von denen.
Wenn ich jetzt ordentlich spielen würde, wäre halt auch nice.
Können die mal aufhören zu spawnen?
Sag mal.
Sag mal, wie... Okay.
Okay, es ist ja mal gut jetzt.
Sag mal, wie viele
haben wir jetzt jetzt?
Wie viele sind da jetzt gespawnt? 40?
Und jetzt haben wir 7 Leben.
Es wird ja immer besser.
Äh, Frage im Chat
sagt, hi Max.
Würdest du auch auf 3 Tage
die Woche Arbeit gehen, wenn du
50k bekommen würdest?
Wie jetzt?
Du meinst 50k für 3 Tage?
Also, du meinst
jetzt nicht 50k weniger, also 50k...
Keine Ahnung.
50k kommt mal raus, ja.
Weiß aber nicht. Erscheint mir ein bisschen...
Erscheint mir dann vielleicht
doch ein bisschen knapp, aber ja.
Ich mein, ich würd's mir überlegen.
Lass mal überlegen, wie viel
verdien ich eigentlich? Wie viel würde ich
verdienen mit 3 Tagen?
3 Tage sind...
40...
40% Reduktion,
oder?
Nee, doch.
Ich müsste
so 55, 60k
irgendwie in dem Dreh haben mit
3 Tagen.
Also, ja, vielleicht.
Also, da hab ich mir noch keine...
Wie hat
der Krempel nochmal funktioniert?
Da hab ich mir noch keine großen
Gedanken zu gemacht bisher.
Das war für mich jetzt noch nicht zur
Diskussion.
Ähm...
Vielleicht, ja.
Also, wenn's mich... Also, ich würde...
Okay, was jetzt? Alter! Alter, ich hab noch
7! Leute, ich hab noch 7 Leben!
Ich hab noch
7 Leben jetzt. Jetzt macht mal
ein bisschen sanft hier.
Also, ich würde...
Ich würde das... Fuck, ich komm hier nicht ran.
Kann man vielleicht das hier schieben?
Oder kann man...
So kann man machen, ne?
Also, ich würde das vielleicht in Erwägung
ziehen, sollte es
mir irgendwie auf den Sack gehen.
Komm ich denn da dran, Leute? Habt ihr
irgendwie eine schlaue Idee?
Nice, Physix.
Na, ex... Excellent, Leute!
Das ist mal geile Physix
hier. Steuerung
beim Springen mach ich schon, guck.
Reicht nicht. Kommt man nicht
dran.
Ich bin zumindest so blöd. Ich hätte die Kiste
vorher runter schieben müssen, oder?
Leute, ich hätte die Kiste...
Shit, ich kann das nicht mehr lernen.
Ich hätte die Kiste vorher runter schmeißen müssen
und dann wahrscheinlich...
Wie soll ich denn das nächste mit
27 Leben überstehen?
Also nicht das hier.
Jetzt kommt das
gleich, wo ich aus dem Lüftungsschacht
abgeschossen werde. Wie soll ich das
mit 27 Leben...
Leben überleben?
Das ist...
Das wird nix.
Nicht getro...
Nicht getroffen werden
vorher.
So machen wir das.
Was war denn das?
We're just
bashen die jetzt.
Okay, ich hab das
schwerer in Erinnerung jetzt mit dem Lüftungsschacht
hier. Ich dachte eigentlich, da sind jetzt 20 Gegner.
Aber es waren anscheinend
nur zwei. Na gut.
Oh, oh, oh.
Das muss ich ausprobieren, Leute.
Ha!
Wusste ich doch!
Man kommt da durch, wenn man schnell genug
ist.
Es war jetzt ziemlich pepega von mir,
weil ich unsinnig viel Ammo verschwendet
hab. Das muss ich aber trotzdem machen. Ich muss das...
Das find ich geil.
Ich verliere viel zu viel Leben.
Ähm, auf der anderen... Sag mal,
bin ich jetzt locked?
Weil ich hier nicht wegkomme? Oder kann ich das hier einschießen?
Nee, ich bin nicht gelockt.
Auf der anderen Seite
ist der Sinn... Es macht doch überhaupt
keinen Sinn, oder?
Weil...
Weil ich kann doch einfach auch hier lang.
Ja, genau.
Easy.
Ja, dann.
Muss ich die Bühne nur mal runterfahren?
So, wie machen wir die jetzt?
Wie machen wir die jetzt?
Mit dem Bogen am besten.
Was war das? What? Habt ihr das gesehen?
What?
Alter, was zum...
Hey!
Du Cheater,
Alter! Du hast ne Shotgun!
Mit der Shotgun kannst du
überhaupt keine Granaten mehr erschießen.
Okay, jetzt sind wir wieder an der gleichen
Stelle hier. Leute, ich hol mir mal kurz
was zu essen.
Zack! Oh, ich muss mal kurz
anmachen,
damit ich...
Ich hol mir mal kurz was zu essen.
Bin gleich wieder da. Wir spielen das noch weiter.
Ich mach übelst Bock, mal wieder
Half-Life zu spielen. Bin gleich wieder da.
So, da bin ich wieder.
Habt ihr irgendeinen Vorschlag, was wir uns angucken
können, während ich was esse?
Ich hab jetzt... Ich hab übelst Hunger.
Wir spielen gleich weiter.
Lasst mal kurz schauen.
Was haben wir denn hier noch?
Wir können uns mal ein aktuelles Video angucken.
Was gibt's?
Es gibt Reis mit Hackfleisch
und
zwei Stücker Brot dabei.
Was haben wir denn hier?
Chat-GPT for all.
Your own Chat-GPT. Okay, das kommen wir uns morgen
früh angucken. Was verdient ein OP-Assistent?
Also, was haben wir denn hier?
21 Awesome Webvideos.
Fireship!
Wir kommen uns Fireship an.
Fireship macht gute Videos.
Nicht wundern, Half-Life geht gleich weiter.
Jetzt erstmal Essen-Break.
...longer to say WWW
than it does to just say World Wide Web.
And that one little change could add...
Ja, ich versteh... das sind ja auch die Amis,
die WWW sagen.
Die sind ja auch nicht mehr ganz dicht. Wir sagen einfach WWW.
...hundreds of milliseconds to your productivity.
Had I known that 15 years ago,
I'd probably have my own space exploration company by now.
But instead, I'm still just
building crappy websites.
While we've all been distracted by the terrifyingly
overhyped rise of artificial intelligence,
the web platform has landed some game-changing
new features that you probably haven't heard of yet
and will change the way we build websites forever.
And that's not even hyperbole.
The first feature on this list is huge.
The native HTML dialog.
I first mentioned this feature about a year ago,
but now it's fully supported on all major browsers.
And what it does is make it way easier...
Moment, gucken wir mal, ob Safari auch kann.
Kann Safari... okay, krass.
Safari kann ja eigentlich nix sonst.
...about a year ago, but now it's fully supported
on all major browsers.
...and what it does is make it way easier...
Lass mich raten, der letzte Browser war Safari,
der es supportet hat.
...to build your own modal windows.
Das gibt so was!
Man muss jetzt kein JavaScript,
CSS,
overlay Dialog mehr bauen.
Man hat jetzt native Dialog.
Es wird mal Zeit,
dass wir wieder ein bisschen Webentwicklung ausprobieren.
I first mentioned this feature about a year ago,
but now it's fully supported
on all major browsers.
And what it does is make it way easier
to build your own modal windows.
Normally, to build a modal from scratch,
you need a full-screen backdrop,
then a window that sits on top of it,
war es viel schwieriger als es sein sollte. Aber jetzt haben wir den Dialog, der nur ein
regelmäßiges HTML-Element ist, das man durch seine ID referieren kann und ein paar
Javascript-Methoden hat, um es zu zeigen und zu verstecken. Zum Beispiel, um den Modal zu zeigen, können wir
den ShowModal-Method auswählen und es erscheint in der UI mit einem Hintergrund. Der Hintergrund
hat seinen eigenen Pseudo-Element, der mit CSS gestylt werden kann. Wir können dann den Modal
schließen, indem wir entweder eine Form mit einem Dialog-Method darstellen oder
den Titel des Streams auswählen.
Ich skippe das mal kurz. Okay, was kommt als nächstes? Zweitens.
Das werde ich legit nie benutzen.
important feature on this list, even if you never use it. It's basically the successor
to WebGL, allowing browsers and web applications to take advantage of GPUs. It is under an
experimental flag today, but many libraries like BabylonJS fully support it already, and
support for 3JS is underway. And that means 3D-Graphics and games are about to get way
faster on the web. I'm using it right now with BabylonJS, and as you can see, the WebGPU
version is far more majestic. And not just that, but libraries like TensorFlow.js support
it, which means developers will be able to build web apps, where end users can train
machine learning models, without the need to download a bunch of Python libraries or
use a notebook in the cloud. That's pretty cool, but for most web developers, the biggest
challenge is writing good CSS. Next on the list, we have container queries. To build
responsive websites, developers often use media queries, where you apply different styles
to an element based on the size of the site.
The problem is that in many cases, you're not worried about the viewport, but you're
worried about the parent container of an element. And that's always been really hard to deal
with, until now. With container queries, you first create a containment context with
a container-type property. Then from there, you can use the container-at-rule, which can
apply different styles, based on the nearest ancestor container. In addition, there are
a bunch of new units that you can use to create container queries.
Max, sag mal, taugt das was? Ist das ein gutes Feature? Ich hab keinen Plan.
In the past, you might run into situations where you have to actually get the bounding
box from JavaScript, then solve some crazy differential equations to get the div in the
right place. And you'll be happy to know that there's an official Tailwind Container Queries
package that allows you to declare these containers directly in your HTML. Another cool CSS feature
you might not know about is color mix. I've used tools like Sass to mix colors in the
past, but now we can do it natively in CSS. It's a function that takes two color arguments
and mixes them in a specified color space, like in this example if we mix red and black.
Na ja, CryptoMiner gibt's doch schon als JavaScript Library. Ich sag nur die Webseite von Cristiano
Ronaldo, der Monero gemeint hat. Na gut, Fairness Album muss man sagen, wahrscheinlich
hat nicht wirklich Cristiano Ronaldo gemeint, sondern der Admin von seiner Webseite.
Blue in an RGB color space, we get purple as a result. That's not very useful on its own,
but it makes it easier to do effects like this, where I have to mix red and blue together.
Sie haben eine Liste von Items, die rot und weiß zusammenmixen, um einen Gradient-Effekt zu erschaffen, der über mehrere Elemente auftritt.
Aber sprichend von Features von SaaS, ist ein weiterer großer Teil CSS-Nesting.
Ich kann nicht glauben, dass es so lange dauert, aber es ist fast vollständig unterstützt in allen modernen Browsern.
Es ist nur ein ergonomisches...
Warte mal, Safari hat was für Firefox.
Was ist das?
Was ist das? Warum?
Was ist da los?
Das ist eigentlich nicht möglich.
Ich kann nicht glauben, dass es so lange dauert, aber es ist fast vollständig unterstützt in allen modernen Browsern.
Es ist nur ein ergonomisches Feature, das euch ermöglicht, Stile in einem viel mehr präzisen und lesbaren Weg zu schreiben,
indem ihr sie in einem Eltern-Effekt nestet, wie ein Känguru in einem Pouch,
was tausende duplizierte Klassen-Effekte auslöscht.
...Klassen-Effekte aus deinem Code.
Aber ein weiteres sehr interessantes neues Feature ist Color-Fonts,
auch als Chromatic-Fonts genannt, die mehrere Farben benutzen.
Das wichtigste Feature überhaupt.
...inside of a single glyph.
This opens up a whole new world of possibilities,
because now you can customize the entire color palette of a font
and create some crazy effects like 3D-Gradients.
What's cool about this is that they're still interpreted as regular fonts in the browser.
Ich hoffe, ich hab euch denn nicht gerade ins Ohr gerülpst.
Ich hoffe, ich war weit genug weg vom Mikrofon.
...whereas previously, stuff like this would only be possible with your own custom vector graphics.
There are only a few color fonts at the moment,
but it will be interesting to see what else comes out in the future.
But the next thing I want to look at is performance and the new Web Vitals Plugin for Chrome.
You can measure the performance of any website by running a Lighthouse Report,
but the process is kind of slow and cumbersome.
This plugin will console-log performance metrics as you use a website,
and it can pinpoint performance issues like layout shift
and point you to the exact element that's causing the problem.
There's a ton of things to consider when it comes to performance,
and I have a full video on that topic on my second channel if you want to learn more.
But now it's time to talk about some new JavaScript features, like ArrayAt.
If you come from a language like Python,
or most other languages for that matter,
you might find it absurd that to get the last element in a JavaScript array,
you have to take the array length and subtract 1.
You can't just use negative 1 or last.
I'm not surprised, that's JavaScript.
At makes this code obsolete.
Now we can just say at negative 1 to get the last element,
or second to last with negative 2.
That's pretty cool, but deep copy is even more useful.
One thing you'll eventually have to do is copy an object.
In JavaScript, objects are passed by reference,
which means if you assign one to a new variable,
you're still going to reference the same original object.
If you modify a property on B,
it will also modify the property on A,
because they're the same object reference.
Now most of the time, we use object assign or the spread syntax to create a new object,
but the problem here is that it only does a shallow copy,
and that means if an object has any nested objects on it,
those nested objects are not going to be able to be copied.
Objects will still maintain the reference to their original object,
but in many cases, that's not what you want.
And what developers have been doing for years,
is using JSON stringify to turn the object into a string,
and then JSON parse to parse it back into an object.
That's a completely ridiculous hack,
that creates a new object reference in memory.
But I'm happy to report, that life doesn't have to be this way.
There's now a global function called structured clone,
that can clone an object.
Also ehrlich, hätte ich gesehen,
structured clone in JavaScript,
ich hätte nicht gedacht,
dass das was built in ist,
unter dem Namen und so,
sondern irgendwas aus der Library.
Was ist hier los? Wir spielen nicht nach Half-Life weiter.
Ich mach grad Essenspause.
...into a new reference,
making it way easier to transfer data from one object to another.
And that gives us 10 awesome new web features to take advantage of.
But wait, there's more.
Like the transform stream interface
that allows you to pipe one fetch call into another.
Or how about import maps that allow you to...
Moment, Moment, Moment.
...stream interface that allows you to...
Moin, Tassilo.
Model.
Was bin ich hier seh'n grade, was?
...response?
...one fetch call...
...response body pipe through...
...pipe through...
Okay, just JavaScript, Digga.
...into another.
...or import maps that allow you to declare a bunch of JavaScript modules all at once.
And I didn't even mention that there's a TC39 proposal
that will allow you to import JSON directly into a JavaScript file in the future.
Oh, and let's not forget that we also now have individual CSS transform properties,
allowing you to modify scale, translation and rotation more easily.
And we have new trigonomic functions in CSS,
like sine, cosine and tangent,
which is incredibly useful if you have circles in your design.
We also now have a CSS initial letter property,
which you might use to make the first letter in an article bigger.
Cooles Feature. Find ich gut.
...just like in a magazine.
I should also probably mention new viewport units,
designed specifically for mobile,
that can take into account if toolbars are opened or not.
Also, let's not forget focus visible...
Sehr gut, sehr gut.
...that can take into account if toolbars are opened or not.
Also, let's not forget focus visible,
which is a more accessibility-friendly way
to handle focus and form inputs and buttons.
Speaking of focus, there's also now an inert property
that you can use on elements
to show they lack the ability to move or be focused on.
That one's kind of boring,
but a way more exciting experimental technology is the View Transitions API,
which allows developers to create animations between web pages
to make websites behave more like mobile apps
that keep the user in context.
And finally, we have Animation Timeline.
As of today, it's experimental,
but it gives you the ability to control animations
based on the scroll position in the browser.
Ohne Scheiß, Leute,
Browser sind mittlerweile,
und das meine ich ernst, das ist jetzt kein Witz,
nicht mal zur Hälfte,
Browser sind mehr komplex als Betriebssysteme mittlerweile.
Everybody does, but always feels way more complicated than it should be.
And with that, we've looked at 21 new features on the web.
If you knew every single one of them,
congratulations, you just won the grand prize.
One free web development job,
redeemable at the company of your choosing.
Just present the certificate during your interview,
and they should let you write in, no questions asked.
Thanks for watching, and I will see you in the next one.
Verbraucht mehr Rahmen.
Na gut, man kann ja alles haben, gell?
Nice.
Interessant.
Ich hab mein Gehalt in Wien.
Oh, nee.
Zu viel Stonksachen jetzt.
Welche Mittelklasse-Smartphone ist das Beste?
Worst Website-Launch of all time.
They show it was nearly impossible to sign up
for the first several days on the healthcare.gov website.
Haben wir das nicht schon geguckt?
Nee.
Moment.
Das hab ich doppelt offen.
E-Sport, das Entertainment der Zukunft.
Jaja, ey, schreit mir jetzt so rum.
Irgendwas Interessantes, was man sich angucken kann?
Bald ist auch Apple Developer-Konferenz, ne?
Ich glaub, nächste Woche Dienstag oder so.
...website, einfach einen Installer runter, starten, zack,
und schon läuft ein Chat-GPT-Klon auf meinem Rechner,
der nicht mal...
Machen die noch andere Videos?
Außer AI-Themen bei der CT?
Wirst du den Battle-Bit fangen?
Was ist denn ein Final-Play-Test, bevor es Early Access wird, oder wie?
...mit dem Internet verbunden sein muss, also wirklich komplett lokal läuft.
GPT for All heißt das Ganze, Open Source ist es auch,
und die Software lädt sogar für euch die Sprachmodelle runter.
Komplett automatisch.
Laut eines geliebten Google-Dokuments
ist genau sowas für Google die größte Konkurrenz.
Nicht OpenAI und nicht...
Ja, Max, geht mir ähnlich.
Aber ich muss jetzt irgendwas laufen lassen, während ich jetzt...
...was halbwegs Interessantes gefunden habe.
Ich kann jetzt ja nicht 10 Minuten klicken, und dann erst mal spielen wir weiter Half-Life.
...Microsoft, sondern die Open-Source-Gemeinde,
die gerade in einem Wahnsinns-Tempo aufholt.
Ich gucke mir GPT for All und die Open-Source-Sprachmodelle mal genauer an.
Sind die schon vergleichbar mit den kommerziellen?
Sind die überhaupt wirklich Open-Source? Bleibt dran.
Können wir uns später angucken, Max.
Liebe Erkerinnen, liebe Internet-Surfer, herzlich willkommen hier bei...
Du-du-du-du-du-du.
Bin grad fertig erst.
Dieses Video wird gesponsert von...
NordPass.
Ihr kennt das vielleicht.
In eurer Firma müsst ihr ständig irgendwelchen Zugängen und Passwörtern hinterherrennen.
Beziehungsweise, wenn ihr selbst eine Firma habt, ist das alles mit viel Aufwand verbunden.
Was bedeutet das? NordPass?
Ist das der Passwortmanager von NordVPN?
Warum sollte ich um alles in der Welt einen Passwortmanager von NordVPN benutzen?
Bin ich dann...
Bin ich des Wahnsinns, oder was?
Bin ich verrückt?
Gibt schon lange.
Ja, aber ich weiß nicht, warum man sowas benutzen sollte.
Weiß.
Ich hab ein Video gemacht zu ner lokal lauffähigen Text-KI.
Das war aber ein ziemlich frickelig zu installierender Hack namens Dalai.
Vor allem musste man hier manuell mit den mehrere Gigabyte großen Sprachmodell-Dateien herumhantieren.
Inzwischen sind zwei Monate vergangen.
In der hyperbeschleunigten KI-Welt entspricht das ungefähr zwei Normaljahren.
Das ist ein bisschen so wie mit Hundejahren und Menschenjahren.
Kleiner Dad-Joke.
Aber ernsthaft.
Jetzt gibt es GPT for All und ganz viele neue Sprachmodelle.
Und der Unterschied zu Dalai...
Der Unterschied zu Dalai vor zwei Monaten ist immens.
Alleine die Installation.
Einfach den Installer von gpt4all.io herunterladen, installieren, starten und dann in der Software auf Download gehen und...
Jetzt nur noch den Reiß reinhauen und dann geht's weiter.
Man kann hier einfach mehr als zehn Sprachmodelle mit einem Klick herunterladen.
Das Ganze läuft auf Windows, Linux und macOS.
Ja, und die Qualität der Ausgabe ist zumindest bei einigen Sprachmodellen auch deutlich besser als noch bei denen, die von Dalai unterstützt wurden.
Stellt man zum Beispiel eine einfache Sachfrage, wie zum Beispiel, welcher Roman von Thomas Mann spielt auf einem Berg,
dann bekommt man vom zurzeit wohl besten GPT for All Sprachmodell Snoozy die klare Antwort.
Ja, der Zauberberg.
Und wenn man fragt, von wann ist der, erschließt das System auch aus dem Kontext, um was es geht, und spuckt 1924 aus.
Google kann ja auf solche Sachfragen oft nicht konkret antworten, sondern zeigt dann meist nur eine Textstelle aus dem Netz an.
Und vor allem benötigt Google ja auch eine Internetverbindung.
GPT for All nicht.
Das heißt, man kann zum Beispiel auch ein Flugzeug benutzen oder sonst wo.
Andere von GPT for All und den ganzen Sprachmodellen hauen allerdings richtigen Mumpitz raus.
Sehr schön fand ich als auf die Frage, welcher Thomas-Mann-Roman spielt auf einem Berg, die Antwort kam, ja, das ist der Titel des Romans von Weilche im Jahr 1882.
Oder kennt ihr schon die dollste Touristenattraktion in Hannover, Schloss Neuschwanstein?
Tatsächlich machen viele der Sprachmodelle sogar heftige Rechtschreib- und Grammatikfehler.
Das ist mir mit Chat-GPT Bing und Bart nie passiert.
Aber wie gesagt, das Snoozy-Sprachmodell,
und das Vicuna-Modell, beide mit 13 Milliarden Parametern, liefern echt ganz ordentlich Ergebnisse.
Sogar unseren 3003-KI-Benchmark schaffen sie.
Erzähle einen Witz, in dem ein Raspberry Pi, Martin Luther und ein Schokokuchen vorkommen.
Die Geschwindigkeit der Ausgabe ist natürlich sehr stark vom verwendeten Rechner abhängig.
GPT for All nutzt standardmäßig nicht die Grafikeinheit, sondern den AVX2-Befehlssatz der CPU.
Und CPUs ab circa...
Da dreht der Lüfter ordentlich hoch dann.
2014 können das, gibt aber auch eine GPT for All-Version für den älteren AVX, also ohne 2-Befehlssatz.
Sehr schnell lief GPT for All bei meinen Tests auf einem MacBook Pro mit M2 Max,
aber auch auf einem Windows-PC mit AMD 3700X-Prozessor war die Geschwindigkeit okay.
Nur auf einem ziemlich alten PC mit Intel i7-6700K machte das keinen Spaß.
Das sah dann so aus.
Ja, aber wo kommen denn die Sprachmodelle eigentlich her?
Und hier kommt jetzt mal ein kleiner Einschub.
Und keine Angst, das wird nicht so kompliziert.
Wahrscheinlich von GitHub, oder?
Also die Technik von ChatGPT basiert auf sogenannten Large Language Models, LLMs.
Das sind neuronale Netze, in die riesige Textmengen hineingekippt werden.
Das Generieren von einem Sprachmodell nennt sich Pre-Training und das ist ziemlich aufwendig.
Wir sprechen hier von tausenden Profi-GPUs, die wochenlang rechnen und das kann dann schon mal mehrere Millionen Euro kosten.
Man darf sich aber nicht vorstellen, dass da dann einfach ein Chatbot hinten rauspurzelt, denn so ein Large Language Model ist kein Chatbot,
sondern nur die Basis dafür.
Man muss das LLM noch auf den vorgesehenen Einsatzzweck nachtrainieren.
Also zum Beispiel Texte einfach vervollständigen oder Fragen beantworten und letzteres würde man für ein Chatbot machen.
Wenn ihr euch zum Beispiel ChatGPT und Microsoft Bing anguckt, die nutzen beide das nicht offene GPT-4-LLM von OpenAI,
aber fühlen sich in der Praxis ganz unterschiedlich an, eben weil sie unterschiedlich nachtrainiert wurden.
Zu beiden haben wir hier schon Videos gemacht.
Die Grund-LLMs werden manchmal auch Foundation Models genannt.
Ja, weil sie quasi das Fundament sind, die Basis für spätere Anwendungen.
Das Nachtrainieren, um zum Beispiel einen Chatbot zu bekommen, nennt man Fine-Tuning.
Das ist deutlich weniger aufwendig, als das vorangehende Pre-Training.
Um so ein Large Language Model...
Fertig, Essen.
Na ja, so halb.
Letzte muss ich noch 100 Stunden.
Dann geht's weiter.
Ich geh noch mal kurz aufs Klo vorher.
Hierbei lasse ich ein Update von meinem Arch-Level laufen.
Dann spielen wir Half-Life weiter.
Wer jetzt erst dazu gekommen ist, wir sind gerade auf dem Weg zum Lambda-Komplex.
Müssten, glaube ich, auch demnächst da sein und Richtung Xen gehen.
Ja, ihr könnt euch da mal kurz ne Runde Fische angucken.
Und bisschen Musik.
Oh, Excellent.
Bin gleich wieder da.
Geh noch mal kurz aufs Klo.
Ja, hat ein bisschen gedauert.
Ich muss der Katze noch was zu essen geben.
Weiter geht's.
Noch mal ein Update.
Ich kann mir nur kurz ein Update anschmeißen.
Okay, let's go.
Muss ich den Titel wieder ändern.
Half-Life-Mod.
Zack, zack.
Half-Life.
Seid ihr noch am Start?
Oder sind alle abgehauen in der Zwischenzeit?
Game Capture.
Boom.
Da sind wir wieder.
Nice.
Okay.
Na, hier haben sie nicht aufgepasst bei Valve.
Was die Texturen angeht.
Wir sind ein bisschen sehr unglücklich.
Oh.
Wo kommt denn das Viech her?
Ich habe da gefühlt gerade drei Stunden reingeballert mit der Kanone.
Aber nein, es lebt immer noch.
Gut da.
Okay, ich warte jetzt, bis es mir hinterher rennt.
Dann wird es weggeballert.
Aber das ist wahrscheinlich nicht dumm.
Und läuft nicht hinterher.
Komm her.
Ja, komm.
Shit.
Jetzt. Lass mich in Ruhe.
Warum schießt denn das immer noch?
Ich habe keine Leben.
Ich kann da nicht reinrennen.
Okay, nice.
Ich glaube übrigens, dass diese Aliens
am Bauch am verwundbarsten sind.
Und nicht am Kopf.
Pippo fett.
Shit.
Das ist echt echt dumm.
Es ist wirklich dumm.
Das hat sich nicht gerechnet.
Das ist einfach.
Ich kann nicht.
Das ist wirklich nicht.
Okay.
Also es ist nicht.
Ich habe keine Lust auf etwas.
Ein llegarer Mensch hat die Möglichkeit,
etwas verbraten zu können.
Ja, das finde ich auch, also bei Black Mesa bin ich echt so ein bisschen zwiegespalten, was Zen angeht.
Die Zen-Levels sind wirklich sehr hübsch gemacht, vor allem so das erste, so die ersten, die erste Hälfte.
Und sie haben es wirklich sehr viel Mühe gegeben.
Es spielt sich auch ganz anders als die Levels auf der Erde und so.
Aber Black Mesa Zen-Levels sind halt ewig lang.
Du brauchst, um Black Mesa durchzuspielen, keine Ahnung, ich sag jetzt einfach mal irgendwie,
fast nochmal doppelt so lang, also fast nochmal die gleiche Länge des originalen Spiels, bis du durch bist.
Also das zieht sich extrem, also das ist hier nicht so.
Hier flitzt er relativ schnell durch und...
Alter, wie schlecht kann man sein?
Hier flitzt er relativ schnell durch und gut, er ist es geschafft.
So, wo sind wir jetzt hier? Okay, ein bisschen Leben.
Vielleicht schaffe ich es ja mal irgendwann in nächster Zeit wieder 100 Leben zu haben.
Oh.
Bam.
Derdke.
Wie, du lebst noch?
Was ist das hier?
So geht's aber nicht.
Ah, jetzt kommt diese Geschichte.
Leute, ich finde es irritierend, dass die Soldaten nicht mehr One-Hit sind mit dem Crossbow in dem Mod.
Normalerweise, normalerweise sind die egal, wo man hingeschossen hat mit dem Bogen, immer One-Hit.
Auf der anderen Seite ist irgendwie auch ganz sinnvoll.
Weil ich meine, wenn du über zig Kilometer mal einen Pfeil irgendwie in deinen Rucksack bekommst, stirbst du halt davon nicht.
Aber die halten auch zu viel aus, guckt euch das mal an.
Die halten drei Pfeile aus, das ist schon heftig.
Und man hat ja auch nicht so viel Munition für den Bogen.
Wenn man keinen Fall-Damage bekommt durch Kisten, ist es der Weg, dass Half-Life einem sagen will, hier bist du richtig.
Ach ja, das war gerade die Frage, was sage ich zum Unendlich-Leben-Klitsch, das kommt jetzt ja gleich.
Weil wir werden den Unendlich-Leben-Klitsch nicht benutzen und ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass der Unendlich-Leben-Klitsch auch gefixt ist, in der Version.
Weiß das jemand?
Haben die den Unendlich-Leben-Klitsch gefixt an der Tür?
Werden wir gleich sehen.
Hier kann man bestimmt aufs Dach noch.
Hui, jawoll.
Dachstelz. Ja, hab ich schon Damage bekommen.
Hab heute gelesen, Valve hat den Dolphin-Emulator bei Nintendo verfiffen.
Wie? Wie verfiffen?
Irgendwie darf man sich das vorstellen.
Oh shit, da falle ich jedes Mal drauf rein.
Warum macht das so viel Damage?
Normalerweise sollte es kein Damage machen, wenn man im Wasser ist.
Was meinst du mit verfiffen?
Also ich meine, das ist doch ein ganz normales Projekt auf GitHub, oder?
Oder muss man sich vielleicht ducken?
Was ich nicht gemacht habe.
Passt mal auf, wir sind einfach schneller als der Dude.
Wir snipen den jetzt in den Kopf.
Okay, das juckt ja nicht, ob er in den Kopf gesniped wird.
Aber...
Ja, man muss sich ducken, sonst kriegt man Damage.
Ja, und was ist jetzt passiert mit Dolphin?
Müssen die jetzt dicht machen oder so?
Das wäre ja extrem pepega.
Aber es ist glücklicherweise ein Open-Source-Projekt.
Wie, du lebst noch?
Ich hab den Kopf geschossen gerade mit dem Armbrust-Pfeil.
Achso, es sollte ein Steam-Release von Dolphin geben.
Nintendo sagt nein.
Okay, ich vermute mal, das ist keine rechtliche Sache.
Sondern eher so eine...
Wir können auf unserer Plattform machen, was wir wollen.
Weil...
Emulation an sich ist ja illegal.
Aber klar, wenn Valve sagt, gibt's nicht, gibt's nicht.
Es ist halt so.
Kann man sich jetzt drüber aufregen, aber im Endeffekt kannst du nichts machen.
Die können ja auf ihrer Plattform treiben, was sie lustig sind.
Okay, das war komplett Verschwendung von der Kremate.
Aber ich wollte einfach die drei Headcrabs gerade splattern.
It's Half-Life Leiter-Physics.
Leiter-Physics.
Dankeschön, Game.
Schön jeepaded.
Leiter-Physics.
Ja, da geht's dann hier weiter.
War hier neben vielleicht noch was?
Ey, hier kommen wir her.
Ja.
Ja, das siehst du halt.
Wahrscheinlich gehen die zusammen Golf spielen.
Leute von Nintendo.
Leute von Microsoft.
Leute von Valve.
Oder was auch immer man so macht.
In diesen Kreisen.
Und da wird sowas auf dem kleinen Dienstweg geklärt.
Und dann sagt der jeweilige Plattform-Betreiber halt, nö, gibt's nicht.
Und da kannst du halt nichts dagegen machen.
Die können in ihrer Plattform ja im Endeffekt machen, was sie wollen.
Ja, Pech gehabt, ne?
Da hast du gelitten.
Was haben wir denn hier?
Ist der nicht lang?
Leute, wir haben gleich 100% Leben.
Bäm.
Ah, shit.
Knapp.
Close.
Den brauchen wir zum Tür-Aufmachen, vermute ich.
Wir können einfach überprüfen, ob man den Typ zum Tür-Aufmachen braucht.
Ja, man braucht ihn zum Tür-Aufmachen.
Sonst wär das Game jetzt nicht.
Game over gegangen.
Auf, komm mit.
Barney, let's go.
Wow.
Die sind ziemlich tanky, die Viecher.
Ich bilde mir auch einen im Original.
Haben die nicht so viele ausgehalten.
Okay, Barney, einmal öffnen, please.
So, und hier gibt's diesen Bug.
Das machen wir jetzt nicht.
Und wahrscheinlich ist der, wie gesagt, auch gefixt in HM-Mod.
Wenn man sich hier in die Tür klitscht,
kriegt man...
Die Tür macht negativ Schaden.
Und dann hat man endlich Leben, wenn man noch weiter drin steht.
Oh, jetzt kommt das Viech.
Ich erinnere mich.
Jawoll.
Nix wie weg.
Normalerweise wird man jetzt hier verfolgt.
Aber ich bin zu schnell.
Ich tu mal so, als werde ich...
Ich lass mich mal verfolgen, dass es dramatischer wirkt.
Das Viech hat's nicht gecheckt.
Ich war zu schnell.
Komm her.
Her, komm.
Auf.
Oh nein, ich werde verfolgt.
Moin.
Moin, KS.
Au.
Okay, ich war wirklich ein bisschen zu lahm.
Oh shit, das war...
Sehr schlau, Max.
Sehr schlau.
Excellent.
High IQ.
So, jetzt aber.
Auf, komm her.
Ich speichere doch sonst immer alle fünf Meter.
Jetzt habe ich natürlich nicht gespeichert.
Oh, jetzt haben wir's geschafft.
So, jetzt muss man hier rüber.
Ins Wasser.
Oh.
Ja.
Ins Wasser.
Hier hoch.
Und jetzt fällt man erstmal runter, weil man extremely pepega ist.
Und jetzt muss man das Teil kaputtbomben.
Mit irgend so einer komischen Steuerung, die...
Okay, okay.
Moment, wo ist das?
Äh...
Okay, das ist in Black Mesa natürlich deutlich angenehmer.
Das ist in Black Mesa deutlich angenehmer gemacht.
Ich hoffe...
Fuck.
Close.
So, das sollte jetzt hier irgendwo einschlagen.
Okay.
Wow.
Wait a minute.
Seit wann kann das Viech da hoch?
Man muss...
Warte mal.
Man muss das Ding doch gar nicht killen, oder?
Man kann doch einfach auf...
What the?
What?
Alter, was habe ich denn hier für nen...
Für nen krassen Speicher?
Pepega-Speicherpunkt.
Guck mal, es reicht doch, glaube ich, wenn man...
Was?
Ich bin...
Ich bin dead. Oder auch nicht.
Muss man nicht den Master jetzt draufstürzen lassen?
Alter, die...
Die Steuerung macht mich fertig.
Shit, Mann.
Alter, das Viech regt mich auf.
So, komm mal hier rüber.
Komm mal... Nein, nein, nein.
Komm mal hier rüber.
So, komm mal her.
Ja, perfekt. Hier, hier her.
Exzellent.
Du kannst hier doch eh nicht hin.
Genau. Lauf mal schön außen rum.
So, und wenn du außen rum
gelaufen bist...
Halt die Steuerung.
Dann... Schauen wir das hier.
Moment, das ist noch gar nicht offen da hinten.
Warum ist das nicht auf?
Ha! Guck mal, wie einfach
das mein Jeep ist. Wie man's Jeep baiten kann.
Ah, jetzt ist es auf.
Guck mal, guck mal, guck mal, wie einfach man's Jeep baiten kann.
Richtiges PP-Grafik.
Haha.
Aha!
Outplayed!
Wir sind übrigens wieder bei 10% Leben angelangt.
Aber wenn ich mich richtig erinnere,
ich glaube an der Stelle,
jetzt kommt erstmal...
Jetzt kommt diese komische
Sequenz, wo man über die Felsen
springen muss, glaube ich.
Ja, genau.
Die man aber einfach umgehen kann,
wenn man
so springt.
Also normalerweise soll
man jetzt
hier quasi so
so dem ganzen Zeug ausweichen
und dann halt die irgendwie da durchgehen.
So, jetzt fahren wir mal
die Sentry Guns aus.
Oh oh. Blöde Idee,
die Sentry Gun auszufahren.
Ups!
Die Sentry Gun
muss man eigentlich ausfahren,
wenn man die Viecher
hier gespawnt hat.
Auf, komm her.
Herkommen!
Komplett sinnlos, das Viech.
Wir machen die Sentry Gun aus und
der wird einfach mit der Armbrust
gebasht.
Oh, das sind zwei.
Shit.
Wow, close.
Wo ist das Viech? Wo ist das Viech?
Komm her.
Schreckt.
Wow!
Hinter mir ist gerade einfach was gespawnt,
und hat mich instant gebasht.
Schön ins Auge.
Das ging ins Auge.
Haben wir es?
Sehr gut.
So, wir nähern uns.
Nein, nicht wirklich.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, wir nähern uns dem Ende.
Das stimmt überhaupt nicht.
Das ist noch ein ganzes Stück, bis wir hier durch sind.
Wir sind noch nicht mal richtig
jetzt im Lambda-Komplex angelangt.
Wobei doch, ich glaube, offiziell sind wir schon da.
Aber
also das mit den
Teleportern und sowas, das fehlt ja noch alles.
Das dauert, das dauert schon noch ein bisschen.
Ja, macht ihr mal eure komischen Alien-Sachen.
Ich verpiss mich einfach.
Ja, ihr dürft jetzt gerne sterben, Alien-Zeug.
Ja, genau.
Irgendwas passiert, wenn man auf den...
Habe ich das gerade schon?
Ich glaube, ich habe es gerade schon ausgedrückt.
Da ist nichts passiert, wenn man hier drauf gedrückt hat.
Ah, nix.
Oh, schlechte Idee.
Kommt man hier vorbei?
Nein.
Ich glaube, man kann die Dinger ganz gut machen.
Man kann die Dinger ganz gut mit der Brechstange killen.
Irgendjemand von euch,
da der zufälligerweise noch nie Half-Life
gespielt hat?
Also das Original meine ich. Echt?
Ach, Ragman, du hast noch nie gespielt?
Und? Also ich vermute mal,
ihr seid ein bisschen jünger.
Meint ihr, sowas kann man 2023
sich noch geben?
Ich meine, das ist halt schon relativ oldschool.
Man kann die einfach auch so killen.
Gameplay ist wichtiger als
Grafik. Das stimmt.
Kann man sagen. Half-Life kommt irgendwie so aus der Zeit.
Das sind, das sind ja nicht PS1-Grafiks.
PS1-Grafik kann man sich nicht angucken.
Das stimmt.
Aber ich finde Half-Life gerade mit diesen Software-Pixel-Renderer,
also diesen bisschen pixeligen Software-Renderer,
das geht durchaus klar.
Auch optisch ist das, ist das schon noch okay?
Weil das ist jetzt, wow, das ist jetzt nicht so,
dass ich sagen würde, hier ist so quasi
Crysis 4-like.
Okay, ich bin
zu pflege dafür.
Okay, wisst ihr was?
Wir setzen das jetzt mal gegen die ein.
Okay, macht sie blatt.
Ich verpiss mich, bis hier alles weg ist.
Half-Life VR.
Du hast damals keinen vernünftigen PC.
Also ich kann euch sagen,
worauf ich das, auf welchem PC ich das erste Mal
Half-Life gespielt habe. Und zwar war das
ein Pentium 2 400.
Relativ sicher.
Es könnte sein, dass ich auch ein bisschen älteren
probiert habe. Aber ich glaube, das war ein Pentium
2 400, übertaktet auf
450 Megahertz und
eine ATI
3D
Rage Pro, oder wie dieses Ding hieß.
Später
dann mit TNT 1.
Da hatte ich eine Elsa
Eraser TNT 1.
Das war der Shit, Alter.
Da sah ich euch die Grafikkarte.
Also es war
zeitweise die beste Grafikkarte, die man sich
kaufen konnte mit TNT 1.
Nur mit dem Unterschied, dass sie damals
glaube ich 250
wahrscheinlich
schon Euro, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne.
Das war noch vor 2000
Mark wahrscheinlich.
Die hat ja damals glaube ich 250 Mark
oder so gekostet.
Und man hat sich gedacht, Alter.
250 Mark für
eine Grafikkarte. Mensch, ist
das viel. Also,
Half-Life habe ich mit Freunden zusammen
gespielt, da habe ich nicht zugeguckt.
Wo ich, wo ich gerne zugeguckt habe, ist,
äh, also ich war ja schon, also bei,
als Kind so immer der Nintendo-Fanboy.
Ich hatte den Super Nintendo N64
und so Zeug. Äh,
Kollege von mir aus der Schule, äh, Freund
von mir aus der Schule, der hatte
von Sega den Kram. Gut,
der hatte auch einen N64.
Und bei dem habe ich bei den, bei den
Sega-Games immer zugeguckt.
Und wir haben, kennt das
noch jemand? Moment, das muss ich euch mal zeigen.
Ähm,
kennt noch jemand
Dune-Game?
Das erste, das Strategiespiel?
Das hier? Das da?
Dune 2?
Nicht, nicht, nicht
das Buch, das Spiel.
Das war so eines der ersten
Echtzeit-Strategiespiele überhaupt.
Guck mal, da gibt es sogar,
Moment, Remastered?
Ja, so sah das aus.
Du konntest, nein, nein, du konntest nur eins
einzelne Einheiten auswählen,
glaube ich. Ja, ja, ich glaube, ja,
relativ sicher. Also auf der Konsole auf jeden Fall.
Was du machen konntest,
ist, du konntest mit befreundeten
Einheiten,
konntest du auf deine Einheiten
klicken, dann sind die denen gefolgt. Das ging.
Du konntest so Ketten bilden, dass dann
dein einer Panzer dem anderen nachgefahren ist.
So, und das haben wir als erstes
auf,
auf irgendeiner Sega-Konsole gespielt.
Später hatte ich es noch auf einem Amiga.
Und die hatten, die
hatten Sprachausgabe,
die haben, die haben versucht auf, auf,
auf, auf, was war denn das?
Sega Mega Drive damals?
Die haben versucht auf der alten Sega-Konsole
Sprachausgabe zu machen für die,
für die Gebäude und sowas.
Und da haben die versucht in der Sprachausgabe
zu sagen, Construction finished.
Und, und
in Deutsch, in Deutsch haben die dann gesagt,
Konstruktion fertig.
Nur mit dem Unterschied, dass die Sprachausgabe
so schlecht war, dass sich das
eher angehört hat wie
,
was?
Und irgendwann meinte, hat mir
mein Freund aus der Schule erklärt, dass das
heißen soll, Konstruktion fertig.
Ich meine,
es war schon wahrscheinlich für die damalige Zeit
richtig high IQ, dass
die es geschafft haben, auf irgendeiner Sega-Konsole
da überhaupt sowas ähnliches wie
Sprachsamples abzuspielen, aber man hat es halt nicht verstanden.
Warum ist das nicht gestorben?
Ja, das sind so Spiele, wo
ich sagen muss, ich finde die sind nicht so
sonderlich gut gealtert.
Wenn man die heute spielt, dann eins
wie allein höchstens so wegen dem Nostalgie-Faktor.
Also, wenn ich
Echtzeit-Strategiespiele spielen möchte,
oder Strategiespiele, irgendwas, dann
würde ich was anderes als June 2 spielen.
Wer auf Oldschool-Sachen spielt, kann sich
die Command & Conquer oder
Alarmstufe Rot Remakes oder Remasters
angucken, die sind tatsächlich auch
ganz gut.
Fand ich jetzt.
Bin gerade unschlüssig, ob das der Intended Way
war, hier drüber zu hüpfen.
Factorio ist richtig pock. Ah, Factorio,
glaub mir, in Factorio erkennst du ja wenigstens
was.
In Factorio erkennst du, was was ist
und das ist quasi sehr viel
Detail auf engem Raum, in June 2 erkennst du
gar nichts.
Ja, Headcrab, pisst dich alle.
Ist hier ein Fisch drinne?
Oh ja, da ist ein Fisch drin.
Nichts viel weg.
Okay, hier sind
Blutegel drin. Gehts weg? Geht ihr weg?
Alle dead.
Oh shit!
Da wird man ja gegrillt, wenn man da hoch geht.
Au!
Und schon,
schon wieder haben wir keine Leben.
Nice, gut gemacht Max.
Und da ist so ein Fisch drinne.
Oh shit. Okay,
ähm, mal gucken, ob wir schnell sind.
Ja, wir sind schon, nein, nein, nein, nein!
Oh shit.
Wartet mal.
Okay, erstmal
wir killen die Sentrygun.
Und jetzt?
Nein.
Wie jetzt?
Wollt ihr mich veräppeln?
Das hast du überlebt, oder was?
Ja, klar!
She baited.
Ne, okay, das hat er nicht überlebt.
Haha.
Die Fleischkanone hat einen richtig guten dritten Schussmodus.
Ja, habe ich schon gesehen, den hier.
Dann explodieren die Gegner.
Das habe ich ganz am Anfang ausprobiert, als ich die gekriegt habe.
Als ich die gekriegt habe.
So, jetzt müssen wir Panzer killen.
Ahem.
So ein bisschen
erkennt man hier die Call of Duty.
So ein bisschen erkennt man hier Call of Duty raus,
weil in Half-Life war es auch so,
immer wenn Panzer gekommen sind,
und Helis und Sachen,
gab es zufälligerweise
vorher Munition für den Raketenwerfer.
So rein zufällig.
What the fuck?
Oh, der hat es voll in die Fresse gekriegt.
Oh, voll in die Fresse gekriegt.
Panzer?
Jawoll, nice.
So, und jetzt?
Package haben wir nicht vergessen, dass da unten massig Munition für den Panzer liegt.
Wir gehen jetzt hier runter.
Äh, Anti-Panzer Zeug liegt.
Wir gehen jetzt hier runter und sammeln das alles auf,
weil wir vielleicht noch genug haben.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob wir das nicht noch brauchen.
Hast du Not a Hero gespielt?
Chatgear hat mich abgelenkt.
Ähm, sagt mir jetzt gerade nichts.
Ist das was Neues auf Retro gemacht?
Oder irgendwas Neues? Aktuelles?
Warte, muss ich mal nachgucken.
Not a Hero Game.
Nee, das ist irgendwas Neues auf Steam.
Halbwegs Neues.
Nee, kenne ich nicht.
Pixel, Pixelstelz auf Steam.
2016, ja, habe ich gerade gelesen.
Fuck.
Ah, hier sind wir jetzt.
So, aufpassen, dass wir nicht in die
Pfützen hüpfen.
Upp.
Ull.
Oh, no.
Ist hier irgendwas?
No pass.
Okay, ich probiere das jetzt mal aus, Chat.
Chat, weil ihr es seid.
Versuche ich damit jetzt mal einen zu splattern mit dem Ding.
Also wirklich, funktionieren tut das nicht.
Oh, jetzt ist er geplatzt.
Oh, die sind
beide geplatzt.
Nicht schlecht.
Nicht gedacht.
Platzge.
Gibt's hier?
Ah, weiß.
Schild.
Ihr habt hier irgendwelche
so Geheimtipps an so Pixel-
Shooter, also, sagen wir mal so.
Dürfen ruhig modernere Games
sein, halt so mit ein bisschen Retro-Look.
Wo ihr sagt, die sollte man unbedingt mal gespielt
haben, so irgendwas von letzter, von letzten paar Jahren.
Also, mir
fällt
Against, wie ist das? Ne, Amid Evil
fällt mir ein. Das haben wir glaube ich auch mal im Stream
gespielt.
Das
gibt's noch, das neue Warhammer-Game.
Ist auch sehr nice.
Boomer-Shooter-Pixel-Retro-mäßig.
Octopath
Traveler.
Das ist für die
Weeps unter uns. Ja, das wollte ich auch schon
immer mal spielen. Schon lange wollte
ich das spielen. Weil ich mag ja eigentlich
so
ab und zu mal so irgendwie
JRPG angehauchte Sachen.
Aber nachdem ich ja so ein Super-Nintendo-
Kind bin.
Muss man hier die Tür mit aufschießen.
Nachdem ich ja ein Super-Nintendo-Kind bin,
für mich ist Chrono-Trigger immer noch das beste.
Das beste
so
JRPG.
Ey, der Panzer ist ja mal
so mies. Der Panzer ist ja so
schlecht, Alter.
Au. Die LMG
verwenden. Moment, da ist eine LMG drauf.
Ja, keine
Chance. Komm, jetzt sind wir dran.
Ich teste nur noch mal, ob da wirklich eine LMG
ist, die man benutzen kann. Ach, man kann die LMG
benutzen. Easy. Ja, hätte ich das
mal gewusst. Und wir sind wieder
bei 18% Leben.
Wir kommen hier auf keinen grünen
Zweig.
Packen sie schon die Alien-LMGs?
So.
Das ist aber ganz gut, weil hier ist
Munition dafür.
Ich glaube, jetzt kommen wir in Lambda-Komplex rein.
Und jetzt kommt, oh, jetzt kommt
diese ganzen
Teleport-Rätsel-Spielchen
und so. Die fand ich ja
früher, als ich das Game
durchgesuchtet habe, mehrfach
Es gab bestimmt
Jahre, da habe ich das Game gefühlt zweimal im Monat
durchgespielt, ja. Da habe ich irgendwie 20 Mal im Jahr
oder so. Also, wie gesagt, ich habe es total
übertrieben, was Half-Life
Singleplayer-
Kampagne auch anging früher, als
es rausgekommen ist.
Ja, und das war so ein Part, der hat mir damals
auch immer nicht gefallen.
Diese Geschichte mit den Teleporter-
Rätseln, die jetzt gleich kommen.
Wir probieren jetzt mal was aus. Guck mal.
Wir machen jetzt das da.
Hehehe.
Das ist tatsächlich
ganz cool. Eigentlich müssen wir für diese ganzen kleinen
Crap-Mobs-
Monster gar keine
Munition mehr verschwenden.
Die Rätsel wurden in Black Mesa
leider stark vereinfacht. Das stimmt.
Da muss ich aber sagen, das fand ich ein paar
Den fand ich jetzt wiederum nicht schlimm.
Sollte das jetzt
nicht eigentlich anfangen runterzufahren?
Okay.
Half-Life-Logik
Wenn irgendwo was schräg runterfährt,
dann
fahren wir nicht mit runter, sondern warten
bis es runtergefahren ist und stelzen uns
hinterher.
Bei Half-Life-Physics und so, da geht das.
Guckst du, die bessere Variante.
Kann das mal sterben, please?
Nice.
Okay, die
Headcrab will nicht sterben.
Wir sparen mal kurz ein bisschen Munition.
Nice! Cool!
Das klappt ja richtig gut. Au!
Wir haben nicht viel Muni.
Müsste jetzt nicht noch
eigentlich der Raum mit den
Assassins kommen?
Der kommt doch noch komplett, bevor
die Teleporter-Rätsel kommen.
Ach, kommt das jetzt?
Wollte gerade sagen, das muss doch jetzt
irgendwann noch sein, dieser Assassin-Raum.
Oh, hier war was. Irgendeine Headcrab
ist an mir vorbeigesprungen. Ich weiß nicht wo.
Ich spekuliere
ja darauf, dass irgendwo noch ein
bisschen Schild und Leben drin ist.
Aber sieht nicht so aus.
Leider.
Da oben gibt's
noch mal ein bisschen was. Die Handgranaten.
Sehr schön.
Da hängt ja nichts aus.
Das ist hier nur, falls wir
die Armbrust irgendwie verpasst haben.
So.
Wie chibaten wir die Assassins?
Ich würde sagen so.
Oder die Black Ops-Typen.
Das wird spannend.
Die haben ja ein bisschen wenig Leben, ne?
Das ist der Raum. Achtung.
Okay, das ist jetzt schon mal
richtig pepega gewesen.
Ach da! Alter, bin ich blöd, man.
Okay, das müssen wir
anders machen.
Oh shit.
Rekt.
Shit.
Okay, der hat ge...
Okay, lass mal kurz in mich gehen.
Wir nehmen jetzt einfach den Raketenwerfer.
Okay, easy.
Pass mal auf.
Nein!
Nein, dann bleibst du auf.
Easy.
Siehste? Wir müssen da...
Wir müssen da taktisch vorgehen jetzt.
Okay, nice.
Max ans Trinken erinnern. Sehr gute Idee.
Mach ich gleich.
Okay, wo sind die Black Ops-Dinger?
Okay, da waren schon welche.
Die Black Ops-Dinger, die werden wir jetzt einfach mit dem
Raketenwerfer in die Luft sprengen. Easy.
Komm her.
Black Ops-Stells. Jawoll.
Hier ist noch Leben. Sehr gut.
Da oben!
Okay. Jetzt müssen wir aufpassen.
Ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher.
Shit.
Alter, kann man die auch mal treffen?
Okay, wir müssen es anders machen.
Wir müssen jetzt einfach hier schnell...
Oh shit, shit, shit.
Die sind da oben. Das finde ich aber unfair.
Sie heffen den High Ground.
Alter, ich bin fast dead ge...
Shit.
Geh auf, auf, auf, auf, auf.
Please.
Direkt vor der Nase.
Okay.
Wir müssen es so machen. Achtung.
Okay, erster down.
Haben die gerade ernsthaft
die Kisten zerschossen, dass meine Granate
kaputt geht?
Sehe ich das richtig? Sind die so high IQ?
So.
Da leben noch welche.
Gehe ich jetzt mal von aus, oder?
Ja.
Shit.
Nice. Shield. Endlich.
Shield. Shield.
Fuck. Aber da müssen...
Da müssen noch ein paar Assassins leben.
Aber endlich mal wieder ordentliche
Health-Vorrat und... und...
Shield und alles.
Von wo? Von wo? Von wo? Von wo?
Wo?
Moment, habe ich gerade getroffen?
Hab... Chat.
Meint ihr, ich habe getroffen?
Ich habe komplett random in die Richtung geschossen.
Ich glaube, der ist dead.
Oh, oh, oh.
Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment.
Ja, nice. War ein bisschen Glück.
Okay, easy. Easy win.
Nur fünfmal reloaded.
Save, reload, get scammed.
Nix.
Hier ist doch überhaupt nichts mehr.
Hier dürfte doch eigentlich überhaupt nichts mehr sein.
Geschafft.
Extremely faster elevator.
Jetzt benutzen wir wieder das Ding hier, um Ammo zu sparen.
Oh, guck mal, man kann nicht splattern
mit dem Teil.
Pog.
Das gefällt mir. Das haben sie gut gemacht.
Hier.
Das einzuführen.
Das ist ja nicht ein
Sekundärie, was ist denn?
Ein tertiärer Fire-Modus.
Oh.
Alles dead.
So, Armbrust raus.
Gucken, was da noch so ist.
Nix mehr.
Oh, den haben wir
schön gescoped.
Guck mal, one hit.
Die Fässer explodieren.
Ich glaube, diese Fässer nicht, oder?
Ach, die auch.
Ah, ich dachte bloß die roten.
Warte mal.
So viel zu 35 mal durchgespielt.
Nice, wir haben es geschafft.
Okay.
Jetzt kommen diese ganzen...
Miss Freeman.
Jetzt kommen diese ganzen Teleporter-Rätselchen
und Zeug.
Oh, nee. Shit.
Ich dachte, man darf den killen jetzt,
nachdem er aufgemacht hat.
Oder war ich zu schnell?
Weil ich glaube, eigentlich braucht man den Typ nicht mehr.
Vielleicht braucht man den aber noch für mehr gleich.
Nö.
Den braucht man überhaupt nicht.
Stellt euch vor, es ist soweit.
Wir haben ordentlichen Vorrat Lebensenergie und Schild.
Das hat jetzt nur das halbe Playthrough gebraucht.
Moin, Barney.
Ah.
Guck mal, das hat jetzt einen alternativen
Feuermodus.
Guck mal, das hat einen alternativen Feuermodus.
Wow.
Ich weiß nicht, was der Unterschied ist.
Ehrlich gesagt.
Ah. Aber okay.
Ach, man kann die aufladen.
Ich glaub, man kann die bisschen chargen.
Leider
scheren sich
beide, also das Ding
und das Ding, den gleichen Ammo-Typ.
Ich dachte, den Speed
Speedruns wird da gekillt.
Ja, vielleicht habe ich aber nicht das richtige Timing gehabt.
Kann durchaus sein.
Moin, Abriss-Joy.
Ich glaube, hier kommt jetzt gleich...
Ah, wusste ich es doch.
Dass ihr mich jebaitet.
Von hinten, Gachi-Bass.
Ja, und du auch.
What the?
Nein, ich will nicht hochfahren.
Ah, okay.
Wie? Überlebt?
Was ist das?
Da sind noch mehr, ich höre es doch.
Wo sind denn hier noch welche?
Au!
Au und...
Bam!
Wo ist das Viech?
Komm her.
Nicht die Headcrab, das andere Viech.
So, in den Reaktorraum müssen wir noch nicht.
So, wir müssen ein bisschen Munition sparen.
Alter, Leute, ich bin überfordert.
Zu viele Waffen.
Oh, den hat es...
Das war ein unfairer Spawn.
Spawnt direkt hinter einem.
Ballert einem in den Rücken und rennt dann weg.
Ehrenlos hier.
Wie das rumsplattert, ja.
Pass mal auf.
Guck mal, da liegt Gordon Freeman.
Das Brecheisen hat einen neuen Modus.
Man kann jetzt ausholen.
Und wenn man dann an die Models rangeht,
von irgendwelchen Leichen.
Bam!
Das ist in Black Mesa nicht so krass.
Das ist so extrem splattert.
Äh, nicht zugehen.
Was ist hier?
Äh, okay.
Warum schießen die aufeinander?
Sind die blöd?
Anscheinend.
Die sind zerlegt an uns.
Oh, da oben ist das andere Viech.
Jawohl.
Next.
Bam.
Down.
Eins, zwei, drei, vier.
Okay, was hier auffällt ist,
die Räume sind deutlich kleiner
und weniger detailliert als in Black Mesa.
Ich meine, das ist klar damit,
weil ehrlich gesagt zu rechnen.
Das ist ja auch alles ein bisschen neuer
und das andere ist auf Source Engine und sowas.
Aber mir ist es so gar nicht mehr im Kopf geblieben,
wie viel kleiner die Räume sind.
Kann man hier mit irgendwas machen?
Nee.
Die Räume in Black Mesa waren wirklich
eine ganze Ecke größer.
Und auch, und auch.
Mehrschichtiger.
Hört auf, hinter mir zu spawnen.
Alter, wie?
Wo kommt...
Jetzt reicht es mir aber.
Jetzt haben sie mich...
Also mit einem
HP-Punkt
spiele ich jetzt nicht weiter.
Lull.
Die Shotgun ist wirklich sehr random.
Meine Güte, ich stelle mich gerade echt
an wie der letzte Mensch,
als hätte ich das Game noch nie gespielt.
Aber macht ja nichts.
Es gibt ja genug,
gibt ja genug Hitpoints und Sachen hier.
Nicht so als wäre es...
Nee, wir müssen Munition sparen,
Zack.
Jawoll. Beste.
Oh.
Ist es dead?
Ich glaube, es ist dead.
Kann man damit auch die Viecher an der Decke splattern?
Ah, nice.
Nice. Das gefällt mir. Das hat was.
Wir hätten, glaube ich, mehr
unsere...
Ja, das machen wir jetzt auch.
Benutzen sollen wir. Wir kriegen ja
kostenlos Munition.
Eins, zwei, drei, vier, fünf.
Ah, die spawnen mir schon gerade relativ unfair.
Immer im Rücken.
So, wenn ich die richtige Erinnerung habe, man kann, glaube ich, hier durchtauchen.
Nein, kann man nicht.
Äh...
Hat das überhaupt einen Sinn, dass man hier rein kann?
Nee, ne?
Glaube nicht.
Keinen Sinn.
Fuck, ich habe kaum noch Munition.
Wir müssen, glaube ich, ein bisschen mehr
das Teil hier benutzen, um Munition zu sparen.
Nein, die Dinger können ja nix.
Guck.
Zweimal die Bienen drauf geschossen, down.
Moment, hier sind Armbrustpfeile.
Nice. Sehr praktisch.
So, die Reaktorseite haben wir eingestellt.
Das war in Black Mesa ein viel größerer Akt.
Da bist du hier ewig unterwegs, bis du das durch hast.
Uh, uh, uh.
Uh, uh.
Lass mal auf.
Ich brauche etwas Leben.
Das ist...
Haben wir nicht irgendwo ein bisschen...
Haben wir nicht irgendwo noch ein bisschen was vielleicht rumliegen?
So...
Wo ist denn der Reaktor?
Da gab es doch auf jeden Fall Leben.
Ein bisschen hier.
Nee, Moment. Wo ist denn das?
Wo geht es denn hier runter?
Im Reaktorraum gibt es auf jeden Fall Leben.
Im Reaktorraum gibt es auf jeden Fall...
Das weiß ich noch.
Da gab es auf jeden Fall ein bisschen was.
Ähm...
Nice. Danke, Game.
Sehr schön.
GG.
Ich glaube, das ging...
Ich glaube, das ging sogar da oben lang, wo das Viech stand.
Den müssen wir...
Bam.
Dead.
Jawohl.
Ich glaube, hier links.
Ja, Reaktor-Access, genau.
Ja.
Hier gibt es was.
Ja, genau.
Boah.
Ich meine, viel...
Viel mehr Leben gibt es hier nicht mehr.
Ich muss jetzt schon ein bisschen aufpassen.
Hauptsache, war ein Typ auf der Liege gesplattert.
Und so viele Headcrabs, die hier rumrennen...
Das ist auch nicht normal.
Da haben die Modges...
Die Mod-Hersteller auf jeden Fall was dran gemacht.
Shotgun, Shotgun.
Was haben wir hier?
Wow.
Da machen wir jetzt mal hier.
Hier geht es noch gar nicht lang, oder?
Ich bin noch gar nicht fertig mit der anderen Quest.
Dann nennen wir es mal Quest.
Also mit...
Ist ja gut.
Ist, ist, ist ja...
Ruhig.
Ganz, ganz entspannt.
Richt euch ab.
Okay, gut.
So.
Wo muss ich hin?
Ich glaube, hier links jetzt.
Genau.
Hier muss ich lang.
Okay.
So.
Hier muss ich lang.
Wenn es jetzt hier eine Ladezone gibt, bin ich richtig.
Ne, hier war ich ja schon.
Alles gut.
Easy.
So.
Da sind jetzt Gegner dahinter.
Schnappen wir uns mal das Ding.
Und plastern die weg.
Detke.
So muss das sein.
War hier irgendwas drin?
Nein.
Wow.
Ich sehe dich nicht.
Moin.
Hey.
Wie es splattert.
Also die Splatter-Effekte haben sie definitiv im Mod überarbeitet.
Das ist.
Also das ist im Original sind die auch ganz schön auseinandergeplatzt, aber nicht so.
Und das finde ich, das passt richtig gut irgendwie zu dem Game.
Sehr nice.
Headcrab?
Wusste ich es.
Ne, keine Headcrab.
Zombie.
Die haben ein bisschen wenig Munition.
Sag das.
Sag das und haut erstmal Munition raus.
Five Head.
Sterben please.
Ja, klar.
So viel halte ich auch immer aus.
So.
Ich hoffe, es ist alles down.
Weil wir müssen jetzt noch.
Wie ist das zerlegt?
Ey, wir müssen jetzt noch hier die Kühlflüssigkeit oder was das sein soll.
Für den Reaktor einschalten.
Komm her.
Ich muss wo hin.
Ich muss Munition sparen.
Beweg dich mal nicht zu viel.
So, ich glaube, jetzt habe ich alles fertig, was wir brauchen.
Jetzt müssen wir wieder in den Hauptreaktor-Raum gehen.
Dann können wir durchschwimmen.
Und dann kommen diese blöden Schalter-Rätsel…
Nicht Schalter-Rätsel..
Teleporter-Rätsel.
Chat.
Wie lang dauert's denn in Half-Life 1?
Es ist nicht so lang wie in Black Mesa.
Also es sind keine 6 Stunden.
Aber 1-2 Stunden
bist du wahrscheinlich schon beschäftigt, ne?
Eine Stunde?
Ne, das dauert schon ein bisschen länger.
Gucken, ob wir das heute noch hinkriegen.
Äh, Game?
So.
Also wenn ich jetzt richtig liege,
dann
hab ich nicht aufgepasst, aber erstmal möchte ich die Viecher killen.
Oh shit.
Oh nice, mit dem letzten Schuss.
Monka.
X.
So, wenn ich jetzt
das richtig erinnere, dann muss man jetzt hier reinspringen.
Durchtauchen.
Und dann kommen diese ganzen
Teleporter-Dinger.
Ja, genau.
Genau, genau.
Sehr schlau, jetzt nochmal ein bisschen Munition rauszuhauen.
High IQ.
Wow.
Alter, wie viel ist denn da los?
Dead?
Okay, da oben.
Da oben zerlegt es irgendwelche Aliens.
Ja, genau, jetzt kommen diese komischen Laser
und uns
Teleporter-Spielchen,
wo man ein bisschen gucken muss.
Hauptsache, Hauptsache
möglichst schnell durch. Easy.
Nice. Möglichst schnell durch, fast dead.
Dead.
Nice. Sehr gut gemacht, Max.
Hi. Ganz, ganz
schlau.
Das Spiel sieht so alt aus.
Das Spiel ist 25 Jahre alt nun.
Aber mit dem Mod,
sieht es tatsächlich besser aus.
Oh, wie fair.
Eine Headcrab hinter der Tür.
Wir haben vier Leben.
Wenn wir Glück haben,
gibt es jetzt noch ein bisschen Leben.
Sonst sind wir ziemlich
aufgeschmissen.
Supply. Nice game.
Gibt es vielleicht ein bisschen Leben?
Nope.
Okay, wir müssen klettern.
Erstmal Plank. Mir ist das klar.
Ich habe es sogar schon mehrfach durchgespielt.
Oh, hallo.
Wo kommt ihr denn her?
Eins, zwei, drei, vier.
Ich habe das sogar schon
das erste Mal durchgespielt.
Aber es war ganz frisch.
Noch vor dem Steam-Release.
Da hat der Crossbow in Black Mesa
noch so komische
Lava-Pfeile verschossen oder so.
Oder sowas.
Das ist ja mittlerweile in Black Mesa auch nicht mehr so.
In Black Mesa sind es jetzt so Giftspritzen, glaube ich,
die der Bogen verschießt.
So Ampullen.
Ah.
Endlich.
Ich bin nicht sicher,
ob man hier rüber kann.
Man muss hier rüber können.
Aber ich glaube, das ist so eines, der...
Man kommt hier so nicht rüber,
das ist, wo man mit den Teleportern
rein spawnen kann.
Ja.
Dann haben sie in Black Mesa vielleicht...
Ich glaube, da geht es außen rum.
Wo?
Ist außen ja nichts.
Vielleicht haben sie...
Nee.
Half-Life 2...
Genau, genau.
Half-Life 1...
Half-Life 2 sind die mit den leuchtenden Bowls
und das hatten die ursprünglichen Black Mesa auch.
Mr. Freeman?
Mr. Freeman braucht Health.
Wow.
Okay, krass.
Wir sparen jetzt mal ein bisschen Muni.
Guck mal, der hat eine...
Revolver.
Wo spuckt es hier?
Wo?
Hat jemand einen Plan, wo das Viech ist?
Äh, ich bin...
Oh, ich dachte, ich bin stuck.
Ich spare mal ein bisschen Muni.
Dazu muss ich zwar ein bisschen
die Leichen hier splattern, aber gut.
Da geht man.
Ich wusste gar nicht, dass der überhaupt hier ist.
Ich glaube, der ist mir nie aufgefallen.
Ach, da unten sind die Viecher.
Den machen wir mal platt,
weil ich glaube,
wenn wir uns da rein teleportieren,
dann können wir uns nicht mehr verletzen.
Jetzt ist das Viech immer noch da.
Ja, sehr schlau, Max.
What?
Jetzt ernsthaft!
Der fucking Wachmann!
Na gut, ich habe ihm Damage gemacht.
Der taucht schon in voll vielen Levels auf.
Ja, aber ich glaube,
hier in den...
hier in den Teleporter reinlaufen,
habe ich ihn noch nie gesehen.
Ich will das Viech killen, weil ich weiß,
dass wir hier nachher mit dem Teleporter reinkommen.
Ist das mal dead?
Kann das mal sterben?
Please?
Ja, nice, down.
Okay.
Next Shotgun.
Shotgun ist das einzige, wo wir noch ordentlich Ammo haben.
Oh shit!
Ja, Barney, du machst das schon.
Hehe.
Die...
Ey, die...
Die Spawns sind mega unfair gerade.
Barney, warst du das?
Warst du das?
Hat der gerade auf mich geschossen?
Was ist da los?
Ich brauche die Munition.
Ich habe kaum noch...
Ich habe kaum noch Leben.
Wir sind ziemlich...
Ziemlich...
Wir sind ziemlich gefickt gerade,
was die Health-Situation angeht.
Ich glaube, Barney kann eigentlich nichts dafür.
Das war, weil es jetzt Projektile sind.
Das ist in seiner AI nicht drin.
Der denkt halt, dass er hitscan ist.
Nice, sehr gut.
Wir sind so dead.
Okay, jetzt kommt...
Okay, hoffentlich.
Hoffentlich ist hier unten ein bisschen Leben.
Und Muni sparen müssen wir auch.
Nice.
Ammo-Box?
Ist ja nix.
9 und 3.
Ja, geil.
Vielleicht hier?
Das wird jetzt was.
Okay, Glück gehabt.
Glück gehabt.
By the way, ich habe das noch nie gecheckt,
dieses Rätsel, wie das hier funktioniert.
Ja, nice.
Dead girl.
Ich muss, glaube ich, nach da oben gucken.
Ja.
Oh, hi.
Könnt ihr mich heilen?
Kannst du mich heilen?
Excellent.
Nice dudes, oder?
Richtige Ehrenmänner, wie man so schön sagt heute.
Guck mal, wo wir sind.
Auf der anderen Seite.
Die sind so verplatziert, immer, die Headcrabs.
Alter, die sind so verplatziert.
What the fuck, Alter.
Okay, noch mal von vorne das Ganze.
Also.
Zack.
Next.
Ja, sehr schön, sehr schön.
Okay, und jetzt?
Keine Ahnung.
So nicht?
Warte mal, ich bin da zu doof für.
Wo ist der Rest?
Oh, oh, oh.
ist denn der Teleporter da oben? Da! So. Wait a minute, hier geht's raus? Ja, das ist sehr fair,
einfach hinter mir spawnen. Scheiß Viech. Okay, jetzt. Achtung. Hä? Okay, ich bin glaube ich
falsch. Da? Nein? Da. Jetzt. Haha. Und jetzt in das, nee. Musste man jetzt hier reinspringen in
das Kaputten, ne? Nee, man musste gucken, wo das Gans ist. Und dann hat man's geschafft, ne? Alter.
So, jetzt kommt nochmal so ein komisches Ding. Nice. Och Gott, ich bin so unfähig, was das,
was so Hüpfeinlagen angeht.
Wait a. Jump, Jump Skills, ja. Massive Jump Skills. Okay, jetzt geht das auf,
das schon mal richtig. Okay, nice. So, die zwei haben wir, da ist die eins. Da müssen wir jetzt
hin. So, geschafft. Jetzt müssen wir nur noch da reinhüpfen gleich. Übrigens, falls ihr es noch
nicht wusstet, so funktioniert ein Atomkraftwerk. Wenn ihr euch schon immer gefragt habt,
wie das da innen drin aussieht, dann funktioniert das. Quasi Simulator hier. Wo kommt man jetzt hin,
wenn man da reingeht? Wieder runter. Ja, ja, ist klar. Na, da will ich natürlich hin. Sehr schlau.
Dort nen Ladetrigger hinzusetzen. Five Header Time. Ja, das ist sehr fair. Okay, was genau soll ich
dagegen jetzt machen? Das kann doch jetzt nicht euer Ernst sein, dass das so funktionieren soll, oder? Einfach verstecken.
Just hide.
just nicht nicht gameplay einfach einfach umgehen beste idee die sounds
der headcrabs die werde ich auch nicht vergessen also die half life sounds die
werden wir immer im kopf bleiben müssten wir eigentlich ja wir sind
durch also nicht durch das game aber durch diese rätsel stelz dinger jetzt
kommt das jetzt kurz vor serien du hast einen headcraft stofftier ja
doch ich will vielleicht auch mal holen sowas ich habe eine half life kappe
bestellt wenn ihr in frankfurt einem in der half life kappe rum renne nicht ist
immer scheint nicht da sind das was das ist normalerweise nicht hier
was ist das ist normalerweise nicht hier
auch was das was das ist normalerweise nicht hier
Neue Waffen! Pogu, Pogu!
So, dann holen wir uns mal hier wieder volle Muni.
Volle Muni, volle Muni, volle Muni!
Langsprung-Modul brauchen wir noch.
Passende Headcrab-Mütze! Ja, das wäre ganz witzig.
Es ist ziemlich unpredictable, wie es auslöst, aber okay.
So, Boss. Wobei, es gibt keinen Bosskampf so wirklich an der Stelle jetzt.
Es sind einfach nur viele Gegner.
Gucken wir mal, ob wir das hinkriegen.
Hello!
Besser!
Highly trained professional.
Ich will eigentlich longjumpen da oben drauf, aber das geht nicht.
Doch geht alles.
Percent.
Off.
Wie in der IT-Welt.
Ja, auf geht's.
Wo kommen die Viecher jetzt?
Jetzt kommen diese Fliege-Dinger auch noch zum ersten Mal gleich.
Ich glaube, die kamen bisher noch nicht.
Oh!
Ich glaube, wir haben es verkackt.
Nice!
Das ging ja gut.
Das ging ja gut los.
Alter!
Wie soll man die denn killen?
Und das geht ja tatsächlich nur damit.
Oh!
Nice!
Nice Skills!
Sag mal, warum macht denn der Shit kein Damage?
Das Zeug macht überhaupt kein Damage?
Habe ich das Falsche, oder wie?
Okay, das wird jetzt was, Leute.
Ich sag's euch.
Warum macht denn das so wenig Damage?
Das ist nicht normal.
Warum macht der so wenig Damage?
Okay, keine Ahnung, wie man das schaffen soll.
Sehr, sehr nice.
Alter!
What the hell?
Die halten auch so krass aus.
Okay, jetzt.
Die tanken ja richtig und die bashen den Scientist da oben.
Oh, wir haben es gleich, wir haben es gleich.
Oh nein, ich habe geladen.
Ich kann nur...
Ich wollte speichern.
Ich habe geladen, aus Versehen.
Sag mal, warum halten die so viele aus?
Alter, was zum...
Okay, das musst du...
Du musst gleich die ersten irgendwie killen.
Unabhängig...
Ist eigentlich egal, ob sie dir Damage machen.
Du musst sie bashen.
Sonst...
Sonst ist der Typ down.
What the hell, Alter?
What the fuck, Alter?
Okay, ich habe echt keine Ahnung, wie man das schaffen soll.
Der Typ stirbt.
Der Typ...
Alter!
Was will ich...
Was will ich machen?
Ah, hier, hier, hier.
Ich hab noch ne Waffe.
Okay, nice.
Oh, fuck, fuck.
Portal ist da.
Nein, zu spät.
Okay, komm jetzt hier.
Alter.
Ne, Moment, der Typ, der stirbt.
Das Portal geht gar nicht auf.
Ich glaub, das muss ich nochmal neu anfangen,
den Fight.
Ich glaub, den Fight muss ich nochmal neu anfangen.
Äh.
Ja, hab ich schon.
Hab ich nen Save?
Wir haben ne Core-Auto-Save.
Okay.
Ich hab dieses Teil hier.
Der Encoder stirbt gleich?
Wirklich?
Ah, ich bin.
Ah, Leute, ich hab die Bitrate
nicht hochgestellt.
Ähm.
Ich kann die Bitrate ein bisschen hochstellen, fällt mir grad auf.
Sieht das, warte mal, wie schlimm
sieht denn das aus?
Twitch.
Da müsst ihr mich...
Versucht mich mal, mal sowas dran zu erinnern.
Ne, das sieht ganz okay aus.
Aber hier ist der...
Naja, okay.
Es geht eigentlich...
Ich mein, besser...
Ich könnte jetzt den Stream neu starten,
aber ich glaub, das passt schon.
Übrigens, weißt du, was ich jetzt mal mache?
Äh, wir machen
ducken
auf Shift
und alternate
auf Shift.
Auf Shift.
Was?
Nein, nein, nein.
Jump ist Space.
Geht gleich viel besser.
Bitrate kannst du ohne Neustart hochstellen?
Ne, kann ich nicht.
Weil...
Ich NVN verwende.
Geht das?
Wirklich?
Glaube nicht, dass das geht.
Probieren wir mal aus.
Tatsächlich?
Seit wann geht denn das?
Früher musste man immer den Stream neu starten dafür.
Okay, nice.
Ja, mach mal.
Mal gucken.
Mal gucken, was die Waffe überhaupt macht.
Ist das das Ding von Opposing Force?
Sieht ein bisschen aus wie das Teil,
was man in Opposing Force kriegt.
Tüt, tüt, tüt, tüt.
Auf, Kollege.
Okay.
Okay, das ist immer noch brutal, ey.
Almost there.
Almost there, Leute.
Nein, nein, nein.
Lass den Typen in Ruhe.
Oh, ich war zu früh.
Ich kann nicht mehr.
Ich kann nicht mehr zielen, gerade ist zu viel los.
Jetzt.
Oder?
Ist er zu weit?
Not yet.
Nein, lass den Typen in Ruhe.
Nein!
Lass den Typen in Ruhe, Mann, ihr Kackviecher.
Almost there.
Ey, ich weiß nicht mehr, was...
Lass mal kurz überlegen.
Mit welcher Waffe...
Eigentlich...
Ich glaube, ich muss die Dinger nur anschießen.
Lass sie halt nicht auf den Dude gehen.
It's ready?
Oh, Alter.
Alter.
Easy clap.
Easiest clap.
Trotzdem gestorben.
Jetzt ist mir egal, ob der Typ gestorben ist.
Hauptsache, ich bin durch.
So, wie hat das der Speedrun-Dude gemacht?
Irgendwie so.
Der Speedrun-Typ hat das irgendwie...
Keine Ahnung.
Ja, sehr fair, sehr fair.
Dankeschön, dankeschön.
Der Speedrun-Dude hat auch 50.000 Leben.
Ja, gut, stimmt, stimmt, stimmt.
Ja, hast du recht.
Kann man jetzt irgendwie so?
Ja.
Au.
Ich darf nicht so viel Leben...
Wobei, ich habe nicht viel Leben verloren.
Zumal man sich den Sender unten aufladen kann.
Das kenne ich noch.
Nice.
Da hüpft er.
Moin.
Kann man ihn nicht zerstören?
Nee, ganz klar kann man ihn nicht zerstören.
Okay, dann müssen wir so rumgehen.
Hier kann man sich komplett recken drin.
Habe ich mitgenommen, ja.
Hier.
Aber ich habe keine...
Ich habe keine Muni mehr.
Ich habe gedacht, wenn der Typ vorbeirennt,
dann hätte ich ihn rennen lassen.
Aber so?
Nope.
Ich muss Munition sparen.
Das aufmachen.
Jetzt Teleporter.
Irgendwo.
Hier.
Habe ich was vergessen?
Ah, Teleporter.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, das sieht aus wie das...
Da hatte ich doch recht.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, das sieht aus wie das Ding aus The Pausing Force.
Oh, jetzt kommt das Viech.
Oder irgendwie sowas.
Ich habe es ganz gut getroffen, oder?
Ja.
Oh, wenn das mal eine Katze mitkriegt.
Haben wir das Viech jetzt dead?
Ich glaube, wir haben es dead.
Also, erste Phase dead.
Auf die Viecher muss man aufpassen.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Haben wir es?
Ja.
Scheint so.
Wo geht es eigentlich hier unten rum?
Gibt es da irgendwie ein bisschen...
Das Leben abzugreifen wenigstens, ja?
Ja, da muss ich hin.
Ja, hör mal auf, hier doof rumzuhüpfen, Mr. Freeman.
Lass mal kurz das Zeug einsammeln.
Ja, nice.
Kurze Runde im Port chillen.
Den Hell...
Den Heal könnten sie auch schneller machen.
Dann wird auch keiner von mir gestorben.
Badehose.
Nichts Badehose.
Der badet auch in seinem...
Wie nennt sich das eigentlich in Deutsch?
H-A-V-Suit.
Das waren wir jetzt eigentlich überall schon.
Krass, sehr gut gemacht.
Pfeifert.
Next.
Okay, jetzt kommt das Viech.
Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment.
So machen es die Speedrunner doch, oder?
Irgendwie so machen das doch die Speedrun-Dudes.
Warum machen es die Speedrun-Dudes so?
Das funktioniert überhaupt nicht.
Ich mach das...
Ich bin immer noch auf die falsche Stelle, oder?
Okay, keine Ahnung.
Ich bin halt einfach kein krasser Speedrun-Dude.
Ja, äh, äh, äh.
Ey, ey.
Game.
Ich glaube, wir haben das Game geklitscht.
Au.
Äh.
Okay.
GG.
Ey, sowieso funktioniert das auf jeden Fall nicht.
Okay.
Jetzt sind wir tot, oder?
Nicht tot?
Nein.
Dad.
Endlich, Dad-G.
Puh.
So, dieses Level gibt es in Black Mesa gar nicht mehr.
Glaube ich auch nicht remaked.
Zumindest fällt mir keins ein, was vergleichbar ist.
Ja, meins ist ja sehr fair.
Aus irgendwelchen Gründen hat es nicht gereckt.
Was schießt der denn hier auf mich?
What the?
Alter.
Man, von, von...
Okay, mal gucken.
Erst mal kurz schauen, ob ich den gesniped kriege.
Okay, ich weiß nicht, wie ich den gescheit snipen soll.
Die halten ja viel zu viel aus, Mensch.
Das sind jetzt Projektile, die Schüsse, ne?
Da muss man aufpassen.
Okay, das ist voll für den Arsch.
Okay, erst mal heilen, ne Runde.
Okay, wie, wie mach ich die, wie mach ich die Viecher jetzt am besten platt?
Ich mein, das sind...
Das sind Projektile.
Damit ist es ziemlich schwierig, das gerade am Himmel, die Viecher zu hitten.
Guck mal, da ist ein Loch.
Man kann hier die Hälfte vom Level umgehen.
Ich dachte, man muss irgendwie oben lang springen.
Ja, es ist alles jetzt Projektile.
Soweit ich das mitbekommen hab.
Wir müssen, wir müssen definitiv Munition sparen.
Was ist das jetzt hier?
What the?
Alter.
Aber, ne, das ist gut.
Das spielt sich besser als Projektile.
Da macht es auch Sinn zu moven.
Das ist tatsächlich nicht verkehrt.
Okay, und jetzt?
Wo, wo, wo geht hier irgendwas lang?
Hier, hä?
Ja.
Gleich, gleich Gachi-Buzz-Time hier.
Jetzt geht's richtig rein.
Gachi-Buzz.
Vielleicht, vielleicht sind diese Auto-Aim, diese Auto-Aim-Mücken gar nicht schlecht gegen die Viecher.
Aber die Mücken Auto-Aimen nicht da drauf.
Guck mal.
Das interessiert die überhaupt nicht.
Na doch, doch.
Hey, hey, die Mücken sind gar nicht übel.
Dagegen.
Hey, die Mücken sind wirklich nicht schlecht dagegen.
Die machen nur zu wenig Damage.
Und dank der Bewegung von der Plattform treffen die Viecher mich nicht.
Nein!
Oh, hu, hu, hu, hu.
Knappe Sache.
Okay, so funktioniert das schon mal nett.
Sehr gut.
So, ich glaub jetzt ist alles deadge.
Auch das Viech da oben.
Das zieht so Damage.
Ja, jetzt sind wir ja auch in der Alien-Welt.
Da darf das abgespaced.
Alien-mäßig sein.
Äh, bewegt sich das nicht mehr?
Ich fürchte, hier bin ich falsch.
Gut, dass ich gesaved hab.
Muss ich auf dieses Ding da drauf und mich da hinfliegen lassen?
Ich kann mich nicht mehr richtig dran erinnern.
Ich glaube, ich muss...
Ja, ich glaube, ich muss auf das Teil drauf.
Da muss ich da rüber.
Ja, ja, ja, okay, jetzt seh ich's.
Äh, da nicht.
Ja, auf die da.
Ja, sehr schlau, Max.
Nice.
Ah ja, cute play.
Ja, das hat sich jetzt nicht gelohnt.
Komm ich da vielleicht schnell?
Ah, ich dachte, ich komm da ohne zu springen rüber.
Weil wenn ich ohne zu springen rüber komm, dann verliere ich nicht so viel Leben.
Ah, okay, das geht halbwegs.
Bringt mich das nicht auch da hin?
Nee, das bringt mich da nicht hin.
Wie zum...
Nice.
Okay.
Alles klar.
Ja.
Ach, jetzt kommen wir...
Jetzt kommen die Tentakel wieder.
Ah, ja, ja.
Krieg ich die auch damit tot?
Ah, die kann man damit auch exploden.
Ich will eigentlich...
Alter.
Genau das wollte ich eigentlich.
Heal.
Nee, nee, nee, so nicht.
Tü-tü-tü-tü-tü-tü-tü.
Tü-tü-tü-tü-tü-tü-tü-tü-tü-tü-tü.
Tü-tü-tü-tü-tü-tü-tü-tü-tü-tü-tü-tü.
Tü-tü-tü-tü-tü-tü-tü-tü.
Tü-tü-tü-tü-tü-tü-tü.
Okay, wir haben es geschafft.
So, wo sind wir hier denn jetzt?
Uh!
Moin.
War das etwas pepeger von mir, hier reinzugehen?
Okay, ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob ich hier richtig hin bin.
Bin ich hier richtig hin?
Äh, hopp.
Okay, ja, ja, ja, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice.
Hier komme ich her, oder?
Hier hast du halt nicht wirklich orientiert.
Orientierung.
Aber ich glaube, hier kann man runter.
Ja, wenn man das richtig macht.
Jawoll.
C.U.
Oh, oh, schlechte Idee.
Ich muss die Muni mitnehmen.
C.U.
Ich finde es witzig, dass die Mod...
Stimmt.
Stimmt, stimmt, stimmt.
Ich glaube, das war im Original nicht so.
Sind wir schon in der Fabrik?
Ist das schon das letzte Xen-Level?
Ja, ist es.
Guck, aus irgendwelchen Gründen...
...ist das hier so Half-Life-Lore-Tank...
...technisch wohl der Anfang dessen, warum die...
...warum die verbündet sind mit einem in Half-Life 2.
Alter, jetzt ist ja mal gut hier.
Ich habe ja überhaupt nichts mehr am Start.
Man rettet die jetzt irgendwie und dann...
...und dann finden die einen geil in Half-Life 2.
Ey, ich bin...
Ich blicke hier nicht durch, das ist mir zu.
Das ist halt alles Projektil jetzt.
Da muss man...
Ey, die haben aber treffen dürften sie trotzdem.
Oh, geil, fünf Schuss.
Jawoll, easy.
Aber schon krass.
Da kommt ja noch so ein Viech.
Das wird was hier mit...
...mit Projektil...
...Gram.
Wir müssen echt ein bisschen Muni sparen, sonst wird das nix.
Rekt.
Oh, oh.
Sind hier nicht so große Viecher drin normalerweise?
Gucken.
Ne, anscheinend kann man die hier nicht kaputt machen.
Ey, wo kommst du her?
Du warst ja eben noch nicht da.
Geschneibt.
Okay.
Wo geht's lang?
Die Logik in dem ich sein Level ist, das ist nicht unbedingt immer...
Ich versuche den mal mit der Shotgun zu bashen.
Weil ich Muni brauche.
Nee, richtig.
Okay, wie komme ich jetzt hier hoch?
Da geht eine Plattform hoch und runter.
Alles klar, let's go.
Ja, Plattform?
Wir kamen übrigens...
Die Xen-Levels kamen mir deutlich länger vor, als ich das früher gespielt habe.
Wusste gar nicht, dass man so durchrushen kann.
Und die waren ja wirklich nicht lang.
Okay, jetzt muss man glaube ich hier oben drauf.
Oh, oh.
Aha.
Bin mir nicht ganz sicher, von wo hier gerade was kommt.
Ah, Muni.
Nice.
Äh, ging's hier hoch?
Ja.
So, jetzt müssen wir mal die Fliege-Dinger killen.
Sonst wird es mir permanent auf den Sack gehen.
Erwischt.
Weggeschneibt.
Ey.
Ey, du sollst schon oben bleiben.
Kann man jetzt hier drauf?
Okay.
Ob hier geht's lang?
Ja, ja, ja, das sieht gut aus.
Bisschen Leben könnte ich jetzt noch gebrauchen.
Okay.
Ja, bin ich, bin ich.
So, ich glaube, wenn man hier drauf schießt...
Ja, genau.
Da kommen die großen Viechenschüsse.
Das heißt, hier darf man nix Explosives benutzen.
Au.
Jetzt aber, Mensch.
Was ist denn...
Diese Spawns, Alter.
So fair, wie man da in den Rücken gehittert wird.
Und so fair, wie die mit einem Doppelshotgun-Shot ins Gesicht dann sterben.
Klar ist, das ist das Main-Game.
Mehr Main-Game kann das nicht sein.
Das ist die Main-Kampagne.
Aber macht dir nix draus.
Ich erinnere mich da auch nicht mehr so hundertprozentig dran.
Oh, oh.
Also, ich werde auf jeden Fall das nächste Encounter mit der Shotgun machen.
Okay, wo willst du hin?
Weil...
Alter, was die für ein Damage machen.
Ich hab kein Leben mehr.
Alter, das gibt's doch nicht, Mann.
Jetzt aber.
Weil...
Ich hab so wenig Leben.
Und es kommt jetzt bestimmt noch einer.
Ey.
Okay.
So, der da.
Der da.
So, jetzt bleib ich einfach mal hier stehen.
Healthpack vergessen.
Du meinst das hier?
Ah, nice.
Gut.
Gut, dass du's sagst.
Siehste?
So, jetzt haben wir schön alles down, was uns irgendwie in die Quere kommen könnte.
Okay.
So, hier, das Viech müssen wir killen.
Oder kommt man da irgendwie drüber?
Aha.
Hier kommt man durch.
Das war mir nie...
Oh, oh.
Shit.
Nie bekannt, dass man hier durch kann.
Leckt mich einfach.
Und tschüss.
Ich kämpfe einfach nicht gegen euch.
Macht, was ihr wollt.
Macht da eure komischen Flugeinlagen und ballert da irgendwie Auto-Aim-Zeug rum.
Bruder, muss los.
Ich glaube, das ist jetzt wirklich kurz vor Schluss hier.
Ich glaube, das ist wirklich das Letzte.
Wie er sich da rumdreht.
Okay, wir müssen mal kurz gucken, ob wir den...
Oh, shit.
Alter, das wird Projekt...
Okay.
Und die fliegen auch noch so langsam.
Aber immerhin, immerhin treffen die mich nicht.
Nice, erster Down.
Okay, ich muss warten, bis die stehen bleiben.
So kannst du es doch vergessen.
Nice, hit, hit, hit.
Dead, dead.
Naja, bleibt einfach stehen in der Luft und schießt auf mich.
Noch einen gesniped.
Noch einer dead, jawohl.
Und der Typ, der macht richtig krasse Kreiselstelz hier in der Mitte.
Guckt ihn euch an.
So, gut.
Bin nicht ganz sicher, wie ich hier hochkomme eigentlich.
So nicht?
Da, hä?
Hier.
Guckt mal.
War noch Damage, Mann.
Aber hier gibt es ja so Healpods.
Also ich denke mal so in 20 Minuten, 20 Minuten sind wir durch.
Nice.
Man hätte fast denken können, er hat gesehen...
...wie der Pfeil auf ihn zukommt.
Komm, stehen bleiben.
Ne.
Der will nicht.
Bam!
Habt ihr den Scope gesehen?
Duell Rust, one on one.
Ey, letzter Boss ist einfacher.
Da eben dieses komische...
Okay, die müssen stehen bleiben, sonst klappt das mit den Projektilen nicht.
Nice, gesniped.
Und wenn ihr nah dran kommt, ist auch gut.
Weil da kann ich ja auch einfach mit der Shotgun outen.
Jawoll, erwischt.
So, der Weg ist frei.
Ich glaube, mehr kommt dann nicht mehr.
Da müssen wir hin.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Oh, fuck, Mann.
Ich geh mal wieder runter.
Die werden jetzt erst mal von hier gesniped.
Ja, ja.
Ja, aber die können halt auch nix, ne?
Man muss eigentlich nur warten, bis sie stillstehen.
Und dann kannst du easy snipen.
Und dann kann man auch mal ein bisschen weiter gehen.
Alter!
Die Bienen! Das ist ne gute Idee.
Easy, guck.
Bienensniper.
Sehr schön, Max.
Einmal leben wir noch.
Ich glaube, mehr kommt jetzt aber nicht mehr vom Endgegner.
Außer der Typ da. Der ist komplett lost.
Guckt ihn euch an. Komplett durch.
Da gibt's nur eins, Leute.
What the fuck?!
Dafür muss Zeit sein, Leute. Dafür muss Zeit sein.
Oh!
Jetzt können wir noch mal hochfahren und dann ist gut. Dafür musste Zeit sein.
Und 100% Leben zum Boss, nice. Aber ich glaube es gibt vorher noch mal vollen Shields und Ammo und Ammo und sowas.
I am the last.
Oder irgendwie sowas kommt jetzt gleich.
Was überhaupt nicht stimmt, weil sonst würde man sich fragen, wo in Half-Life 2 die ganzen Viecher herkommen.
Du bist normal.
Gab es nicht noch Ammo aufgefüllt oder so?
Gab es da nicht noch irgendwas?
Nee, nee, nee, nee. In Half-Life 2 gibt es auch diese komischen Viecher, die mit den grünen, grünen, die
Warty-Nauts oder so. Die gibt es in Half-Life 2 auch, also kann er ja schon mal gar nicht der letzte sein.
Auf geht's.
Xen ist im Original mega kurz. Ich hatte das auch viel länger im Hinterkopf. Wo ist, wo ist das?
War hier nicht noch irgendwas?
Äh, wie ging das noch mal?
Musste man nicht den hier killen und das war's dann?
Bin gerade ein bisschen lost, aber...
Ach nee, man musste glaube ich noch Damage, Damage aufs Gehirn machen, ne?
Alter.
Ja, schieß mal deine komischen Teleport-Kugeln, alles klar.
Ich habe halt keine Waffen. Gab es hier nicht irgendwo noch Waffen-Refill-Zeug?
Shit, Alter.
Hier gab es doch noch Waffen-Refills irgendwo so für...
Ach, wenn man in den Teleporter reingeht.
Ich habe halt auch... Aha!
Ich glaube Shotgun auf die Range ist halt einfach nicht so geil.
Was ist mit dem...
Ja, ja, das ist der letzte Boss hier.
Okay, so ganz check ich es noch nicht. Ich weiß, dass das Ding eigentlich übelst easy ist.
Man kann im Prinzip hinter dem Felsen stehen bleiben, aber es passiert nichts.
Ich glaube die Anzahl der Dinge um seinen Kopf sind doch wie viel Leben er noch hat, oder?
Oder den Kopf auf, oder?
Shit!
Ah, nee, wir müssen irgendwelche komischen Hüpfdinger machen.
Oh, wie ich diese Sachen mag, ey.
Oh ja, wie geil ich das finde, diese Hüpfdinger.
Beste.
Beste Hüpfstelzdinger überhaupt, ey.
Und jetzt?
Oh, habe ich jetzt ein bisschen Munni?
Irgendwie ein bisschen was Gescheites.
Pistole?
Shotgun?
Ja, nett, wirklich, ne?
Okay, Gehirn, Gehirn, Gehirn.
Okay, so funktioniert das schon mal nett.
Alter!
Ich muss in dein Hirn ballern.
Sehr gut, Max, nice.
Oh, nee, habe ich hier gespeichert zuletzt?
Ey, das ist ja abartig, ey. Easy.
Ich muss jetzt erst mal speichern, wenn ich hier rauskomme.
Wir haben es gleich.
Eigentlich war es das jetzt.
Wenn ich da mal irgendwie an seinen Kopf drankommen würde.
Aber er hat keinen Bock darauf, dass ich an seinen Kopf drankomme.
Es gibt keinen Kopfstelz.
Moment, man kann...
Der hat einen Teleporter in seinem Kopf.
Warum hat der einen Teleporter in seinem Kopf?
Würdest du dir einfach ins Hirn ballern lassen, nur weil deine Schädel decken?
Na klar.
Immer.
Okay, wie geht es hier raus?
Irgendjemand?
High IQ Idee, wie man hier rauskommt?
Ah, man muss da drauf.
Kann es sein, dass man hier drauf stellen muss?
Hier war ich legit in dem Game noch nie.
Ja.
High Speed.
Okay.
So, jetzt lass mich mal in dein Hirn ballern.
Lass mich nur...
Okay, das wird jetzt ein bisschen random, bis das klappt.
Oh, Gott, Alter.
Richtig pfeifert, ja.
Gibt es da irgendeinen Trick, wie man noch höher kommt, oder?
So wird das nichts.
So, komm mal runter.
Richtig pfeifert.
Das sieht wirklich aus, wie das pfeifert, die Mode.
Exakt eins zu eins.
Muss ich da oben irgendwie hin, oder wie ist das?
Ich meine, zumindest regt er nicht.
Nee, ich drück schon.
Ich drück schon immer aufspringen.
Guck hier.
Woi.
Hä?
Der ist gerade gestorben?
Der ist gerade gestorben.
Ich weiß nicht warum.
An was?
Und ich bin auch verreckt.
Aber an was?
Pass mal auf.
Vielleicht komme ich jetzt direkt in den Abspann.
Ich weiß nicht, warum.
An was?
Pass mal auf.
Vielleicht komme ich jetzt direkt in den Abspann.
Mal gucken, ob das geht.
Ich glaube nicht.
Ich glaube nicht, dass ich in den Abspann komme, wenn ich tot bin.
Du hast seinen Weakpoint.
Keine Ahnung.
Ich glaube, einer seiner...
Der Mobs hat da reingeballert irgendwie.
Jetzt aber.
Jawoll.
Easy win.
Geht doch.
Guck, und er ist überhaupt nicht the last.
Der lügt.
Easy win.
Wir haben es geschafft.
Jetzt nicht noch hinten lassen auf den letzten Meter.
Oh.
Gordon Freeman in the flesh.
Or rather in the hazard suit.
I took the liberty of relieving you of your weapons.
Most of them were government property.
As for the suit, I think you've earned it.
So, G-Man, ich hau ab.
C.U.
Ich brauche so eine richtige Pennatonne hier am Start.
Aber man darf nicht weg.
Employer.
Wisst ihr, was ich interessant finde?
Die haben im Abspann Texturen, die sie in keinem anderen Teil des Games verwendet haben.
Was passiert eigentlich?
Ah, man kann doch nicht runterspringen.
Time to juice.
You proved yourself a decisive man, so I don't expect you'll have any trouble deciding what to do.
Chat, ihr dürft deciden.
If you're interested, just step into the portal and I will take that as a yes.
Gehen wir durch die Tür?
Oder sagen wir, fick dich, G-Man.
I can offer you a battle you have no chance of winning.
Annehmen.
... after what you've just survived.
Ich mein, annehmen ist der Canon-Choice quasi.
Time to juice.
Beide Enden.
Okay, ich kann beide Enden zeigen.
Ich zeige euch erst mal das Ende, was passiert, wenn man nichts macht.
It's time to juice.
Congrats, Mr. Freeman.
Guckt euch mal die Gegner im Hintergrund an, die sind einfach nur...
So, das ist das eine Ende.
Wenn man halt nicht durch die Tür geht, das ist halt auch nicht das...
... das...
... in other words, Canon-Cannon-Ende.
It's time to juice.
Und das hier ist halt...
Wisely done, Mr. Freeman.
... das für Half-Life 2.
I will see you up ahead.
Das war's, es gibt kein ewig langes Outro.
Wobei ich das Outro schon damals mega geil fand, dass man sich dann halt nochmal mit dem G-Man rumteleportiert hat und sowas.
Nicest game.
Echt geiles Game.
Also immer noch eines meiner top Lieblingsgames of all time.
Kann man nix sagen.
Gibt andere Games, die ich auch noch mega nice finde und jederzeit mal wieder spielen könnte.
Aber Half-Life 1 dürfte, glaube ich, so mit Secret of Mana zusammen das Game sein, was ich am öftesten durchgespielt hab.
Ja, war seiner Zeit irgendwie...
Ich mein, was heißt, war seiner Zeit voraus?
Kann man so nicht sagen.
Es hat das quasi definiert für Jahrzehnte.
Auch so dieses lineare ineinander übergehen von den Leveln.
Bisschen mehr Storytrip und alles.
Ja, es gab noch Unreal, gab's noch.
Unreal war auch extrem pog.
Ja, Blue Shift und Opposing Force laufen teilweise parallel zum Hauptgame, ja.
Sollte man jetzt nicht eigentlich noch ein bisschen was sehen?
Chat, sollte jetzt nicht eigentlich der Abspann laufen gerade?
Anstatt schwarzer Bildschirm?
Ist das irgendwie ein bisschen defekt, der Abspann?
Der Abspann ist kaputt.
Ich kann springen.
Ja.
Ich glaub, das ist verbuggt, die Credits.
Das war's, Leute.
Haben's geschafft.
Half-Life 1 M-Mod.
Haben die auch Opposing Force vielleicht?
Nee, glaub nicht.
Opposing Force hätt ich auch mal wieder Bock.
Ist auch schon ewig her, wo ich das Addon gespielt hab.
Das Game hatte auch geile Addons.
Dark Star.
Boah, das ist ja ewig her, wo ich das gespielt hab.
Bestimmt schon über 10 Jahre.
Das ist ja ein Custom-Mod.
Uplink ist ja die Demo.
Ja, genau, ich weiß.
Uplink ist die Half-Life 1 Demo.
Das haben sie ja damals aus dem Spiel entfernt und haben so eine Demo draus gemacht.
Muss man sich mal überlegen.
Die haben ernsthaft Content gebaut, der exklusiv für die Demo ist.
Und das spielt sich sogar gut.
Und ist gar nicht so kurz, die Demo.
Aber es ist auch sinnvoll gewesen, nicht die Demo rauszuhauen und dann irgendwie random in Half-Life was zu spielen.
Weil Half-Life hat die Leute halt einfach komplett überrascht.
So vom Ablauf her und was passiert ist.
Ist ja blöd gewesen, in der Demo schon das irgendwie zu spoilern.
Nein.
Keine Ahnung.
Ivan the Spacebiker.
Ja, das war das originale Model für Gordon Freeman.
Guck mal, guck mal.
Ivan the Spacebiker.
So hätte Gordon Freeman oder so sah Gordon Freeman während der Entwicklungszeit aus.
Eigentlich ganz gut, dass es jetzt so ist, wie es ist.
Kannst du das Hackerspiel ablenken?
Ne.
So, jetzt kann ich die Bitrate wieder ändern.
Weil wir sind ja fertig mit Spielen.
Leute, fast 6 Stunden Stream.
Das ist tatsächlich schon lange nicht mehr gewesen.
Schau mal die Black Mesa.
Du meinst Black Mesa selbst oder Mods für Black Mesa?
Black Mesa habe ich schon mehrfach durchgespielt.
Sogar on Stream haben wir es gespielt.
Und ich habe sogar auf YouTube mal ein paar Sachen hochgeladen von als es ganz neu war.
Also die aller allererste Version 2015 oder so.
Warte mal.
2000.
Alter.
2012.
2012 kam da die allererste Version schon raus.
Aber die Version auf Steam ist viel besser.
Was hältst du bisher von Diablo 4?
Noch wenig.
Also ich habe es noch nicht gespielt.
Also ich, alle dem was ich bisher gelesen habe, scheint Blizzard mal wieder ein gescheites
Game auf die Reihe bekommen zu haben.
Seit langer Zeit.
Ob das da wirklich so ist, weiß ich nicht.
Ich bin mir auch nicht sicher, ob ich Bock drauf habe auf Diablo 4.
Ich hätte mehr Bock auf Perseverance.
Ich hätte mehr Bock auf Path of Exile 2, wenn ich ehrlich bin.
Jetzt noch Just Chatting dranhängen.
Ne.
Ich gehe jetzt off.
5 Stunden 40 reicht mir echt.
Okay Leute.
Irgendwelche wichtigen Sachen noch, die wir heute besprechen müssen.
Ansonsten bin ich morgen früh wieder am Start.
Wie gehabt so zwischen 8 und 9.
Also 8.30 bis 9.
Irgendwie in dem Dreh komme ich ja immer on.
Perseverance 2 auch?
Ja klar.
Free to Play.
Ich glaube was anderes.
Wahrscheinlich haben sie es sogar gesagt.
Aber es wäre unsinnig was anderes.
Gut.
Also wir sehen uns Leute.
Bis morgen früh.
Macht's gut.
See you.